[Musique]
[Rires]
bonjour à tous il est 14h30 nous sommes
en direct sur l'antenne de Public Sénat
pour suivre l'examen de la réforme des
retraites ici à la Chambre haute du
Parlement pour l'occasion nous sommes
installés au cœur de la salle des
conférences cette salle qui joue je te
l'hémicycle où se tiennent les débats
autour de cette réforme n’hésitez pas
d'ailleurs à lire les analyses les
articles de la rédaction sur notre site
et je vous donne l'adresse et elle
s'affiche c'est bien sûr public sénat.fr
nos journalistes qui suivent au plus
près l'examen de ce texte heure par
heure alors où en sommes-nous en ce
samedi 14h30 la réforme des retraites
est examinée en séance depuis jeudi
après-midi depuis ce matin les sénateurs
et sénatrices ont commencé l'examen de
l'article 1 sur la suppression des
régimes spéciaux il reste très
précisément à l'heure je vous parlais et
je vérifie le chiffre qui s'actualise
3626 amendements à examiné très
précisément sur l'ensemble de la réforme
d'ici au 12 mars la séance va reprendre
d'un instant à l'autre mais avant cela
on va retrouver notre journaliste
mathiasaraez vous allez m'accompagner
toute cette journée Mathias bonjour à
vous vous êtes un peu nos yeux et nos
oreilles à Public Sénat depuis la
tribune de presse qu'est-ce qui va se
jouer exactement cet après-midi dans
l'émission
on repart sur les mêmes basques ce matin
Quentin après l'article 1 dans sa
globalité les amendements venus de la
gauche vont cet après-midi s'attaquer à
Linéa par alinéa à cette mesure visant à
supprimer les 5 régimes spéciaux la
stratégie de la gauche semble rester la
même faire durer en longueur les débats
une sénatrice socialiste glissait même
peu avant la pause ironiquement vous
voyez on résiste bien avec encore
plusieurs centaines d'amendements à
examiner Quentin l'article 1 n'est pas
encore prêt d'être mise au voie et bien
merci Mathias mais justement ce matin la
gauche a aussi tenté de supprimer
l'intégralité de l'article 1 et pas
seulement des alinéas comme elle va le
faire cet après-midi mais elle n'y est
pas bienvenue cette gauche notoriale et
ça s'est passé dans un vote juste avant
la pause déjeuner et non il n'y ait pas
parvenu avant même l'examen des
amendements cette gauche avait tenté via
une motion de renvoi partielle en
commission de faire tomber l'article 1
sans succès pendant les débats la gauche
a donc dénoncé une mesure régressive
pour les conquis sociaux elle a parlé
elle a dit que ses régimes sociaux
n'étaient pas des privilèges mais tout
simplement des compensations vis-à-vis
de la pénibilité un discours qui n'a pas
trouvé ses cocher la majorité
sénatoriale qui est resté campé sur ses
positions pour elle on parle le bien
d'injustice lié à ces régimes spéciaux
sans surprise la cinquantaine
d'amendements pour supprimer l'article 1
ont été rejetés c'est m'intéresse pour
tous ces explications pour en parler
j'accueillis ici René Paul Savary
bonjour monsieur Savary vous êtes un peu
le chef de fil DLR sur cette réforme
vous êtes le rapporteur de la branche
vieillesse du projet de loi de
financement de sécurité sociale de la
sécurité sociale mais effectivement
quand on le dit avec plus de simplicité
c'est vous êtes encore mieux pour nos
téléspectateurs mais qu'est-ce que vous
vous dites vous quand vous voyez ces
3626 amendements qu'il reste à examiner
et ce rythme assez lent parce qu'il y a
des amendements mais aussi des
explications de vote venu de la gauche
qu'est-ce que ça vous évoque bah écoutez
sur les amendements qui rentrent dans le
texte c'est tout à fait intéressant sauf
que jusqu'à présent nous n'avons vu que
des amendements de suppression alors une
fois qu'on s'est exprimé sur la
suppression il y en a des dizaines et
des dizaines et des dizaines qui sont
tout à fait similaires c'est la raison
pour laquelle le texte effectivement
n'avance pas c'est assez assez
surprenant je dirais comme comme
technique
parlementaire puisque à la fois on nous
demande des explications sur la prise en
compte de la pénibilité comment on écrit
on pense accélérer par exemple les les
les la convergence des régimes spéciaux
tout cela sont c'est dans des articles
plus loin donc
la patience se traduit et ces
contradictoires par nombre
d'affrontements de suppression de
l'article donc il y a pas de rapport
dans tout ça quoi on avait parlé hier
d'obstruction courtoises de la part de
la gauche qui a énormément de prise de
parole mais tout ça sur un ton très
feutré la gauche elle vous accuse vous
aussi de faire l'obstruction par votre
silence vous voulez LR qu'est-ce que
vous lui répondez ben écoutez les je
pense que tous les
sénateurs qui sont exprimés depuis ce
matin absolument parce que tous les
sénateurs qu'ils soient de la majorité
sénatoriale ou de l'opposition sont
impatients de traiter ces problèmes de
régime spéciaux ou d'âge où toutes les
mesures de justice sociale que l'on peut
proposer les uns c'est en faisant des
amendements et des amendements avant d'y
entrer les autres et ben ils attendent
tranquillement qu'on aborde les vrais
sujets et là crois-moi croyez-moi vous
vous les entendre qu'est-ce que ça dit
aussi dans les mots sur ce rythme mais
est-ce que on peut aller vers la fin de
l'examen d'un texte en 11 jours il
soutenez dans cette version il n'a pas
besoin d'aller plus loin c'est ça non
non ça mérite précision effectivement ça
fait quatre ans que la majorité
sénatoriale propose voilà propose un
projet de réforme du système de retraite
à la fois avec les bornes d'âge mais
également ça a toujours été surtout les
amendements une convergence des régimes
spéciaux que propose l'article 1 de
fermer ces régimes spéciaux au nouveau
entrants ça veut dire que ces régimes
spéciaux effectivement seront en voie
d'extinction
beaucoup plus que ça le temps d'avoir
réglé tous ceux qui sont des cotisants
et qui bénéficieront d'une retraite ça
veut dire le temps de la carrière plus
le temps de la retraite plus le temps de
la réversion donc c'est dans 60 à 80 ans
que seront effectivement éteint les
régimes spéciaux donc il y a une marge
de temps tout à fait significatif
d'interview pour qu'on comprenne bien
certains LR mais donc pas au nom de la
Commission mais au nom du groupe
politique LR vont souhaiter aller plus
loin c'est ça et pas forcément lors de
l'examen de l'article 1 mais plus tard
sur l'article 7 que l'on connaît pour
cette mesure d'âge c'est bien ça oui
tout à fait l'article 1 c'est la
fermeture de ces régimes voilà on parle
pas des régimes quand on parle des
régimes et des décalages éventuels d'âge
c'est l'article 7 comme on décale l'âge
de 62 à 64 ans vous voyez c'est le même
article parce que après il faut décliner
le décalage selon les différents régimes
puisqu'ils ils ont déjà anticipé donc on
verra ce débat revenir plus tard dans la
semaine prochaine lorsqu'on sera sur
l'article 7 et c'est là qu'on aura des
amendements DLR pour aller plus loin
voilà les amendements porteront
effectivement sur les décalages d'âge à
savoir si on attend 70 ans ou dans un
délai 10 à 15 ans on fait en sorte que
une égalité de traitement dans toutes
les personnes dans à l'intérieur de ces
régimes spéciaux merci merci René Paul
Savary pour toutes ces explications au
micro de Public Sénat je vous laisse
regagner les mystiques puisque la séance
vient de reprendre nous on va rejoindre
mathiasarayez qui se trouve toujours en
tribune de presse alors Mathias la
séance a repris maintenant derrière vous
dans un contexte un peu particulier la
gauche on l'a dit avec René Paul savéric
qui dénonce le quasi silence de la
droite depuis hier il y a absolument
Quentin je ne pense pas me tromper en
vous disant que depuis ce matin plus de
90 % du temps de parole est à attribué à
la gauche une forme de monopole qui
existe en réalité puisque la droite vous
l'avait dit n'a quasiment pas pris part
au débat ce mutisme de la majorité et
bien il a été dénoncé par le communiste
Pierre Laurent lors d'un rappel au
règlement en disant je cite est-ce que
les LR estime avec leur attitude
participer aux travaux du Sénat en
réalité derrière ce silence se cache une
stratégie celle de ne pas rallonger les
débats c'est ce que dit en tout cas la
gauche une théorie réfutée par les LR et
le premier d'entre eux Bruno Retailleau
qui l'a assuré les LR prendront la
parole lorsqu'ils auront à défendre leur
propre amendements et bien merci et
merci Mathias sarez pour tous ces
explications sans plus attendre on va
rejoindre l'hémicycle du Sénat puisque
effectivement les débats ont repris
c'est la parole est à ani le huero
et pallier les difficultés de
recrutement et c'est l'objectif de cet
amendement
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues c'est
amendement vise à supprimer les alinéas
1 et 2 visant à fermer le régime spécial
des retraites de la RATP en effet les
salariés de la RATP sont soumis à des
suggestions importantes et une
pénibilité particulière les conditions
de travail se dégradent de plus en plus
horaires atypique fréquence des
astreintes
usure physique mais aussi augmentation
des incivilités auxquelles font face les
agents tout cela affecte la condition
physique et mentale et travailleur à
cela s'ajoute le recours désormais
systématique au travail de nuit afin
d'augmenter la productivité qui dégrade
lui aussi les conditions de travail les
conducteurs de bus eux sont confrontés à
la dégradation continue des conditions
de circulation d'anticipation de la
population nouvelle mobilité rendant la
conduite de plus en plus stressante sans
aucune compensation donc ce n'est pas un
luxe de prendre se rend compte ces
divers critères de pénibilité c'est
avant tout une mesure de justice sociale
aussi plutôt que de niveler les droits
des salariés par le bas supprimant ce
régime spécial nous estimons que
l'ensemble des salariés exposés à la
pénibilité doivent partir plus tôt en
retraite les transports franciliens
métro RER comme le bus connaissent
aujourd'hui des sous effectifs de
conducteurs qui ont largement dégradé
les conditions de transport ces derniers
mois pour les habitants de la région
parisienne comment recruter quand on
réduit encore l'attractivité de ces
métiers je vous remercie
chacun
l'amendement 809 monsieur Jacquin
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre un moment vise à ne pas fermer
le régime spécial le retrait de la RATP
les horaires atypiques la fréquence des
astreintes ou encore l'usure physique
affecte la condition physique et mentale
des travailleurs ce n'est pas un luxe
que de prendre en compte divers critères
de pénibilité c'est avant tout une
mesure de justice sociale ainsi plutôt
que de niveler les droits et salariés
par le bas en supprimant les régimes
spéciaux nous estimons au contraire que
l'ensemble des salariés exposés à la
pénibilité doivent partir plutôt à la
retraite les transports franciliens
métro RER comme bus en plus de la
réorganisation totale du fait de
l'ouverture à la concurrence que notre
groupe a combattu lors de l'examen de la
loi d'orientation des mobilités en 2019
ces transports franciliens subissent une
crise majeure de ressources humaines le
mal-être des conducteurs notamment de
bus est immense comme le prouve les
mouvements sociaux particulièrement en
grande couronne dès lors comment penser
arriver à pallier aux problèmes de
recrutement si l'on réduit encore
davantage l'attractivité des métiers
nous ne comprenons pas votre logique
c'est tout le sens du mouvement stop
galère lancé par les associations
d'usagers et parties de gauche
d'Île-de-France cet hiver face à cette
triple
inepsie attaque sociale contre les
travailleurs de la RATP
osent du Pass Navigo baisse des
financements ce n'est pas au travailleur
et aux usagers de payer les pots cassés
d'une mauvaise réforme des retraites et
d'une mauvaise compensation par l'état
des pertes de recettes d'Île-de-France
mobilité du fait de la crise sanitaire
comme des mauvais calculs en vue du
Grand Paris Express enfin le
gouvernement et la majorité sénatoriale
loin de cesse de crier à l'injustice
contre la situation qui prévoit en
Île-de-France et dans les autres réseaux
de transport en commun dans le pays mais
pourquoi donc toujours vouloir niveler
les régimes vers le bas vous voulez
supprimer le régime spécial de la RATP
en conséquence de l'ouverture à la
concurrence que vous avez voté la
majorité
sénatoriale vous étiez alors moins
silencieux comme je vous l'ai dit allez
faire un tour un soir en
Seine-Saint-Denis par exemple en
deuxième couronne pour conclure qu'un
conducteur de bus et on en reparlera
monsieur le Président rénal
et oui
pour vous ça va bien vite alors je vais
parler doucement
bon
donc cet amendement
à ne pas fermer le régime spécial de
retraite de la RATP bon c'est bien que
les horaires atypiques la fréquence des
astreintes ou encore l'usure physique
affectent la condition physique et
mentale de travailleurs ce n'est pas un
luxe que de prendre en compte divers
critères de pénibilité et effectivement
dans les critères de pénibilité je vous
rappelle que
ceci en réalité ne concerne que très peu
de gens au sein de la RATP moins de 5%
des personnes sont concernées en réalité
par l'ouverture des droits 10 ans avant
les salariés du régime général donc très
très peu de salariés concernés et ceux
qui ont les métiers les plus les plus
pénibles les mesures qui sont prévues
d'ailleurs suite à la suppression des
régimes spéciaux sont insuffisants en
effet l'extension des régimes spéciaux a
pour but de supprimer tous les
dispositifs de départ anticipés pour les
remplacer par le compte de prévention la
C2P donc nous nous étonnons pas qu'il y
ait un mouvement de refus de ces de ce
texte et en tout cas pour notre part et
pour ma part je refuse effectivement
cette amendements ces alinéas et je me
propose donc de fermer ce régime spécial
monsieur Houlgate pour le monde 1061
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
en 2024 et c'est déjà été mentionné la
France accueillera les Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques ce sont des millions de
personnes qu'il faudra transporter en
région parisienne la question des
transports est sans doute le point clé
de la réussite de ces Jeux Olympiques et
sera déterminante pour l'image de la
France à l'étranger or nous pouvons être
raisonnablement inquiet on voit
actuellement la tension sur le planning
de réalisation des infrastructures que
ce soit au niveau des travaux à
effectuer ou de leur financement qui
n'est pas encore totalement bouclée pour
relever ce défi la RATP lance en ce qui
la concerne le recrutement de
2700 chauffeurs de bus et de 400 agents
de maintenance soit plus de 3100
recrutements
pour voir en jetant le discrédit sur les
agents de la RATP qui seraient des
privilégiés et en fermant à compter du
1er septembre prochain pour les
nouvelles embauches vous compliquez la
tâche de Jean Castex pour mener à bien
son recrutement alors je sais je sais
que l'ancien Premier ministre
de avec bonhomy et succès le salon de
l'agriculture mais ce n'est pas une
raison pour lui mettre des bâtons dans
les roues d'autre part la fermeture du
régime spécial des agents de la RATP
comment on le sait est un artifice au
pire un appât pour se concilier une
soi-disant opinion publique et
s'octroyer lui sans l'octroyer les
faveurs pour faire passer une réforme
qui en fait n'est que brutale et surtout
pas nécessaire mais si Monsieur Éblé
président merci beaucoup
mes chers collègues vous n'ignorez pas
que les horaires atypiques la fréquence
des astres
l'usure physique a faite des Ormes
fortement la condition physique et
mentale des travailleurs c'est
singulièrement vrai en matière de
transport ce n'est pas un luxe que de
prendre en compte divers critères de
pénibilité c'est avant tout une mesure
de justice sociale ainsi plutôt que de
niveler les droits des salariés par le
bas en supprimant les régimes spéciaux
nous estimons au contraire pour notre
part que l'ensemble des salariés exposés
à des pénibilités élevées doivent
bénéficier de conditions favorables de
départ à la retraite en ce qui concerne
les transports franciliens
singulièrement puisque c'est ce qui
concerne au plus la RATP qu'il s'agit du
métro du RER des bus ils connaissent
aujourd'hui et singulièrement depuis la
crise de la pandémie du covid des
sous-effectifs de conducteur qui ont
largement dégradé les conditions de
transport ces dernières mois donc cette
question est pas seulement celle de la
protection des salariés mais aussi des
usagers pour les habitants de la région
parisienne et singulièrement pour ceux
de la grande couronne que je côtoie
personnellement
chaque jour comment recruter quand on
réduit encore l'attractivité des métiers
il y a là une véritable question qui
doit nous préoccuper et donc nous
proposons je propose par cet amendement
de ne pas fermer le régime spécial de
retraite de la RATP mais bien au
contraire de prendre en considération
les spécificités particulières de ce
métier l'adaptation de nos
réglementations et de nos législations à
l'espèce à des conditions particulières
c'est juste l'exigence de notre travail
de parlementaire on ne peut pas être
dans une uniformisation il faut donc
tenir compte de ces règles particulières
et en l'occurrence ne pas faire
disparaître ce régime spécial madame
Lubin
merci monsieur le Président moi je
reviendrai sur sur le contrat sur le
contrat qui a été passé entre les agents
de la RATP et leur employeur
puisqu'effectivement on sait que il peut
nous arriver de choisir certaines
professions en fonction de la très qu'on
a pour un métier certes aussi en
fonction de l'attrait que peut avoir
l'organisme qui qui vous emploie et sur
des métiers qui sont quand même
compliqués comme conduire un bus à Paris
ou le métro quand même
dire passer sa journée passer je ne sais
combien d'heures ils font d'affilée dans
des tunnels du métro pour conduire rame
de métro on peut pas dire que ce soit
quand même quelque chose de
particulièrement
enrichissant sur un certain un certain
nombre de de points de vue donc on peut
considérer que l'un des attraits de ce
métier ça soit justement le fait que
cette difficulté cette non richesse
quelque part soit qu'on pensait par un
départ à la retraite qui puisse être un
petit peu plus tôt que les autres je
voudrais dire aussi que nous focalisons
sur ce qui est prévu actuellement c'est
à dire un départ un départ à 50 ans mais
nous avons bien entendu lorsque nous
avons auditionné le directeur général
que par pas 52 ans sont beaucoup plus
près de 56 57 ans sur les carrières
actives que de 52 ans donc et ça faisait
sourire nos collègues ce matin mais
c'est vrai que plusieurs de mes
collègues ont relevé le fait que c'est
un métier qui perd en attractivité comme
d'autres d'ailleurs en ce moment mais
celui-là particulièrement et que ce
changement pourrait quand même comment
dire
accentuer le manque de séduction de ces
métiers à l'avenir voilà monsieur le
président
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre il s'agit par cet amendement de
maintenir le régime spécial des
retraites à la RATP de renforcer
l'attractivité mais aussi et surtout de
tenir compte des critères de pénibilité
utilité face aux besoins réels de ce
secteur de favoriser le transport
collectif d'anticiper les Jeux
olympiques de 2024 on en a déjà parlé
mais c'est important de favoriser les
mobilités douces
des besoins réels et pour tenir
également compte du réchauffement
climatique il faut également monsieur le
ministre que vous puissiez favoriser
l'emploi dans ce secteur qui peine à
qui peine vraiment à trouver des
personnes ressources suffisantes parce
que ce n'est pas attractif il y a de
grands besoins il faut faire bénéficier
aux salariés
une façon digne et surtout important
pour que ces personnes aient des
retraites dignes et favoriser le
transport utile pour nos concitoyens
merci Monsieur Montauger
oui monsieur le Président chers
collègues monsieur le ministre donc la
suppression de du régime de la RATP
c'est une attaque en règle une de plus
contre nos services publics les agents
de la RATP ça a été dit des livres
quotidiens un service absolument
indispensable à des millions de
Franciliens et ce service faute de
moyens suffisant parce que c'est aussi
de ça dont il s'agit père de ses
capacités à répondre aux besoins des
usagers c'est indiscutable en plus d'une
gestion tout aussi discutable vous
voulez donc à moins de rire l'intérêt
que pourrait trouver les candidats
potentiels à cette grande entreprise à
l'arrêt RATP les possibilités de départ
anticipées bénéficient à ceux qui font
vivre ce service public essentiel donc
des conducteurs des agents de station du
personnel chargé de la maintenance des
voix etc les horaires sont difficiles
les astreintes ou l'usure physique
pèsent sur la santé
et psychique des salariés dans ce
contexte un régime spécial peut aussi
être considéré non seulement comme
normal mais aussi comme un atout à
préserver c'est mon avis vous raisonnez
en réalité à l'envers ce sont tous les
métiers pénibles qui devraient être
mieux protégé plutôt que de défaire les
derniers protections qui en préservent
encore l'attractivité le régime spécial
de la LP de la RATP comme les autres
régimes spéciaux doit pour ces raisons
être préservé et je m'opposerai nous
nous opposerons à cette suppression
madame Préville merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues cet amendement vise à ne pas
fermer le régime spécial de retraite de
la RATP effectivement les conditions de
travail n'ont guère changé au sein de la
RATP toujours des horaires atypiques
toujours des la fréquence d'astreinte du
travail de nuit des amplitudes
d'horaires
de l'usure physique qui affecte les
conditions physiques et mentales des
travailleurs ça n'est pas un régime
privilégié c'est juste une mesure de
justice sociale ainsi plutôt que de
niveler les droits des salariés par le
bas toujours en supprimant ces régimes
spéciaux l'ensemble des salariés au
contraire doit pouvoir bénéficier d'un
départ plus tôt à la retraite je citerai
en cela pierre aux envallons dans un
article paru cette semaine dans le 1 qui
évoque le sentiment d'une raie qu'une
règle générale écrase la réalité
particulière de chacun et la réalité
particulière de chacun qui est vécu par
les salariés de la RATP n'est pas celle
d'un régime usurpé d'un régime favorisé
mais au contraire celui d'une
compensation par rapport à une vie au
travail particulièrement dure c'était la
règle du jeu d'autre part les transports
franciliens métro RER bus connaisse et
sous-effectifs de conducteurs notamment
et vont poser problème puisque nous
allons accueillir les Jeux olympiques
l'année prochaine celle d'image de la
France qui est en jeu gouverner cette
anticipé donc regardons de près comment
nous allons pouvoir répondre à la
problématique du recrutement et si nous
n'arrivons pas à recruter comment
fera-t-on pour assurer une bonne image
de la France lors de ces Jeux Olympiques
monsieur baril
merci monsieur le président
première question que l'on doit se poser
les métiers de la RATP sont-ils pénibles
il suffit de connaître leurs horaires
leur travail de nuit leurs astreintes
leur
usure physique les conditions de
circulation de plus en plus difficiles
en Île-de-France le stress lié au
comportement d'un certain nombre de
clients pour répondre positivement bien
évidemment à cette question la deuxième
est-ce que les agents de la RATP en
abusent non ils partent en moyenne après
l'âge auquel il pourrait prétendre à la
retraite à 52 ans
cette suppression de leur régime
va-t-elle faciliter les recrutements là
encore non alors que les besoins à
l'aune de la Coupe du monde de rugby en
2023 et des Jeux Olympiques en 2024 sont
énormes et que les conditions de
réussite de ces événements passe
effectivement comme la rappeler un de
mes collègues par la qualité des
déplacements dans notre région
quatrièmement
est-ce que vous voulez faire une
mauvaise manière à Monsieur Castex à qui
on prête de grandes ambitions pour la
RATP bien évidemment alors qu'il doit
faire face à une dégradation des
conditions de déplacement pour les
usagers franciliens et peine à recruter
les 2500 nouveaux agents dont il aura
besoin
c'est la raison pour laquelle
effectivement il ne faut pas fermer ce
régime et au contraire s'en inspirer
pour bon nombre d’autres métiers et si
vous voulez éviter que les agents de la
RSTP ne partent dans d'autres réseaux ou
aillent à la concurrence et bien il faut
leur préserver leur régime
[Musique]
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre chers collègues cet
amendement vise à ne pas fermer le
régime spécial de retraite de la RATP
les métiers de la RATP souffrent d'un
vrai manque d'attractivité et les
Franciliens on ressentent les
conséquences au quotidien il suffit de
prendre les transports en commun pour se
rendre compte de l'impact du manque de
personnel sur les réseaux franciliens
l'année dernière sur les 1500 postes de
chauffeurs de bus qui manquait
700 seulement ont été pourvus s'attaquer
au régime spécial de la RATP c'est
rendre encore moins attractif ces
métiers et en conséquence aggraver les
difficultés que le réseau connaît déjà
j'ajouterai que ce projet de suppression
du régime spécial de la RATP est à
contretemps et paradoxal en effet rendre
attractif les métiers de la RATP s'y
rendre attractif les transports en
commun pour les Franciliens ce faisant
vous vous vous en prenez une fois de
plus au service public de transport
alors même qu'ils sont la solution face
au réchauffement climatique dont les
effets dévastateurs sont dès aujourd'hui
palpables alors que vous poussez dans un
sens pour la mise en place des edfe vous
ne faites rien parallèlement pour
développer significativement les
transports en commun dont les Français
ont besoin au quotidien au contraire
vous les en dégouttez et tomber dans le
piège de l'écologie punitive alors mes
chers collègues parce que nous refusons
le nivellement par le bas pour les
employés de la RATP ainsi que pour des
considérations liées à la sauvegarde des
services publics je vous invite à voter
la suppression des alinéas 1 et 2 de
l'article 1er madame Poumirol
merci monsieur le Président il s'agit
effectivement de la suppression des
alinéas 1 et 2 puisque cet article
premier enfermé le régime général
spécial de la RATP les agents de la RATP
et c'est moins de 5% comme la rappeler
notre camarade Claude rénale tout à
l'heure ont des conditions de travail
bien particulières et souvent difficile
qui sont prises en compte dans leur
régime spécial de retraite
et c'est pour ça que nous demandons
cette suppression Monsieur le Comte
pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
Miss mes chers collègues comme vous
l'avez compris c'est un amendement de
suppression de la suppression du régime
spécial de la RATP
il est indéniable que les transports
publics et d'une manière générale les
mobilités subissent actuellement des
mutations technologiques des révolutions
d'habitude d'usage et de besoins comme
probablement jamais depuis l'avènement
du chemin de fer toutefois faut-il il
faut constater que les conditions de
travail les horaires les astreintes
restent prégnantes pour les agents qui
travaillent dans ce secteur et en
particulier les agents de la RATP c'est
la raison pour laquelle la justice
impose de prendre en compte cette
pénibilité l'efficacité c'est-à-dire le
besoin de personnel pour remplir ces
services églises aussi de prendre en
compte cette pénibilité enfin prendre en
compte cette pénibilité dans la vie
quotidienne des agents c'est aussi
faire attention à la sécurité des
usagers ce qui n'est pas un petit sujet
alors la multiplication des des acteurs
et je pense aussi à un certain nombre de
travailleurs des plateformes qui
travaillent sur ces secteurs de la
mobilité pourraient mériter une
réflexion globale sur la manière de
prendre en compte lorsqu'on exerce ce
type d'activité
les pénibilités les contraintes et les
risques de du métier mais aujourd'hui il
se trouve qu'il y a un régime qui prend
cela en compte le régime de la RATP il
est donc
souhaitable de le maintenir même si nous
pourrions appeler une réflexion plus
globale sur ce sujet compte tenu de la
multiplication des acteurs mais en tout
état de cause montrez du doigt des
soi-disant privilégiés alors que ce sont
ceux qui aujourd'hui bénéficient d'un
régime qui prend en compte les
contraintes de leurs conditions de
travail c'est logique et nous défendrons
ce système merci monsieur le Président
Kader
merci monsieur le Président mais
monsieur le ministre je ne pensais pas
qu'un jour j'en défendrai autant les
intérêts de Jean castech dans cette
émission mais on le fait avec avec force
et détermination mes chers collègues
l'origine spécial de la RATP c'est quoi
exactement ça a été dit par plusieurs
d'entre nous mais l'art de la pédagogie
c'est la hépatique la répétition 40
000 40 000 collaborateurs de la RATP
contre
550000 en statut contre 5500 CDI le
droit privé mais vous le savez seul que
quelques catégories puis pourront partir
en départ anticipé il s'agit des
conducteurs des agents de station des
agents de sûreté honnêtement des agents
qui ont des métiers qu'on peut qualifier
réellement de pénible et qui plus est la
possibilité de départ à la retraite
anticipée à 52 ans n'est que très très
peu utilisé vous le savez pertinemment
la décote qui ont résulté si importantes
que les salariés de RATP ne font valoir
leur droit que de manière très à la
marge enfin pour être très clair et
éviter de diffuser une vision de nanti
que serait les salariés de la RATP je
rappelle que pour bénéficier d'une
retraite à taux plein un salarié de la
RATP doit cotiser autant de temps que
pour le régime général vous l'avez
compris cet amendement demande le
maintien de ce régime spécial parce que
c'est un régime spécial qui est
simplement juste et c'est pour ça donc
nous le défendons madame Espagne
à ne pas fermer l'origine spéciale de la
retraite de la RATP les horaires
atypiques la fréquence des astreintes ou
encore l'usure physique avec les
conditions physiques et mentales des
travailleurs il est indispensable de
prendre en compte divers critères de
pénibilité c'est avant tout une mesure
de justice sociale comme cela était dit
par mes collègues ainsi plutôt que de
niveler les droits des salariés par le
bas en supprimant les régies spéciaux
nous estimons au contraire que
l'ensemble des salariés exposés à la
pénibilité doit partir plus tôt à la
retraite les transports franciliens
métro RER comme bus connaissent des
sous-effectifs de conducteur ce qui a
largement dégradé les conditions de
transport ces derniers mois pour les
habitants de la région parisienne
comment recruter donc quand on réduit
l'attractivité des métiers merci
monsieur le Président merci Madame pour
ces Monges
madame poncemonge
oui merci monsieur le Président alors
effectivement je voudrais revenir sur ce
qui a été dit à savoir que les droits
sont effectivement ouverts pour les
travailleurs relevant des tableaux de
pénibilité à 52 et 57 ans mais dans les
fêtes ils n'ont pas de réalité sauf dans
vos discours alors dire qu'ils n'ont pas
de réalité que très peu le prennent je
vais quand même dire que c'est une
liberté quand même de le prendre et
d'arbitrer éventuellement avec la
pension parce que souvent on dit en
moyenne les gens parlent plus tard donc
c'est pas gênant si on met l'âge légal
plus tard c'est pas tout à fait vrai
parce que la moyenne est une chose et ce
qui est perdu la CGC le dit bien c'est
la liberté d'arbitrer avec sa pension et
ce n'est pas rien la liberté alors
effectivement je vais rappeler que
ceux qui pourraient partir à 52 ans un
certain nombre pattes mais que dans la
réalité effectivement ils partent à 56
ans voilà parce que effectivement il n'y
a pas que l'âge il y a aussi la décote
et que une personne des gens partent
quand ils peuvent partir à l'âge légal
et d'autres attendent la fin de la
décote et ils sont effectivement 85 % à
estimer que c'est pas tant l'âge qui qui
motive leur décision mais 85 % attendent
la fin de la décote donc effectivement
pour ceux qui pouvaient partir à 52 et
par 56 et que pour ceux qui pouvaient
partir à 57 c'est plutôt 57 et demi
alors ce que ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que aussi j'ai entendu ce matin oh
là là ils sont vraiment favorisés la
preuve c'est que ils ont le salaire
calculer sur les six derniers mois mais
en fait c'est pas tout à fait vrai parce
que l'orthodontacement est à 65% et non
à 75% tout comme les fonctionnaires donc
agité aussi ça comme un privilège non et
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qui sont de
plus en plus nombreux ça a été multiplié
par trois les dernières faut conclure
voilà accumuler l'emploi retraite c'est
à dire à travailler après
madame apourse aux police
monsieur le Président Laurent
oui merci monsieur le Président je crois
que dans la situation actuelle de la
RATP l'adoption de la suppression de ce
régime spécial il faut le dire serait
proprement irresponsable
il y a un mouvement très important stop
galère qui vient de réunir des dizaines
de milliers d'usagers à l'initiative des
élus de gauche de la région qui tirent
la sonnette d'alarme la situation est
très alarmante elle ne va pas être
simple à régler parce que derrière cette
crise il y a entre autres une très forte
crise de recrutement pour prendre juste
quelques chiffres 26% des bus ne
circulaient plus à Paris
à la fin de l'année 2022 faute de
conducteur mais c'est la même situation
dans le RER et dans d'autres situations
il y a eu 1000 démissions à la RATP il y
a un absentéisme qui s'accroît tout ça à
cause de conditions qui se dégradent
comment allez-vous pour ceux qui
soutiennent la suppression de ce régime
puisque vous dites ça n'aura aucune
conséquence alors que c'est évident que
ça va en avoir comment est-ce que vous
allez résoudre cette très grave crise de
recrutement il faut que vous preniez la
peine quand même de répondre à cette
question j'ajoute qu'en plus le chaos va
être aggravé par la privatisation vers
laquelle s'obstine Valérie Pécresse il
semble même que et Jean Castex et dans
les couloirs ministériels on y soit pas
très favorable parce que cette
privatisation va conduire 18000 salariés
potentiellement à changer d'entreprise
donc le chaos des transports franciliens
il est devant nous et dans ces
conditions la situation
la mesure que vous proposez aura des
conséquences inévitablesment très
importante et très catastrophique alors
je vous répète ceux qui sont favorables
à cette suppression expliquez-nous
comment quelle mesure vous allez prendre
pour résoudre le problème de recrutement
de la RATP en Île-de-France merci il est
15h10 nous sommes en direct sur Public
Sénat depuis 14h30 on écoute une série
de prises de paroles toutes venus de la
gauche de l'hémicycle ce matin cette
gauche a tenté d'empêcher elle a
suppression des cinq régimes spéciaux
comme le prévoit la réforme des
retraites cela occupé les débats de 9h30
à 13h la gauche sénatoriale n'est pas
parvenue à supprimer ces article 1 de la
réforme elle essaye donc désormais de
s'attaquer au texte et bien morceau de
l'article 1 par morceau d'article 1
Mathias Arès il s'agit donc un on va le
comprendre avec vous de défendre le
régime spécial des salariés des
transports parisiens de la RATP
absolument Quentin vous l'aurez compris
il est ici question d'amendement visant
à supprimer la suppression du régime
spécial des salariés de la RATP avec
plus d'une vingtaine d'amendements
soutenus par les logos de l'hémicycle
l'opposition ici au Sénat souhaite faire
entendre que les horaires décalés la
pénibilité au travail justifie le
maintien de ce régime spécial propre à
la Régie autonome des transports
parisiens un régime qui concourt à
l'attractivité du secteur en peine en ce
moment d'ailleurs en matière de
recrutement un fait qui a été souligné
par le sénateur Jean-Michel Houlgate
socialiste en disant je cite vous allez
compliquer la tâche de Jean de Jean
Castex pour le recrutement de ses
employés ce qui a provoqué l'ilarité de
la salle ce n'est pas la seule fois
d'ailleurs que le président le nouveau
président de la RATP a été cité
aujourd'hui Didier Marie a également
expliqué que le gouvernement souhaitait
jouer un mauvais tour à Jean Castex ou
encore Patrick Kanner le patron des
socialistes a expliqué un sourire aux
lèvres qu'il ne pensait pas un jour
défendre les intérêts de l'ancien
Premier ministre merci Mathias pour
toutes ces explications et je vous
signale qu'il y a une dizaine de
syndicalistes de la CGT mines énergie
qui est donc aussi concernée par la
suppression de leur régime spécial qui
manifeste dans le calme devant le Sénat
avec une banderole régime spéciaux pour
toutes et pour tous retour au débat
alors l'amendement 318
merci monsieur le Président
effectivement nous sommes opposés à la
fermeture de ces régimes spéciaux et en
particulier donc celui de la RATP et
nous avons donc pensé que la rupture de
ce contrat qui a été passé entre la RATP
et ses agents devait être repousser le
plus tard possible donc l'amendement ma
collègue Monique Lubin tout à l'heure
parler de 2050 nous parlons dans
celui-ci que jusqu'à une date déterminée
donc par décret en Conseil d'État après
concertation des organisations
syndicales et patronales un devoir pas
être ultérieur au 1er janvier 2049
merci le suivant
qui le défend
monsieur Fichet oui monsieur le
Président pour participer à gagner
l'ambiance générale je vais reprendre
les arguments et dire combien ça peut
être difficile
d'entendre que tout d'un coup le
couperait tombe au premier septembre
c'est rapide c'est brutal et cette
inacceptable c'est pourquoi ce que nous
proposons à travers cet amendement c'est
que il n'y ait pas de durée au premier
septembre 2023 mais un report avec une
date d'entrée en vigueur de la fermeture
de régime spécial de retraite de la RATP
à une date déterminée par des crêpes
pris en Conseil d'État après
concertation des organisations
syndicales et pas trop dalles et au plus
tard au 1er janvier
2048 je vous remercie
on s'est déjà fait
voilà le suivant
madame Martigues
c'est bien sûr un autre amendement de
repli vous pardon pardon c'est bien sûr
à notre avant de demande de repli et
vous comprenez monsieur le Président que
nous utilisons tous les moyens qui sont
à notre disposition pour essayer de nous
faire entendre ça fait
ça fait un moment
ça fait un moment que nous vous disons
que et la rue le dit aussi que nous
sommes contre cette retraite cette
réforme des retraites mais aussi comme
certaines mesures et effectivement la
rupture de pacte social elle est
réellement présente sur tout si cette
ces dispositifs arrivent dès 2023 parce
qu'elle va concerner des gens qui sont
rentrés dans cette profession pour
vraiment aussi quelques avantages qu'ils
ont et qui compensent un petit peu
toutes les difficultés de leur travail
et nous les connaissons tous et moi je
prends et parfois les transports
franciliens et je me rends compte les
difficultés qu'il y a à travailler
particulièrement dans les zones de
banlieue je voulais le dire donc
moi effectivement cet amendement de
repli il est le même que je me suis de
mes collègues mais il est pour insister
là-dessus effectivement la pédagogie
c'est aussi la répétition donc moi je
propose que ça soit reporté au plus tard
au 1er janvier
2047 je vous remercie monsieur le
Président le 3021 défendu par qui c'est
pourquoi madame
après la présentation
je suis entre elle
merci monsieur le président
je défendrai également cet amendement
nos débats finalement sur cette réforme
des retraites le confirme il s'agit
d'une d'une réforme injuste et brutale
dont l'article premier dont nous parlons
depuis ce matin n'est qu'une
illustration parmi d'autres la
suppression des régimes spéciaux et
l'incarnation du manque d'empathie dont
fait preuve ce gouvernement et la
majorité sénatoriale qui soutient le
gouvernement la pénibilité justement des
chauffeurs de bus
intra-urbain et bien et bel et bien réel
puisqu'ils sont susceptibles de
développer des troubles
musculo-squelettiques ce métier fait
particulièrement mal au dos je vous
invite à l'essayer ne serait-ce qu'une
journée vous verrez c'est le résultat
d'une combinaison de facteurs qui ont
été détaillés d'ailleurs de risque
biomécaniques à cause des vibrations et
des facteurs de risque aigus en raison
du port de charge
comme par hasard ce sont deux des quatre
risques que vous avez supprimés du
compte professionnel de la prévention le
compte pénibilité que nous avons
introduit dans nos précédents très
formes avec l'article premier le
gouvernement pousse encore plus loin la
brutalité de 2017
demain les nouveaux travailleurs des
régimes spéciaux seront intégrés
mécaniquement dans le droit commun c'est
à dire dans le régime général qui
compense la pénibilité de manière très
insuffisante c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire les chauffeurs de métro les mineurs
qui ne voient que rarement la lumière du
jour les chauffeurs de bus parisiens qui
se lèvent tôt parce qu'ils habitent en
banlieue tous ces travailleurs qui
subissent la dureté du travail ne
pourront mécaniquement plus bénéficier
du régime spécial qui les protégeait
jusque là en leur permettant de partir
justement à la retraite au moment où
leur corps n'était pas complètement usé
et c'est ce que cet amendement propose
justement de faire
nous préciser sur quel article du
règlement certainement monsieur le
Président sur la base de l'article 44 6e
man c'est une demande de priorité la
demande de priorité ayant les faits je
l'indique au collège en cas d'adoption
de modifier l'ordre de discussion des
articles d'un texte ou des amendements
il s'agit en l'occurrence de
l'amendement de Monsieur Retailleau
numéro 2057 rectifié bis cet amendement
à vocation à permettre de mettre en
oeuvre dès 2023 là suppression des
régimes spéciaux nous sommes totalement
dans cette discussion et par une
mécanique légistique qui met largement
étrangère mais je salue les services de
la séance et du groupe LR de la voir
imaginé cet amendement ne viendrait
apparemment discussions uniquement elle
a pris l'article 7 ce qui rend les
choses le débat un petit peu exotique
donc demande de priorité que nous disc
utions maintenant puisque nous sommes en
train de parler de ce sujet et que tous
les amendements portent sur ce sujet cet
amendement de Monsieur Retailleau et de
quelques-uns de ses collègues qui a
vocation à mettre en oeuvre dès à
présent la suppression des régimes
spéciaux dès 2023 j'indique que je ne
suis pas la commission je ne suis pas la
présidence je ne suis pas le
gouvernement mais je peux quand même
demander que le Sénat se prononce sur
cette demande oui
je vais consulter sur ce rappel au
règlement pour éclairer l'assemblée mais
je crois qu'il n'est possible qu'en
deuxième partie par nature mais je vais
demander la vie du rapporteur ou d'un
rapporteur général
oui merci monsieur le Président je crois
qu'on a dit déjà ce matin que ça ne
pouvait se faire que dans la deuxième
partie puisqu'en fait c'est un moins de
recettes et donc ça agit sur les comptes
et donc ça ne vient pas sur cette partie
que nous discutons en ce moment
nous passons à l'examen de l'amendement
suivant qui est l'amendement 322
bon alors donc je suis bien dans la
première partie et comme l'indiqué ma
collègue Monique Lubin je propose une
digression sur le choix de la date et
j'en profite pour rappeler les propos de
mon collègue symbole d'Elise ce matin
nous sommes véritablement avec la
suppression de ce régime spécial de la
RATP dans les conséquences de la loi des
mobilités qui a permis l'ouverture à la
concurrence sujet pour lequel nos
collègues de la majorité étaient bien
plus bavards qu'aujourd'hui et donc dans
cet amendement du groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain ils vise à
repousser la date d'entrée en vigueur de
la fermeture du régime spécial de la
retraite de la RATP à une date
déterminée par décret pris en Conseil
d'État après concertation des
organisations syndicales et patronales
et au plus tard au premier janvier 2045
je vous remercie si l'abonnement 3023
madame espagnol
il s'agit également donc de repousser à
une date d'application après discussion
et concertation et les organisations
syndicales et patronales avec par un
décret au Conseil d'État au plus tard au
1er janvier 2024 merci
non pas 2024
excusez-moi bien sûr monsieur le
président
vous voyez je vais
ment
300024 oui c'est le Président c'est le
ministre mes chers collègues je
l'évoquerai pas le caractère injuste et
du tral de cette réforme de ce régime
spécial mais genre une approche très
pragmatique tout simplement et vous
savez regarder
la société le développement des
transports publics est indispensable il
s'agit de réduire l'utilisation de la
voiture individuelle
les caractéristiques des métiers exercés
en matière de transport public en
Île-de-France
nécessite un régime de protection
particulier prenant en compte les
contraintes de ces métiers compte tenues
des difficultés aujourd'hui de
recrutement que l'on constate il est
heureux engendre de repousser le plus
possible ce régime qui porte des
dispositions favorisant l'attractivité
de ces métiers des transports publics en
Île-de-France c'est la raison pour
laquelle
cet amendement vise à reporter
l'application du régime au-delà de du
premier juste on va au plus tard au 1er
janvier 2043 après les concertations qui
apparaissent nécessaires légitime des
organisations syndicales et patronales
je vous remercie merci
l'amendement 3025
madame Préville merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues cet amendement vise à
repousser la date d'entrée c'est un
amendement de repli par rapport au
précédent
du la fermeture du régime spécial de
retraite de la RATP à une dette
déterminée par décret pris en Conseil
d'État et je vais me permettre
d'insister après concertation des
organisations syndicales et patronales
au plus tard au 1er janvier 2042 oui les
syndicats ont leur mot à dire car les
syndicats sont les plus proches de la
réalité sociale il serait judicieux
singulièrement et actuellement et
particulièrement vertueux de les écouter
les syndicats connaissent les nouvelles
réalités du travail la loi générale se
heurte à de plus en plus de singularité
des métiers et des carrières le monde
étant de plus en plus complexe il est
important dès d'écouter les
organisations syndicales
merci de surnomsarrasy pour l'abondement
numéro 3026 oui merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues le groupe socialiste
écologiste s'est répliquant vous l'avez
compris et fermement opposé à cette
article et je ne reviendrai pas sur les
motifs longuement répétés par mes
collègues qui vont dans le sens de cette
suppression je crois qu'ils sont ils
sont nombreux et si j'en juge par
quelques logements de tête ils sont
parfois partagés y compris sur la partie
droite de cette hémicycle mais ce qui
importe avant tout je crois assez de
prendre en compte la vie des
organisations syndicales et patronales
et ça fait cruellement défaut dans les
échanges que nous avons là et qui
illustre la façon dont le texte a été
élaboré donc nous ce que nous proposons
c'est qu'effectivement on écoute ces
organisations syndicales et patronales
et donc qu'après avis du Conseil d'État
on applique
cette suppression plus tard mais cette
fermeture au plus tard le 1er janvier
pendant 3027
voilà nous sommes au milieu de ces
débats sur la suppression de cinq
régimes spéciaux et on a entendu tout à
l'heure à une sénatrice socialiste
Marie-Pierre delagonrie faire une
demande de priorité en clair elle a
demandé à ce que certains amendements
qui sont prévus pour être examinés bien
plus tard dans le texte soit examiné
tout de suite en l'occurrence des
amendements portés par la droite
sénatoriale notamment les amendements de
Bruno Retailleau leur chef de fil
concernant également certains de ces
régimes spéciaux ce qui fait que l'on a
parlé à la fois de l'article 7 et de
l'article 1 mathiasaraez c'est cela en
fait il y a des amendements sur les
régimes spéciaux dans une autre partie
du texte c'est bien ça oui absolument il
y a des amendements qui ont été déposés
par les LR et notamment un par le chef
DLR Bruno Retailleau concernant la
suppression de la clause du grand-père
c'est selon eux selon les LR et bien
c'est un amendement à sa place dans le 7
car il dépend pour eux du volley
dépenses l'article 1 dans lequel nous
nous trouvons au moment où je vous parle
fait lui partie du volley des recettes
c'est celui qui nous intéresse au moment
où on se parle il concerne la
suppression des régimes spéciaux alors
que l'article 7 quant à lui fait partie
des dépenses et il concerne entre autres
le report de l'âge de départ ou encore
l'accélération de la durée d'assurance
alors si on a parlé à nouveau de cet
article et bien c'est comme vous l'avez
dit Quentin et bien parce que la
sénatrice socialiste Marie-Pierre de la
Gontrie a demandé à ce que cette
amendement déposé par Bruno retwaille
Retailleau soit traitée dès à présent en
faisant un rappel au règlement en
matière de priorité car selon elle et
bien c'est amendement à sa place
aujourd'hui dans la discussion autour
des régimes spéciaux merci Mathias pour
ces explications on voit à la gauche qui
conteste le fait que ces amendements
autour d'article 7 porté par la droite
ne soit pas examiné tout de suite du
Conseil d'État après concentration et
implication réelle
les organisations syndicales et
patronales au plus tard le 1er janvier
2038 a fait de favoriser les métiers de
renforcer la tractivité et de favoriser
également le transport collectif
l'amendement 300030 je monte Auger merci
monsieur le Président chers collègues
monsieur le ministre nous nous plaçons
dans l'hypothèse que que nous que nous
n'approuvons pas sur les le côté gauche
de cette émission que le texte global
soit voté et nous prenons dans ce cadre
là encore une fois que l'on ne souhaite
pas nous prenons acte de l'incapacité du
gouvernement à discuter sereinement avec
les
organisations syndicales de la RATP pour
aboutir à une date plausible de sortie
du régime des retraites actuelles de la
RATP voilà pour cette raison là il nous
paraît sage
de faire de prendre appui sur le Conseil
d'État et donc nous souhaitons que par
des craies et après discussion avec les
organisations syndicales et patronales
cette sortie puisse être organisée
envisagé si la loi est votée et on ne le
souhaite pas au 1er janvier 2037
l'abonnement 331
merci monsieur le Président donc c'est
un manquement présenté un amendement de
repli donc qui vise à proposer donc une
un report on va dire de la mise en
oeuvre de ce suppression de régime
spéciaux à compter du une date enfin
pardon à compter du 1er janvier 2036
cela bien évidemment dans la
concertation je pense que ce mot-là a
été extrêmement important la
concertation des organisations
syndicales et patronales car la décision
qui est prise au travers de cette
réforme de mettre à mal et de supprimer
ces régimes spéciaux ne tiennent pas
compte de difficultés qui sont déjà
rencontrées dans certains secteurs et
celui de la RATP particulièrement alors
on peut se demander pourquoi le
gouvernement veut-il supprimer ces
régimes spéciaux combien de personnes
seraient concernées et
était-elle vraiment trop avantagée on en
a parlé longuement ce matin mais
véritablement ces questions là restent
en tout cas je vois que le ministre ne
nous écoute pas du tout donc reste des
points d'interrogation important ça a
été souligné tout à l'heure les besoins
en ce qui concernent la RATP au regard
des événements importants qui nous
attendent donc peu de moi donc quelques
mois sont importants sont nécessaires
pardon en matière d'attractivité et les
JO de 2024 selon mon collègue l'a
rappelé font déjà appel à de nombreux
recrutements qui rencontrent déjà des
difficultés alors si on remet en cause
un aspect particulier de ce contrat de
travail et bien ça ne va évidemment pas
dans le bon sens 1032
merci monsieur le Président alors c'est
un amendement de repli également qui
propose que
crée pris en Conseil d'État après
concertation des organisations
syndicales et patronales soient pris au
plus tard au 1er janvier 2035 cette
concertation est nécessaire et garante
de la cohésion sociale qui est ébranlée
vous le savez quand on regarde de près
les conséquences de cet article on
mesure le fait que vous n'êtes pas prêt
à cette application les agents de ces
organismes concernés par la fermeture
des risques spéciaux seront désormais
affiliés au régime de droit commun par
la pour l'assurance vieillesse et
demeureront couvert pour ces régimes
spéciaux pour les autres risques de
sécurité sociale la maladie la maternité
les actions du travail les maladies
professionnelles
décès et invalidité pour la RATP en
conséquence
pour la retraite complémentaire les
salariés nouvellement embauchés dans les
secteurs et des organismes concernés
seront affiliés à l'agir Carco
organismes gérés paritairement par les
organisations patronales et salariales
et ils yiennent vous le dites dans
l'exposé des motifs cette mesure
nécessitera à terme de revoir le circuit
financier de financement de ces régimes
des travaux seront à conduire pour
évaluer ses conséquences n'est-il pas
donc prématuré de nous présenter cette
fermeture des régimes spéciaux de la
RATP dès ce plfsf rectificatif pour 2023
alors que vous ne connaissez pas encore
toutes les incidences et les
conséquences financières qui en
découlent et donc rendent
inutile le vote à cette date dès
maintenant ces années là n'est-il pas
donc plus plus sage de reporter de
reporter cette disposition et ne pas
mettre donc la charrue avant les bœufs
parce que ce que
se passer c'est que la charrue
le 7 mars les bœufs soit renversé par la
charrue de cette marque
donc on vient de relever le socle et on
passe au 303
merci monsieur le Président alors je
pense que stade où nous en sommes chacun
a compris que nous sommes contre la
suppression des régimes spéciaux
que le gouvernement est pour la
et que certains collègues élèves pas
tous souhaite qu'elle soit immédiate
donc nous faisons une ouverture nous
cherchons un compromis
et nous proposons ici toute une série de
dates qui permettrait au lieu de la
clause du grand-père de d'instaurer la
clause de l'arrière-grand-père
personnellement mon arrière-grand-père
ce serait 2034
mais en tout état de cause comme j'ai
compris que dans cet assemblée il
fallait trouver une majorité
que je ne suis pas totalement certaine
que Monsieur retailleul à la trouve
peut-être pouvons-nous trouver un chemin
et peut-être que ce chemin se trouve
dans un des amendements qui vient d'être
présenté retardés davantage la mise en
oeuvre de cette réforme l'amendement
[Applaudissements]
oui monsieur le Président je vous
remercie
cette série d'amendements et celui que
j'ai l'honneur de vous présenter nous
cherchons à prémunir les agents
actuellement en activité à la RATP et
susceptible dans les années à venir de
bénéficier d'un départ anticipé comme
leur permet aujourd'hui leur régime de
les prémunir de l'éventuelle adoption
d'un abondement de Monsieur Retailleau
le 2057 sous forme d'articles
additionnels après l'article 7 qui vise
à appliquer cette réforme dès 2023
c'est-à-dire cette année même en
revenant sur la clause dite du
grand-père
nous avons expliqué pourquoi il ne
fallait pas remettre en cause ce régime
protecteur prenant en compte les
éléments de pénibilité que nous avons
développé et que personne ici ne semble
contester puisque je n'ai entendu aucun
de nos collègues dire que les métiers de
la RATP n'étaient pas des métiers
pénibles pour une bonne part d'entre eux
malheureusement vous ne semblez pas nous
entendre aussi nous vous proposons une
forme de compromis pour garantir aux
salariés actuels qu'ils pourront bien
bénéficier d'un départ anticipé s'il le
souhaite et nous faisons un geste en
direction de Monsieur Castex pour qu'il
puisse satisfaire ses ambitions et
effectivement recruter les 2500 agents
dont il va avoir besoin dans les années
qui viennent car si vous supprimez dès
2023 par l'amendement de Monsieur
Retailleau la possibilité de bénéficier
de ce régime il va soit que bon nombre
de ceux qui pourraient être intéressés
pour rejoindre la RATP dans les 10 ans
qui viennent tourneront le dos et iront
travailler ailleurs c'est la raison pour
laquelle monsieur le Président mon
amendement propose 2033 pile dans 10 ans
l'abonnement 335
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues bon vous
l'avez compris nous ne sommes pas
favorables à la fermeture du régime
spécial de la RATP mais néanmoins dans
l'hypothèse où cette fermeture devrait
intervenir il appartient de laisser
place à la négociation pour permettre
d'ailleurs à ce qu'il puisse y avoir
pour ceux qui sont concernés pour
renforcer l'attractivité du métier a des
compensations je remarque que je ferai
remarqué que lors de l'exercice
similaire qui s'est fait pour la SNCF il
y a eu place à la négociation et il y a
eu place ad contrepartie la question que
l'on peut et que l'on doit se poser dans
l'hypothèse où nous ouvrons la porte à
cette négociation est-ce que la RATP a
les moyens d'octroyer à ses futurs
salariés les compensations qui seront
indispensables et qui vont d'une
certaine façon permettre de continuer à
ce que les métiers soient attractifs
RATP n'a peut les moyens en réalité de
procéder à ces compensations le chiffre
d'affaires consolidé en 2021 était de 5
milliards 8 la dette pratiquement de 5,7
milliards d'euros la RATP pardon doit
faire face à un plan d'investissement de
plus de 2 milliards d'euros le résultat
opérationnel s'élève à 183 millions
d'euros pour l'exercice 2022 et le
résultat net est négatif de 26 millions
d'euros contre 207 millions d'euros en
2021 ce qui veut dire que la situation
financière de la RATP demeure fragile
ces marges de manœuvre sont extrêmement
limitées d'où la nécessité de donner du
temps pour permettre à la SNCF et nous
lui fait à la RATP et nous lui faisons
confiance de redresser la situation
financière de dégager des marges qui
permettront
d'octroyer des condensation
l'amendement 3036
me donner la parole monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues donc comme mes
collègues je présente un amendement qui
vise à repousser la date d'entrée en
vigueur de la fermeture du régime
spécial de la retraite de la RATP à une
date déterminée par décret pris en
Conseil d'État précertation des
organisations syndicales et patronales
au plus tard au 1er janvier 2031
pourquoi je développerai rapidement
trois raisons tout d'abord parce que le
moment est particulièrement mal venue au
regard des difficultés de recrutement
que nous avons largement évoqué cet
après-midi la RATP ne fait pas en ville
les métiers de la de la RATP ne sont pas
attractifs alors que nous avons à faire
face à des échéances particulièrement
importantes que nous devons tous
ensemble réussir je pense par exemple
aux Jeux Olympiques
ensuite le moment est malvenu parce que
nous sommes au pied du mur le
réchauffement climatique nous impose de
développer et rapidement les transports
en commun les transports publics et que
pour ce cher il ne faut avoir des
salariés qui est en vie de contribuer à
la réussite de ce défi ensuite troisième
chose et bien comme l'a dit mon collègue
précédemment il faut que nous nous
donnions le temps de la concertation
plutôt que de bloquer la France et bien
il faut que la concertation réussisse à
convaincre les premiers concernés et que
nous puissions obtenir leur adhésion je
vous remercie un moment 307
monsieur Éblé
c'est moi monsieur le Président comme
vous le voyez je me suis légèrement
déplacé dans l'hémicycle de façon à me
rapprocher du micro et nous faire gagner
de précieuses minutes car nous en avons
bien besoin pour aller au bout de ce
débat et j'ai opté pour une place qui
est d'ailleurs celle de notre illustre
prédécesseur le sénateur Victor Hugo
dont je ne doute pas qu'en raison de la
condition francilienne parisienne même
et de son attachement au monde du
travail il aurait certainement apprécié
et soutenu l'amendement que je vais
maintenant défendre devant vous
il s'agit
[Applaudissements]
il s'agit de modifier la date de la
fermeture du régime spécial de retraite
de la RATP que vous nous proposez enfin
que le sénateur Retailleau nous propose
en septembre 2023 ce qui est infiniment
rapide et assez abrupte pour tout dire
même violent pourrait-on considéré du
point de vue de la nécessité d'une
négociation avec les organisations tant
syndicales que patronales d'ailleurs en
l'occurrence le patron Castex mais voilà
il faut un décret en Conseil d'État et
donc pour ma part je proposerai une date
qui me paraît bien plus raisonnable et
qui permet de conduire cette discussion
et qui serait celle du 1er janvier 2030
cela ne me semble pas trop rapide cela
permet d'approfondir les conditions qui
permettraient de conduire cette
fermeture du régime spécial de retraite
que par ailleurs nous ne souhaitons pas
mais que
qui pourrait éventuellement être adopté
par notre assemblée et donc il s'agit de
l'avez compris d'un amendement de repli
l'amendement 3043
que le président Kader oui c'est moi
monsieur
tu as souligne et pressé mais non non
c'est moi monsieur Assouline
mes chers collègues je suis le président
dont je salue le calme olympien voilà
c'est ça nous permet de travailler dans
de bonnes conditions et j'en suis très
heureux
mes chers collègues 2015
si c'est du travail voilà c'est du
travail pour nous ça vous l'avez compris
2015 nomination de Madame Élisabeth
borne à la tête de la RATP
j'ai regardé depuis tout à l'heure
depuis ces amendements de repli ici il y
avait eu une réflexion concernant le
régime spécial de la RATP je recherche
je n'ai pas trouvé je ne veux pas sonder
ni le les reins ni le cœur de Madame
borne en la matière mais mais
forte et ta pensée que finalement quand
on est pas trop de la RATP ce régime
spécial n'est pas si catastrophique que
cela pour les salariés donc monsieur le
Président en lien avec mes autres
collègues sur cet amendement de repli
sur ces amendements de repli je vous
propose donc qu'après concertation avec
les organisations syndicales et
patronales et bien nous puissions au
plus tard au 1er janvier 2029 donc
repousser l'application de cette
disposition prévue par le texte que nous
examinons en ce moment l'amendement 3045
je pense que c'est Monsieur Assouline
qui présente
écoutez on a essayé dans un premier
temps de vous montrer que c'était une
réforme et un débat hors sol hors sol
parce que il n'y avait pas d'urgence à
le nicher dans une loi de financement
alors que le débat est ample est
nécessite un peu plus de paramètres
notamment sur le travail les nouvelles
technologies les projections à 10 ans 20
ans 30 ans etc
et d'autant plus hors sol que
en gros au moment où il y a une
inflation terrible où les gens de plus
en plus de mal à vivre ou les salaires
stagnent ne sont pas à la hauteur ou
donc
des classes moyennes se popularisent et
viennent s'ajouter à ceux qui sont déjà
pauvres qu'il y a une telle tension on
vient nous dire que alors que certains
font des milliards de bénéfices à la
faveur de la crise qu'il faut absolument
faire payer par deux ans de leur vie les
plus démunis dans le pays mais c'est
aussi hors temps et c'est de cela que
l'on discute en ce moment hors temps
pourquoi parce qu'à travers c'est cette
suppression de régime spécial à la RATP
on vient mettre
disons le l'accusation
sur un secteur qui souffre aussi
particulièrement et c'est pas seulement
ce ne sont pas seulement les
travailleurs mais surtout les usagers
aujourd'hui les transports parisiens
d'Île-de-France la RATP est va
défondrement à cause de la gestion
désastreuse du gouvernement et de
Valérie Pécresse c'est-à-dire la droite
unique comme dans cette hémicycle comme
dans cette hémicycle et au moment où on
ne sait pas si ce service va pouvoir
continuer pour les Franciliens à la
veille des Jeux Olympiques on vient dire
que ce sera un privilège ce statut mais
si c'était un privilège pour qu'on
n'arrive pas à recruter d'agent de la
RATP mais il se rurait tout sur ce
statut privilégié et donc pour cette
raison il ne faut absolument pas
adopter conclure adopter il faut
conclure je conclure il ne faut pas
l'adopter parce qu'elle est
madame Cohen pour l'amendement 3913 oui
le président et c'est aussi un
amendement de repli je pense que nos
argumentations qui sont vraiment
diverses et variées sur le même sujet
peuvent parce que ces pédagogiques
convaincre un certain nombre de nos
collègues des bandes de droite en tout
cas c'est le but que moi j'ai en ce
moment au moment du de notre réflexion
dans un contexte où l'île de France
mobilité qu'on connaît une difficulté
majeure celle-ci justifie de préserver
l'attractivité de ces métiers et prendre
du recul quand à l'ouverture prochaine
de la mise en concurrence prévue pour
les bus en 2025 pour les tramways en
2029 et pour les RER en 2039 cette
ouverture à la concurrence aura des
conséquences aussi bien sur la qualité
que sur la fiabilité du régime et il
nous paraît donc indispensable de
préserver le régime spécial de la RATP
d'où nos amendements de suppression mais
vous les avez refusé et donc c'est cet
amendement de repli vous savez
pertinemment que malgré la campagne de
recrutement régulière la RATP peine à
attirer des salariés rien d'étonnant la
bande l'abandon progressive du statut un
effet négatif sur l'attractivité de
l'entreprise ou 75% du personnel
travaille avec des horaires atypiques
horaires décalés à l'occasion
complémentaire de déplacement décalage
par rapport à leurs frais de transport
abandon progressistes progressif des
compensations dans la maintenance la
précarisation est aussi la est aussi de
mise à la RATP donc supprimer ce régime
spécial ne fera que dégrader les
conditions de travail donc les
conditions de transport de millions de
voyageurs en Île-de-France votre mesure
va donc entraîner une dégradation
brutale des droits des nouveaux entrants
et alors que vous vantez d'un dialogue
social au sein des branches la réalité
c'est que vous passez outre les
discussions qui ont permis l'obtention
de ce droit grâce justement à des
négociations de branches et vous balayez
d'un verre de main régime qui a pour
vertu de prendre en compte la pénibilité
spécifique de cette ville filière d'où
notre amendement merci
je vais demander maintenant la vie de la
Commission sur l'ensemble des
amendements qui ont fait l'objet d'une
discussion commune merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues sur l'ensemble des premiers
amendements qui étaient des amendements
de suppression nous avons donné un avis
défavorable en commission puisque c'est
contraire à ce qui a été voté à la
Commission et sur l'autre série
d'amendements qui sont finalement
de repousser cette fermeture alors c'est
plus la clause du grand-père en fait moi
j'aurais peut-être envie de qualifier ça
la clause de l'arrière-grand-père
puisqu'on repousse encore et pourquoi
pas rire grand-mère
en tout cas je voulais vous dire que
c'était un avis défavorable je voudrais
revenir sur quelques points il a
beaucoup été évoqué qu'on parlait de
privilège moi j'ai jamais parlé de
privilège j'ai trouvé que c'était des
conditions à l'époque qui étaient
nécessaires à mettre en place pour ces
métiers donc j'ai absolument jamais
parlé de privilège ensuite vous parlez
de pacte social et de justice sociale en
fait moi j'ai parlé de du fait que
aujourd'hui l'ensemble des Français qui
ne sont pas dans les régimes spéciaux et
bien exerce une forme de solidarité
nationale vis-à-vis de ces régimes
spéciaux et que c'est anormal il me
semble que c'est injuste que ce n'est
pas équitable en tout cas les efforts de
tous les Français sont évidemment pas
géométrie variable il faut aussi
regarder ça avec attention je voulais
aussi parler du fait que ces métiers
évidemment ils ont changé dans leur
environnement certains sont encore
pénibles sont devenus pénibles par
d'autres phénomènes mais il y a eu aussi
beaucoup de progrès techniques des
moyens modernes qui ont été mis en place
pour que ces métiers s'exercent de façon
beaucoup plus sereine pour certains je
dis pas pour tous je fais très très
attention de façon plus sereine donc il
y a eu les progrès techniques il faut en
tenir compte et c'est important en tout
cas les critères de pénibilité seront
quelque peu pris en compte dans le C2P
donc c'est un progrès il faut aussi là
le noter je voudrais aussi dire que le
dialogue social comme les discussions
dimanche par métier par entreprise se
feront et c'est indiqué dans ce projet
de loi le dernier point c'est sur les
difficultés de recrutement puisque vous
les avez beaucoup évoqué alors
aujourd'hui il y a un régime spécial
pour la RATP et il y a des difficultés
de recrutement alors je ne comprends pas
finalement parce que s'il y avait pas de
commandes de régime spécial bon je me
dis que finalement
des entreprises comme la RATP propose
des conditions particulières et
finalement ils ont des problèmes de
recrutement dans d'autres territoires
ils n'ont pas ces régimes spéciaux ils
ont aussi des problèmes de recrutement
je pense qu'il y a besoin de réenchanter
un certain nombre de métiers d'exercer
de faire en sorte qu'ils soient fait des
campagnes aussi d'attractivité de ces
métiers et donc c'est c'est aussi
comment dirais-je des choses à noter
donc je pense avoir répondu globalement
l'ensemble des des enjeux qui ont été
évoqués par mes collègues c'est donc un
avis défavorable féministe la vie du
gouvernement
merci beaucoup à monsieur le Président
en fin de matinée je disais que les
amendements de suppression de l'article
1 avait été présenté avec les mêmes
arguments que ce déployer à l'occasion
de la discussion générale sur l'article
et que ça m'invitait à être relativement
bref dans les explications pour
justifier d'un avis défavorable je
voudrais simplement souligner trois
points pardon et faire une remarque le
premier point concerne une réflexion de
Madame ponce il y a quelques instants
parce que madame la sénatrice a indiqué
que les départs à l'âge minimum
d'ouverture des droits de la RATP était
finalement assez peu nombreux et que le
fait que les salariés concernés n'est
pas leur durée de cotisation au moment
où là je départ de l'âge d'ouverture des
droits minimum intervenez les invités à
prolonger notamment pour aller jusqu'à
l'âge de suppression de la décote et
vous avez raison c'est ce qui se passe
et cela tombe plutôt bien puisque
justement nous ne supprimons pas nous ne
bougeons pas et nous ne relevons pas
l'âge de suppression de la décote ça
devrait être de nature à vous rassurer
peut-être même à vous inviter à retirer
cet amendement la deuxième chose que je
veux souligner mais qui rejoint les
éléments généraux de ce matin c'est que
le régime de la RATP aujourd'hui mais
évidemment pas équilibré nous avons 40
000 cotisants et nous avons à peu près
autant de retraités de droits directs
sans compter les réversions ce qui
explique que l'État apporte une
subvention d'équilibre de 700 euros et
c'est une des justifications 700
millions d'euros pardon 700 millions
d'euros c'est une explication qui nous
amène à proposer la fermeture de ce
régime la troisième chose que je veux
dire mais qui rejoint aussi une
intervention de Madame ponce
pardonnez-moi madame je me suis appuyé
sur vos propos vous avez notamment dit
qu'il vous tenez absolument par ces
amendements à faire respecter le contrat
à intervenir entre les salariés de la
RATP et la RATP avec un régime spécial à
un moment de la signature de leur
contrat la cause de grand-père nous
prévoyons garantit ce contrat et
garantit ce pacte social puisque dans le
texte que nous proposons au Parlement la
fermeture intervient en flux dans les
nouveaux salariés nous vous embaucher
devrais-je dire à partir du 1er
septembre 2023 et puis enfin monsieur le
Président si vous me le permettez je
n'ai pas pu intervenir ce matin en toute
fin de matinée puisque le scrutin était
déjà annoncé et que je ne pouvais pas
intervenir à ce moment-là mais plusieurs
intervenants avaient dit leur
interrogation sur la place d'un article
de fermeture du régime général de
l'assurance vieillesse pour les régimes
spéciaux dans le PLFSS et notamment le
pffss rectificatif le lien est pourtant
évident dès lors que nous disons qu'à
partir du 1er septembre 2023 les
nouveaux embauchés des entreprises
bénéficiant d'un régime spécial seront
affiliés à la caisse nationale la Caisse
nationale d'assurance vieillesse et donc
au régime général de l'assurance
vieillesse il y a mécaniquement un
transfert des recettes de cotisations de
ces nouveaux embauchés de la caisse des
régions spéciaux vers la caisse du
régime général en l'occurrence la CNAV
c'est ce qui justifie ce qui explique et
illustre la nécessité et je crois la
pertinence en droit de l'inscrire dans
un pdfss rectificatif
merci nous allons maintenant passer
depuis 14h30 on voit cette défense du
régime spécial de la RATP de la part de
la gauche sénatoriale cette gauche qui a
essayé ce matin de supprimer l'article 1
de la réforme des retraites et qui est
bien lui-même supprime 5 régimes
spéciaux la gauche n'est pas parvenu
avec cette manœuvre là donc maintenant
elle a déposé d'autres amendements pour
attaquer plus précisément à un certain
alinéa de cet article 1 mathiasarez et
qu'est-ce qu'il y a exactement dans cet
article 1 et bien écoutez dans cet
article 1 vous le savez Quentin il y a
les régimes spéciaux et la suppression
de ces régimes spéciaux ce à quoi on
vient d'assister bien c'est la gauche
qui a défendu amendements sur des
amendements vis-à-vis des alinéas par
alinéa et là il était question vous
l'avez dit des alinéas concernant le
régime spécial de la RATP il en a eu
plusieurs dizaines cette gauche qui a
tenté de faire entendre que les horaires
décalés pénibilité au travail juste ici
le maintien de ce régime spécial propre
à la Régie autonome des transports
parisiens un régime qui concourt à
l'attractivité de du secteur en peine en
matière de recrutement un fait souligner
par Jean-Michel Houlgate le sénateur
socialiste qui a dit je cite vous allez
compliquer la tâche de Jean Castex pour
le recrutement de ces employés ils ont
donc défendu d'abord la suppression de
cet article qui vise donc à supprimer le
régime de la RATP et ensuite il y a eu
d'autres amendements qui disaient à
repousser la suppression de ce régime
spécial il va vous l'avez donc compris
sans surprise aussi bien la commission
que le gouvernement ont donné un avis
défavorable assez amendements avant
prochainement de passer au vote merci
merci Mathias merci aussi pour votre
agilité lorsque je vous pose des
questions sur les points précis du texte
et effectivement oui on le voit en tout
cas on l'a compris la gauche multiplier
les amendements la gauche qui multiplie
maintenant les explications de vote
puisque c'est ce qui va se passer il n'y
a pas encore de scrutin sur l'ensemble
des amendements puisque ils sont de
nombreux maintenant à demander à pouvoir
prendre la parole pour s'exprimer sur
l'ensemble des amendements et ensuite on
va le voir il y aura sans doute un
scrutin public sur l'ensemble de ces
amendements et que vous
perdez à maintenir secret savoir si ce
sujet du régime spécial de la RATP est
évoqué et qu'elle conclure
merci monsieur le Président alors je
voudrais revenir sur le fait que avant
de vouloir fermer le régime protecteur
je dis protecteur pas spécial de la RATP
ont été multipliés les embauches de
contractuel soit des personnes exclues
du statut aujourd'hui c'est contractuels
sont déjà 5000 et donc ils sont déjà au
régime général et un tiers des
recrutements sont des contractuels mais
cela ne va pas assez vite alors vous
fermez le régime avec la clause du
grand-père et vous avez ouvert entre
temps à la concurrence c'est des
salariés transférés au privé perdront
leur statut mais garderont leur régime
de retraite bon j'espère que vous suivez
puisque vous souhaitez un référendum sur
les régimes spéciaux c'est pas plus dur
que le référendum constitutionnel on
continue donc nous avons des
contractuels qui n'ont pas de statut et
pas de régime retraite nous avons
transféré au privé des gens ils perdent
leur statut mais garde le régime de
retraite c'est très brutal mais il garde
ça la clause du grand-père il garde les
deux c'est pas moi monsieur le ministre
qui est dit qu'il avait rupture de
contrat mais on ne prête corrige et les
nouveaux embauchés donc auront le statut
mais plus le régime de retraite je sais
pas si vous avez suivi mais il y avait
quatre combinaisons vous les couvrez
toutes quatre combinaisons de
dérégulation moi je vous propose une
seule c'est plus simple c'est de garder
ce qui existe depuis 45 de garder le
statut et le régime de retraite
anticipée
pour explication de vote
madame line m'a pour chacun le temps de
se préparer
merci monsieur le Président moi je ne
vais pas
citer un
collègue à qui qui chantait
excusez-moi nous avons toute la vie pour
travailler il nous restera que la mort
pour nous reposer il avait dit nous
avons toute la vie pour nous amuser nous
avons toute la mort pour nous reposer
voilà le refrain de votre partition
voici le signe ce programme que dessine
votre réforme voici le projet cargument
après argument nous combattons face à
vous qui a défaut d'arguments restez
relativement muet en cas de recul de
l'âge de départ à la retraite à 64 ans
comme le prévoit se présente projet de
loi
le départ le départ dont des personnes
de la RATP serait décalé de 54 ans à 52
ans pour la catégorie B soit les
conducteurs sous réserve bien sûr
d'avoir travaillé 27 ans et de 57 ans à
59 ans pour la catégorie A soit les
opérateurs machinistes agents de
maintenance notamment aussi sous
réserves d'avoir effectué 27 ans mais je
vous en prie postulez donc à l'air ATP
n'hésitez pas à frapper à la porte de de
Castex puisque ces emplois sont si
confortables puisque vous souhaitez
maintenir le régime autonome des
sénateurs à vos yeux ses emplois
méritent donc moins de prendre en compte
la pénibilité du travail que notre
propre fonction monsieur le rapporteur
Savary vous avez précédemment dit que
plus on met en avant la pénibilité des
métiers plus on est à l'attractivité de
ses professions sa solution serait donc
de cacher la poussière sous le tapis que
le législateur fasse l'autruche face à
la réalité des conditions de travail
nous le concitoyens pour nous cela
revient à mentir à la population que de
faire fille de la dureté de ses métiers
qui sont combien indispensables au
fonctionnement de la communauté
sincèrement ce n'est pas sérieux c'est
pour cette raison que nous demandons la
suppression de ces alinéas qui
concernent des agents de la RTP
tous les salariés du secteur des
transports des bus quelle que soit
l'endroit en France où ils font ce
travail ont des conditions de travail
souvent difficiles et partout il y a des
problèmes de recrutement
elle sait pas en supprimant le régime
spécial en fermant le régime spécial de
la RATP que ça va donner le moindre
avantage la moindre amélioration à ces
autres salariés
et alors l'argumentaire de nous
rapporteur c'est de dire mais on va
s'occuper des problèmes de pénibilité on
va faire des accords de branches qui
vont prendre en compte la spécificité de
ce métier je vous le dire tout net s'il
y avait de bons accords de branches sur
l'ensemble de la profession du transport
on pourrait s'interroger sur le maintien
d'une différenciation
mais en supprimant ce régime avant toute
négociation de branches globale qui
constitue une amélioration une
valorisation des conditions de travail
de salaire et de retraite de ces métiers
vous cassez le moindre rapport de force
d'harmonisation vers le haut de
convergence vers le haut vous
institutionnalisez comme l'a dit Madame
par rapport je me trompe toujours pensé
bon bref notre collègue c'est pas
pourquoi j'ai un trou sur son nom mais
je n'oublie pas son argumentation elle a
très bien expliqué la fragmentation de
ces métiers elle a très bien vu comment
en les mettant en opposition tirer vers
le bas conclusion des courses nous
n'avons plus de salariés qui ont le
sentiment que ce métier peut être
porteur pour eux quant à la pénibilité
je vous invite de prendre un bus de la
RATP vous allez voir la tension globale
vous allez voir la différence qu'il y a
peut-être avec ce qu'il y avait une
cinquantaine d'années bref faut
maintenir ce régime pour aller vers une
convergence vers le haut pour les
métiers de transport
monsieur le Président Gontard
et se préparera le président Laurent oui
merci Monsieur le retour en salle des
conférences ici au Sénat cette salle qui
joue sur l'hémistique j'accueille ici
Xavier bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénateur RDPI c'est le groupe de la
majorité présidentielle ici à la Chambre
haute un mot sur ce qui se joue en
séance depuis ce matin avec ses prises
de parole ses amendements ses
explications de vote comment est-ce que
vous appréciez ce qui se passe dans
l'hémicycle justement je pense que rien
ne se joue dans l'hémicycle aujourd'hui
à part l'obstruction de la gauche de
l'hémicycle qui multiplie les prises de
parole les amendements
sur le front comme on vient d'entendre
avec Madame
cette réforme non mais qui est des battu
des débat sur le fond c'est le propre du
Parlement et on doit les avoir par
contre quand on fait 23 amendements
d'affilée
identiques en repoussant juste d'une
année la mise en application de la
suppression des régimes spéciaux et
faites par la même sénatrice on voit
bien aujourd'hui qu'il y a de
l'obstruction on voit bien également que
toutes les rappelles au règlement que
les prises de parole les les amendements
de suppression qui ne sont pas groupés
c'est une première c'est généralement on
groupe les amendements de suppression le
groupe communiste d'ailleurs est plutôt
cohérent c'est à dire qu'ils font un
amendement de suppression pour leur
groupe et ils ont ensuite les
explications chacun sur leur argument ce
qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui grosses
socialiste vous pensez de la remarque
justement de ces socialistes qui
regrettent ce silence venu de la droite
du Centre et aussi des marcheurs dans
l'hémicycle non bah alors déjà les
marcheurs les membres de la majorité
présidentielle on prend la parole on
prend la parole pour
tendus on a entendu monsieur lévrier
pour l'instant moi j'ai pris deux fois
la parole depuis ce matin mais lui il en
a pris aussi deux fois la parole mais
bon en l'occurrence on est deux
aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle le
président Patriat nous a rejoint et donc
on prend la parole quand il le faut mais
prendre la parole sur de l'obstruction
hormis dénoncer l'obstruction c'est
quand même difficile aujourd'hui on n'a
pas de débat de fond réellement on a
pris la parole sur la question des
régimes spéciaux on a dénoncé
effectivement l'attitude de la gauche
qui veut préserver les régimes spéciaux
et d'ailleurs moi je vous l'ai qui nous
depuis des semaines il nous demande
d'écouter les Français mais moi je suis
d'accord écoutons les Français mais
écoute n'ayant pas l'oreille sélective
et faisons en sorte d'écouter les
Français quand ils nous disent qu'ils
veulent la suppression des régimes
spéciaux monsieur yakovelli un mot sur
ce que disent les sénateurs en séance
ces métiers pour lesquels vous allez
supprimer des régimes spéciaux ça
correspond à des métiers qui sont
particulièrement difficiles à RATP comme
on vient de l'entendre ce sont des
personnes qui sont dans des métros dans
des souterrains pendant toute une
carrière c'est pas des arguments qui qui
peuvent vous faire douter de la
pertinence de supprimer ces régimes
spéciaux il y a un argument que j'ai que
j'ai entendu aussi et qui était la
difficulté actuelle pour la RATP
notamment de recruter
1200 postes qui étaient ouverts la
moitié seulement ont été pourvus pour
RATP alors même qu'ils ont le statut du
régime spécial c'est à dire que on voit
bien que ce n'est pas le régime spécial
qui fait qu'on peut recruter ou pas
au contraire alors au contraire c'est
aujourd'hui on a le régime spécial et on
a du mal à recruter donc on voit bien
qu'il n'y a pas de corrélation entre le
fait de partir à 55 ans ou 52 ans
parfois sur la RATP et le fait d'être
recruté donc effectivement il y a une
question de pénibilité au travail ça
c'est un autre sujet on n'est pas sur la
question des régimes spéciaux les
régimes spéciaux c'est un départ
anticipé en fait et donc effectivement
quand on est conducteur de bus de la
RATP à Paris je ne vois pas pourquoi on
aurait pas le même statut qu'un
chauffeur de bus à Amiens ou dans la
Creuse et bien merci merci Xavier Aquali
pour toutes ces explications au micro de
public c'est un retour au direct dans
l'hémicycle
ben non les 700 millions le déficit du
régime enfin entre le liés au
déséquilibre entre actifs et retraités
il existe toujours vous le changez de
caisse c'est vrai mais vous le faites
pas disparaître donc cessez de
d'utiliser des arguments qui sont des
subterfuges et qui en vérité ne
correspondent à rien du tout vous
manipulez les chiffres mais en vérité il
y a du vent derrière
je suis le président rénal vous voyez
expliquer votre vote
oui
et Madame jasmin se prépare
j'écoutais mon collègue président du
groupe communiste donc j'étais tout ouïe
et surtout il a il a développé un salon
d'argument que je voulais reprendre mais
il y en avait au moins deux le premier
c'est de nous dire finalement cette
profession avec les progrès techniques
et les progrès technologiques est-ce
qu'elle est aussi difficile qu'hier
est-ce que finalement le régime dont il
s'agit est aujourd'hui encore nécessaire
moi j'étais figurez-vous je crois qu'on
était pas nombreux mais bon au vœu de la
RATP je suis allé écouter le prise en
Castex et
c'est vœu de la RATP c'était intéressant
c'était pas des vœux classique c'est à
dire que président Castex a peut parler
mais il a fait parler les salariés de la
RATP il a fait parler en particulier des
jeunes chauffeurs et des chauffeurs un
peu plus anciens qui parlaient de leur
métier ils en parlaient d'ailleurs avec
beaucoup d'émotions beaucoup d'esprits
de maisons et on l'a senti on a senti
qui ils appartenaient à une famille et
en même temps ils ont fait part de
toutes les difficultés qui existaient
dans leur métier et c'est vrai on
pourrait se dire chauffeur de bus
aujourd'hui c'est pas comme allez mon
grand-père il y a 50 ans quand il
mettait une minute à trouver la
troisième vous voyez il fallait il
fallait orienter le levier de vitesse
c'était pas aussi simple que ça c'est
vrai qu'il y a beaucoup d'aide à la
conduite mais quand même aujourd'hui la
responsabilité de ces agents est
extrêmement forte la responsabilité face
à des circulations extrêmement
conséquente à des risques de traverser
de trottinette de piétons etc tout ça
est extrêmement nerveusement extrêmement
compliqué et ces jeunes gens et ces
jeunes je suis bien qu'il faut
complètement très difficile mais pour
eux c'était très compliqué donc je crois
simplement qu'il faut revenir sur cette
idée c'est une mauvaise idée de merci
monsieur le Président Madame
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre et chers collègues l'ancien
premier ministre Jean Castex a besoin de
nous il a besoin de notre soutien dans
cette affaire qui s'apparente à un
sabotage réel à son encontre à
l'encontre de la RATP mais aussi des
salariés la France doit réussir les JO
de 2024 c'est un défi pour lui nous
devons collectivement maintenir le
régime spécial de la retraite de la RATP
pour convaincre des nouveaux chauffeurs
avec les organisations syndicales et
patronales pour favoriser l'attractivité
des différents métiers et les
déplacements de nos concitoyens et de
nos invités merci
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues j'ai
entendu beaucoup d'arguments développés
autour des conditions d'accueil des
millions de visiteurs aux visiteuses
pour les Jeux Olympiques et leurs
conditions de transport ajuste raison
d'ailleurs en Seine-Saint-Denis on est
très heureux parce que c'est nous qui
allons accueillir les Jeux olympiques
avec le Stade de France et la piscine
mais la réalité c'est que les conditions
de transport sont dégradées pour des
millions de Franciliens franciliens dès
aujourd'hui dans mon département pour le
bus 148 à Blanc-Mesnil il faut parfois
40 minutes d'attente pour aller à
Bobigny et quand vous avez vous êtes
même pas sûr pouvoir monter dans
tellement il est plein c'est ça
aujourd'hui les conditions de transport
et donc les conditions de travail
des détraminaux et vous avez une
question
il y a beaucoup de démission on l'a dit
tout à l'heure et vous nous répondez pas
300 l'an dernier d'ailleurs beaucoup
sont même pas par ces par la DRH je leur
dis ils ont abandonné du jour au
lendemain leur travail pourquoi
conditions de travail dégradées salaire
bloqué on commence en dessous du SMIC à
l'arrière ATP et on passe au-dessus du
SMIC juste par les primes c'est ça la
réalité et vous avez la question du
statut l'ouverture à la concurrence et
la privatisation prochaine de la RATP
donc nous vous proposons la question et
d'ailleurs on aurait aimé que monsieur
Clément bonne comme on aimerait que
Madame panure statut des Ig soit à vos
côtés est-ce que oui ou non ils sont
pour l'extinction et la case de statut
et comment on contre recruté avec ces
conditions de travail dégradées et le
régime spécial abattu et le statut mi
Amal il va falloir quand même nous
répondre parce que même si les JO sont
une question c'est aujourd'hui qu'il
faut répondre à la crise des transports
pour les millions de Franciliens
franciliens et en faisant ça nous avons
aggravé le problème je vous remercie
monsieur Joly ensuite monsieur la Mini
surpris monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues nos
échanges sur la retraite et sur celui
des régimes spéciaux en particulier
témoignent qu'on ne peut délier ces
sujets d'autres sujets de société qui
lui sont liés en particulier l'évolution
du travail et de ses caractéristiques
selon les différents secteurs d'activité
l'approche renouvelée du lien au travail
par nos concitoyens et puis sur la
question du financement des solidarités
ayant particulier du financement des
solidarités entre générations et entre
Français dont chacun doit selon la
Constitution participer selon ses
capacités financières pour en venir en
particulier au sujet des régimes
spéciaux cette réforme n'est ni juste ni
légitime d'autres l'ont dit avant moi
faut-il rappeler que une partie
importante de des Français en
particulier ceux qui ont voté au
deuxième tour pour le président de la
République ne l'ont pas fait pour cette
raison est dans la perspective de cette
réforme loin de là et vous le savez
comme moi il m'apparaît donc nécessaire
de donner du temps à la mise en oeuvre
si elle était votée infinie à cette
réforme sur la fermeture des régimes
spéciaux et en particulier de celui de
la RATP et dès lors la date butoir de
septembre du 23 n'est pas acceptable et
ne peut ne peut permettre pas de
disposer du temps nécessaire à la
concertation avec les organisations
syndicales et patronales représentative
celle des agents en particulier les plus
concernés je voterai tout amendement dès
lors qui reportera cette date de mise en
oeuvre et permettra ainsi une réelle
concertation je vous remercie merci
monsieur la Mini
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre madame la Présidente de la
Commission mes chers collègues j'avais
honnêtement j'avais pas prévu
d'intervenir mais je le faire
modestement non parce que je dirais bon
comme beaucoup le savent je reste un
défenseur du ferroviaire la RATP en fait
partie comme la SNCF l'a fait c'était
rappelé sur les régimes historiques et
en 2018 j'étais le seul de mon groupe à
ne pas voter le pacte ferroviaire donc
après se conforme à mes convictions et
engagement et je respecte tout à fait
par un métier aussi et sympathie
l'ensemble des collègues de tous les
groupes et je souligne néanmoins tout le
travail qui a fait la commission des
affaires sociales la reporteur général
et le rapporteur je tiens aussi
sincèrement à le dire parce que en plus
vous avez fait plus de 30 ou auditions
donc je pense que là dessus vous êtes au
fait vous êtes très très compétent pour
l'ensemble de
l'ensemble des articles notamment cet
article premier et ces amendements et
c'est ces amendements qui visent à ne
pas fermer le régime spécial de la
retraite de la RATP puisque ça s'inscrit
dans cette première partie liée aux
recettes et je dirais concernant la
caisse de retraite du personnel de la
RATP on les chiffres je reprends les
chiffres que vous avez donné au niveau
de de la commission 42 42000 cotisons 50
000 environ pensionnés donc là dessus à
ce niveau là et je crois que vous avez
parlé des attractivité des métiers et
c'est vrai que c'est des métiers qui
sont de plus en plus difficiles et
compris pour les conducteurs de bus mais
ça vaut j'irai à l'échelon national
métropole ou autre je crois et surtout
les territoires c'est plus en plus
compliqué donc mais néanmoins je suivrai
la vie des rapporteurs
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai écouté attentivement
j'ai écouté attentivement la
l'intervention de Monsieur laminyle et
je l'invite et non non mais je l'invite
vraiment à renouveler ce type
d'intervention parce que il a donné des
explications venant d'un autre bord
politique qui nous font réfléchir donc
et
c'est très intéressant et en tous les
cas c'est beaucoup plus intéressant que
ce débat ou la droite qui est quand même
majoritaire dans l'hémicycle n'a rien à
dire en fait parce que parce qu'elle
attend son heure et ça montre que ce
qu'on discute aujourd'hui et que nous
propose le gouvernement n'est qu'un
cheval de Troie parce que la réalité
c'est pas que vous proposez que
progressivement les choses se fassent
c'est que vous ouvrez le chemin pour que
derrière La droite majoritaire dans
cette hémicycle viennent dire c'est tout
de suite qu'on supprime et plus de
clauses du grand-père donc cheval de
Troie mais c'est aussi une diversion
une version c'est que dans le pays tout
le monde a bien compris que ce dont on
discute et dont on va discuter pendant
deux semaines c'est de retarder pour
tout le monde l'âge de départ légal de
deux ans supplémentaires de 62 à 64 ans
c'est cela qu'on discute et c'est cela
qui suicide l'indignation majoritaire
dans le pays alors vous vous dites on va
essayer de monter ces Français les uns
contre les autres on leur disant que
finalement ça ne toucherait que quelques
privilégiés et que vous tous vous n'êtes
pas vraiment touché et vous essayez de
créer de l'agitation sur des soi-disant
nantis parmi les travailleurs or même
cela ça ne marche pas dans le débat et
c'est aussi pour cela que nous sommes
contre et nous sommes pour ces
amendements et compte que vous avez dit
et puis là puisqu'il s'agisse
spécifiquement de la RATP je le rappelle
nous sommes dans une situation en ce
moment catastrophique pour les
transports en ligne
et donc on ne peut pas à ce moment-là
rogner sur le statut de ces travailleurs
et à moindrir l'efficacité de ce service
public
madame le héros qui est le dernier
script explication de vote donc vous
souhaitez
fermer le régime spécial de la RATP or
un rapport de cesse de 2015 alerté et
alerte sur la concentration très élevée
en particulier
de métaux dans les couleurs du métro
dans les couloirs du métro les employés
du métro et des gares souterraines
courent un risque pour leur santé
pendant leur travail ce rapport de lande
cesse est très documenté sur le sujet
les conséquences sanitaires sur la santé
des agents sont réels risquerait
à cette exposition chronique des
travailleurs aux particules de l'air des
enceintes ferroviaires souterraines dans
les couloirs du métro et du RER or vous
n'avez pas prévu de rétablir les risques
chimiques ou l'exposition aux produits
dangereux que vous avez supprimé en 2017
je le rappelle parmi les critères de
pénibilité que vous devez revoir cette
réforme est donc injuste elle est
prématurée elle nécessite un travail
approfondi avec les organisations
syndicales c'est pourquoi je vote pour
cet amendement de suppression et contre
la fermeture du régime spécial
18 si vous nous rejoignez sur l'ANT le
public Sénat nous sommes en direct pour
suivre la réforme des retraites il y a
donc des amendements qui ont été déposés
par la gauche sénatoriale afin et bien
tout d'abord de supprimer l'article 1
qui lui-même supprime 5 régimes spéciaux
et puisque et bien ces amendements et
bien été battus ce matin la gauche a
donc ensuite déposé d'autres amendements
et donc on voit maintenant inscrit un
public qui est organisé dans l'hémicycle
du Sénat c'est à dire que les sénateurs
vont voter non pas à main levée sur
l'ensemble de ces amendements qui
concernent le régime spécial de la RATP
mais ils vont et bien effectivement
s'exprimer avec des bulletins
électroniques ce qui signifie que
lorsque tout le monde aura fini de voter
nous aurons et bien la cartographie de
l'ensemble du vote du Sénat sur ces
amendements qui visent donc à supprimer
les alinéas qui correspond le monde au
régime spécial des salariés de la RATP
sans grande surprise on va voir le même
clivage que depuis le début de l'examen
de la réforme des retraites c'est-à-dire
une droite et le centre au Sénat qui est
bien sûr qui soutiennent la réforme des
retraites et la gauche qui tente avec
les groupes écologistes socialistes et
communiste et bien de supprimer
certaines parties du texte mais qui n'y
parvient pas pour l'instant il va y
avoir donc comme cela le résultat du
scrutin dès que plus personne n'aura
demandé à voter retour dans l'hémicycle
votant 344 exprimés 340 pour de 98
contre 242 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
nous allons maintenant
consulter sur
les amendements
à partir de l'avendement 2715
consultation aura lieu à main levée pour
lequel la commission a donné à naviguer
favorable et le gouvernement défavorable
d'amende l'amendement 2715
quel est votre article nous sommes en
pleine procédure de
vous pouvez inventer un numéro mais
[Musique]
[Rires]
bon monsieur Lurel s'il vous plaît
oui oui oui bon
il s'agit pas d'une louve au cri c'est
bien alors petit 32 alinéa E4 que le
Sénat vous monsieur le Président vous
incarnez le Sénat vous pouvez décider
puisque il y a un silence et entretenu
en face que ils ont des secrets à se
partager le vrai notre langue Amélie
n'aurait peut-être pas eu à faire cette
intervention s'il avait été mis dans les
secrets que le Sénat peut se réunir d'un
comité secret que 35 sénateurs ou le
Gouvernement peut demander à se réunir
d'un comité secret voilà je vous demande
de mettre voir que ton sexe sénateur
puisse demander à nos collègues et je
fais ça au nom et pour le compte de mes
collègues
libéraux en fin disons de doigts voilà
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur puisque je suis l'incarnation
je rappelle que le comité se tient
pendant les périodes de guerre et je
pense que ça n'est pas encore la
situation de notre pays je vous demande
pas de ma revue je me suis le
président monsieur le Président s'il
vous permettez avec sur le ton de
l'humour vous le savez nous sommes en
guerre sociale j'estime ce l'équivalent
moral d'une guerre
mais oui mais oui et donc nous demandons
le comité secret il y a pas de débat
dans ce cas là alors nous passons au
vote amendement 2715 qui est pour
madame Lubin c'était votre amendement je
crois que vous êtes pour
ceux qui sont pour le manifeste qu'il
faut à votre clair en levant la main
avec le contraire
abstention il n'est pas adopté je pense
que pour le 318 il en serait de même
3019 non vous l'expliquez votre vote
3020 même vote
3021 même vote
3022 même vote non non c'est moi qui
commande 3023
m'évoque
3024 même vote 3025 même vote 3026 même
vote 3027 même vote 3028
identiques
3029 même vote 3030
même vote 3032 même vote 3033 même vote
3034 même vote 3035 même vote
336 même vote
3037 même vote
même vote
je suis maintenant saisi d'une demande
de scrutin public par le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste pour les amendements
identiques
3045 et 3913
je vous rappelle que la vie de la
commission défavorable la vie du
Gouvernement est défavorable il va être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement
le scrutin
sur l'antenne de public c'est né un
nouveau scrutin public a été demandé par
les communistes on le comprend assez
scrutin public Vienne ralentir la
procédure c'est à dire qu'au lieu
d'avoir un vote à main levée comme on
vient de l'avoir d'ailleurs sur une
dizaine d'amendements similaires
toujours sur le cas des salariés de la
RATP et bien là les communistes sont
demandés est-ce qu'il y a un scrutin
public sur deux de leurs amendements en
fin de l'examen de cette série
d'amendements on va ensuite passer à une
autre série d'amendements mais toujours
sur la question des régimes spéciaux on
passera au régime spécial des salariés
de à la Banque de France un mot sur le
fait que voilà cette gauche sénatoriale
use de tous les outils du règlement même
parfois les plus inconnues comme vient
de le faire Victorin à l'urel pour
s'opposer à cette réforme on va écouter
tout de même le scrutin le résultat du
scrutin
ok le scrutin est clou
votant 344 exprimé 340 pour 98 contre
242 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
nous allons procéder à l'examen de 47
amendements qui sont
identiques
nous allons commencer par l'amendement
madame briquet
qui voulait bien le présenter
c'est un amendement de suppression
d'alinéa
le régime spécial de retraite de la
Banque de France en effet la motivation
pour fermer ce régime particulier
interroge car outre le fait de mettre en
exergue certains régimes à titre
d'exemple il ne coûte pas mes rapports
au contribuables aujourd'hui si un
basculement le régime général était
entériné cela coûterait plus cher que la
situation actuelle alors même que
l'objet même de cette réforme a pour
seul but
on continue dans l'examen de ce texte
Mathias on tourne la page on ferme le
volet du métro parisien et maintenant on
attaque un autre volet du texte un autre
alinéa de l'article 1 sur les régimes
spéciaux consacrés donc aux salariés de
la Banque de France c'est bien cela
absolument Quentin il aura fallu
quasiment deux heures de débat sur ses
amendements visant à supprimer les
alinéas 1 et 2 de l'article 1 qui comme
vous l'avez dit concerne la les régimes
spécial de la RATP sont surprises le
vote a suivi les recommandations de la
Commission et du gouvernement à suivre
maintenant donc le régime spécial de la
Banque de France avec plus d'une
quarantaine d'amendements visant à
supprimer les alinéas qui le concernent
c'est un régime qui compte envir
7850 cotisants qui en comptait en tout
cas en 2021 pour plus de 17000
pensionnés un déséquilibre qui a coûté
en charge nette 546 millions d'euros à
la Banque de France dont le gouverneur
François Villeroy de Gallo a défendu le
mois dernier dans les pages du Figaro la
vertu car il s'agit selon lui d'un
régime autonome merci Mathias pour
toutes ces explications je vous propose
de retourner dans l'hémistique pour
écouter ces débats on se retrouve
et pas l'Opéra de Paris par exemple
on a défendu avec conviction et
pédagogie l'art de la répétition le
régime spécial de la RATP et demandez de
retarder la date d'application à 2048
les arguments déployés pour la RATP
valent pour tous les régimes spéciaux et
donc pour les régimes de retraite de la
Banque de France nous plaidons pour
qu'il ne soit pas fermé et que les
négociations aient lieu avec les
partenaires Aires sociaux je vous
remercie merci l'amendement 506 monsieur
chanterelle
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le présent
amendement propose de la suppression des
alinéas portant sur la fermeture du
régime spécial de retraite de la Banque
de France de manière cohérente nous
sommes fermement opposés à la
suppression de l'ensemble des régimes
spéciaux et évoqués dans cet article
premier car nous considérons que ces
mesures sont injustifiées à ce titre le
régime spécial de retraite de la Banque
de France est un exemple pertinent
largement excédentaire avec plus de 1,8
milliards d'euros reversés dans le pot
commun depuis 2020 ce régime spécial a
donc un impact positif certain pour la
préservation de notre modèle social et
une nouvelle fois ce régime est
excédentaire grâce à des surcotisations
actées collectivement par les cotisants
de ce régime les départs anticipés à 57
ans notamment ne concerne qu'une infime
partie des agents qui exercent les
activités les plus pénibles
de plus comme l’ont déjà rappelé
certains de mes collègues marqué malgré
le rôle central de cette institution
bicentenaire la Banque de France subit
une diminution constante de ses
effectifs et une dégradation continue
des conditions de travail notamment avec
une quasi stagnation des salaires alors
que le secteur privé possède déjà le
quasimonopole du secteur financier et
bancaire cette nouvelle attaque envers
les agents de la Banque de France risque
de profondément affecter le rôle joué
par cette institution que ce soit pour
la stratégie monétaire la stabilité
financière ou encore les services
économiques à la collectivité
ainsi mes chers collègues de la majorité
sénatoriale si votre objectif est de
réaliser des économies ne souprement pas
ce régime spécial qui est excédentaire
et bénéfique pour le bon fonctionnement
de cette institution
l'amendement 569 madame de La Gontrie
merci monsieur le Président donc cet
amendement comme ceux de mes collègues
qui ont précédé vise à ne pas fermer le
régime spécial de la Banque de France
puisque nous sommes défavorables à
l'intégralité de ce qui est proposé ici
de fermeture des régimes spéciaux mais
au-delà de cela je voudrais adresser un
message de solidarité à nos collègues
les vies Burgoa Paco logi Dufour
cadet de la pauvreté à la marque
Châtillon Perrault Morin de saillie et
Ingré qui ont déposé l'amendement 123
qui dit la même chose
et donc je voulais leur dire vous n'êtes
pas seul
l'amendement 582 monsieur Redon sarrazi
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues monsieur
ministre la question vous a déjà été
posée ce matin et à l'instant par mon
collègue fiché pourquoi avoir choisi
certains régimes sociaux pour leur
suppression
si vous reconnaissez que certains
peuvent
perdurer c'est que vous admettez que
certains secteurs d'activité méritent un
traitement différencié alors je vous
pose la question monsieur le ministre
ainsi qu'à vos soutiens de la majorité
sénatoriale pourquoi ne pas ouvrir la
réflexion pour de nouveaux métiers ou de
nouvelles activités
mais je crois que non cette cette
approche ne vous effleur même pas
vous ne vous interrogez pas sur le
quotidien de ceux qui sont en première
ligne ou même en deuxième ligne voir en
troisième ligne j'ai l'impression que
vous n'écoutez que ceux qui sont au
quartier général
donc nous demandons effectivement la
suppression de cette alinéa
merci monsieur le Président par cet
amendement nous souhaitons que le régime
spécial de la Banque de France soit
maintenue institution vieille de plus de
200 ans les fonctionnaires de la Banque
de France ont accepté depuis longtemps
de s'aligner sur le régime général de la
Fonction publique avec un taux de
cotisation de 11,10 % et la suppression
en 2007 de la majoration de leur pension
de retraite malgré ses efforts consentis
le gouvernement veut continuer de
pénaliser ses agents le régime de
retraite des salariés de la Banque de
France s'autofinance grâce à des
investissements et la caisse qui le gère
peut verser 100% des promesses de
retraite faites aux agents il
s'équilibre de lui-même entre la
cotisation des agents
7850 cotisants en 2021 celle de
l'employeur et les réserves accumulées
pendant 215 ans ce régime est
excellentaire le montant des réserves
atteignait 15,4 milliards d'euros fin
2021 le régime est même à même versé des
accidents à la collectivité ces trois
dernières années l'âge légal de départ à
la retraite est d'ailleurs de 62 ans
pour tous les agents de la Banque de
France pourtant vous voulez le remettre
en cause alors même que le alors même
que le coup de son intégration au régime
général représenterait des sommes plus
importantes que celles qui rapportent
aujourd'hui à l'état si ce que nous
demandons c'est que une concertation
puisse avoir lieu avec les organisations
syndicales qui ont découvert la nouvelle
dans la presse je crois que c'est
inacceptable si les organisations
sociales et syndical donc devait
conclure à cette fermeture le temps
n'est pas venu dans ce PLFSS
rectificatif pour 2023 donc laissons la
négociation se faire
la triche comptable
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues l'article
premier supprime pour les agents
recrutés à partir du 1er septembre 2023
les régimes spéciaux de retraite de
certaines entités nous avons demandé la
suppression de cet article donc on toute
cohérence nous demandons la suppression
de ces alinéas 3 et 4 qui visent à ne
pas fermer afin de ne pas fermer le
régime spécial de la Banque de France ce
régime spécial ne correspond à aucun
privilège pour les hommes les femmes de
cette institution qui partent en
retraite à 62 ans comme tout le monde
avec la même durée de cotisations un
départ anticipé existe mais extrêmement
marginal et ne justifie pas à lui seul
la suppression de ce régime spécial ce
régime spécial comme l'indiqué le
gouverneur de la Banque de France
et un régime autonome elle dispose même
d'une réserve de 15,4 milliards d'euros
cette institution a déployée
d'importance efforts pour assurer
l'efficience la maîtrise des coûts des
services avec une baisse des effectifs
de 25% au prix d'une dégradation
continue des conditions de travail et
avec une modération salariale qui est la
règle depuis 2007 et finalement comment
remercie-t-on ces personnels en
annonçant la fin de leur régime spécial
par voie de presse sans concertation
préalable supprimer ce régime revient
donc à dire aux agents qu'ils auraient
été gagnants à ne faire aucun effort je
vous remercie merci Monsieur Jacquin
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues monsieur le ministre je
comprends mal certaines logiques de
cette réforme je connais très mal le
statut des agents de la Banque de France
je connaissais nettement mieux ceux de
la SNCF et de la RATP pour lequel je me
suis exprimé tout à l'heure mais là
devant ces incertitudes c'est
incompréhension je pense que plutôt que
des logiquement tout supprimer ou
certains régimes spéciaux monsieur le
ministre vous seriez mieux disposé et
inspiré de retirer cette réforme de
reprendre de véritables négociations
avec les partenaires sociaux et
d'étudier profession par profession
l'opportunité de revenir intégralement
ou en partie sur certains régimes 10
spéciaux une bonne réforme des retraites
d'une réforme qui a lit sauvegarde de la
répartition et Progrès Social pas qui
stigmatise certains et qui monte les
Français les uns contre les autres je
vous remercie merci amendement 898
monsieur Durel
si Monsieur le retour en salle des
conférences ici au Sénat j'accueil sur
ce plateau Marc Philippe de Bresse
bonjour vous êtes sénateur LR du Nord un
mot sur ce qui se joue dans l'hémicycle
certains de vos collègues nous ont dit
par exemple qu'ils avaient le sentiment
d'avoir plutôt un monologue de la gauche
qu'un débat véritable sur les régimes
spéciaux écoutez la gauche bon d'abord
elle se comporte de manière civile et
respectueuse et aussi c'est quand même
mieux que les ébulons de l'Assemblée
nationale mais sur le fond qu'est-ce
qu'ils font ils font des amendements
identiques
qu'il défendent les uns derrière les
autres pour dire la même chose et
derrière ils ont je ne sais combien
d'explications de votes moi j'en suis à
ma cinquième réforme des retraites comme
je suis un parlementaire qui a quelques
heures de vol et je me souviens d'avoir
présidé une séance quand j'étais
vice-président de l'Assemblée nationale
ou on accepte que un orateur par groupe
sur les explications de votre parce que
ce qui est intéressant évidemment le
peuple de France c'est de savoir quels
sont les arguments échangés et
évidemment à partir du moment où les
rapporteurs qui sont excellents
Madame doanneau et Monsieur Savary
donnent la position majoritaire de la
commission la réponse est faite vous
voulez donc on ne va pas aller dans des
débats qui vont s'éterniser parce que si
le but c'est qu'on ne vote pas cette loi
au final nous c'est pas notre but nous
nous voulons que la loi qui est celle du
Sénat c'est à dire ce n'est pas celle du
gouvernement le Sénat va fortement
améliorer cette loi que cette loi soit
votée au final mais ça veut dire que
mise à part les parlementaires de gauche
il y a que la Commission qui dans ce
débat sur les régimes sociaux la droite
n'a rien à dire à part pour ce qui est
malade pour les centrist la droite de
représentant la majorité sénateur si on
avait ce que je vous ai je viens de vous
dire qui se passe de temps en temps et
que le règlement permet c'est-à-dire un
orateur pour un orateur contre
évidemment que on aurait un orateur qui
viendrait être contre les amendements de
suppression de la gauche mais là en
l'occurrence c'est le but est de faire
traîner les choses en longueur on va pas
tomber dans ce piège de rajouter du
temps au temps on a dit les choses si on
veut justifier un effort important des
Français pas ça 64 ans c'est un effort
important demandé aux Français si on
veut justifier l'effort il faut
fortifier la justice du texte donc nous
ce qui nous intéresse c'est la suite
c'est à dire qu'on peut qu'on puisse
faire plus pour les maires de famille
qu'on puisse clarifier le dispositif des
carrières l'ont compris scarifier les
questions de pénibilité et qu'au final
on est plus de justice parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est profondément juste
expliqué moi puisqu'on parle de régime
spéci pourquoi un conducteur d'autobus
tu en m'a métropole lilloise lui il est
condamné à avoir un régime comme tous
les Français et que la RATP ils peuvent
partir entre 52 et 57 ans il y a une
injustice profonde et donc il faut
réparer cette injustice peut-être que
les Français effectivement regrettent
qu'il n'y ait pas ce genre d'échange
effectivement dans l'hémicycle un mot
sur le texte du Gouvernement la droite
et le centre va le soutenir là on en a
maintenant la quasi certitude il y a
tous ces votes qui sont comme d'un bloc
sur les scrutins publics la droite et le
centre vont soutenir le texte du Sénat
il y a pas eu de vote à l'Assemblée
nationale et donc c'est le texte qui
aurait été profondément modifié par le
Sénat avec un principe bien sûr qu'on va
soutenir le principe du départ à 64 ans
et bien sûr qu'on va avoir des mesures
compensatrices pour toute une série de
catégories qui sont les plus pénalisés
et nous allons beaucoup vous le savez
mettre l'accent sur les maires de
famille et là on va s'exprimer on va
s'exprimer beaucoup pour expliquer
comment on peut des injustices
aujourd'hui le système est profondément
injuste il faut le rendre plus juste
nous appelons à apprendre notre mal en
patience sur cet article premier parce
que
vous comprenez bien que si nous passons
beaucoup beaucoup de temps à répondre la
même chose à des amendements identiques
on aura plus assez de temps pour pouvoir
justement justifier nos amendements qui
sont pas que l'article cet après
l'article 7 il en reste 13 et ils sont
très importants merci Max Philippe de
Brest pour cette réaction microflux
direct dans l'hémicycle d'un second qui
vise à la fermeture de 14 quais
supplémentaires du fait de la diminution
drastique de l'utilisation des espèces
au quotidien par nos concitoyens la
Banque de France est ainsi passée de 20
000 salariés à
9290 en 10 ans vous imaginez donc
l'effort d'adaptation qui a été demandé
aux salariés la Banque de France rend
des services d'intérêt général en
assurant une médiation du crédit en four
des analyses de conjoncture et en
réalisant des cotations économiques et
financières d'entreprises de
collectivités territoriales dont on
bénéficie d'ailleurs ou de territoires
pour les particuliers elle gère les
fichiers centraux de renseignements et
traitent notamment les cas de
surendettement ainsi que le droit
d'accès aux comptes qu'on appelle
tribuellement les interdits bancaires
les métiers de la banque de France
nécessitent de l'expertise de haut
niveau dans un contexte où les
compétences financières sont très
recherchées par des cabinets privés de
cotation l'attractivité du statut est un
gage d'indépendance et permet à la
Banque de France d'assumer dans de
bonnes conditions ces missions de
service public il ne faut pas toucher au
statut
monsieur Hublet
mais oui
dis donc
je vais descendre à mon tour
le sujet du maintien de ce régime
autonome de retraite de la Banque de
France permettrait après avoir évoqué un
prédécesseur de faire écho à ce que
vient de nous dire un de mes successeurs
le président rénal président de la
commission des finances je partage
absolument son analyse mais j'ai été
totalement conforté dans cette
conviction en lisant un courrier qui
vous a été adressé monsieur le ministre
par le gouverneur François Villeroy de
Gallo le gouverneur de la Banque de
France qui n'est autant qu'en puissance
juger ni un dangereux gauchiste ni un
insoumis et
défendant le maintien de ce régime pour
ses salariés il ajoute à la fin du
courrier de sa main manuscritement je
suis naturellement
à disposition sur ce sujet mineur au
regard de la réforme d'ensemble mais
essentiel pour la Banque de France et la
poursuite de sa transformation donc en
fait c'est juste un enjeu de dynamique
propre à cette institution bancaire tout
à fait essentielle que nous avons à
examiner maintenant donc on peut
méconnaître ça faire dans un esprit que
je qualifierais de démagogique à l'égard
de l'opinion publique le sacrifice d'un
régime particulier de retraite mais il
faut bien mesurer ce qu'on fait et les
conséquences que ça peut avoir sur le
fonctionnement d'un certain nombre
d'institutions tout à fait essentielles
dans notre République donc si ce régime
existe ce n'est pas pour privilégier je
ne sais quelle catégorie mais c'est
simplement parce que des discussions
avec des salariés qui assument un
service public a conduit à un moment
donné à considérer que c'était par le
biais d'un régime autonome qu'on pouvait
satisfaire des revendications légitimes
des salariés
madame Lubin
merci monsieur le Président nous sommes
sur un projet de loi de finance
rectification de la sécurité sociale ça
a été
largement argumenté ici et donc ce
projet de loi de finance il a été
imaginé par le gouvernement juste pour
[Musique]
reculer l'âge de la retraite pour la
majorité des salariés de se priver de ce
pays les salariés du privé et on a
l'impression quand même que dans le
cadre de ce projet de loi de finance le
gouvernement et c'est de
j'avais envie de dire régler des comptes
non je sais pas réglé des comptes mais
en tout cas
régler des situations que la droite de
ce pays a en travers de la gorge depuis
un moment c'est-à-dire les régimes
spéciaux alors la longuement parlé de
celui de la RATP on parlera de celui des
gaziers puis là au milieu on trouve ce
petit régime spécial qui celui de la
Banque de France alors évidemment la
Banque de France on imagine que ce sont
des gens effectivement qui doivent
travailler dans des conditions
plutôt bonne on imagine que c'est pas
les mêmes que les chauffeurs de bus ou
de métro ou que les gaziers ça on
imagine bien même si on imagine aussi
que pour un certain nombre d'entre eux
il y a une charge mentale importante je
parle de ceux qui occupent bien sûr les
responsabilités les plus importantes
mais on se demande quand même qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont bien pu faire pour que tout
d'un coup alors qui demande rien à
personne et que leur système de retraite
est excédentaire et qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
bien pu faire pour que au détour de ce
projet de loi de finances rectificative
on vienne régler le compte de leur
système de retraite donc nous demandons
la suppression effectivement de cette
alinéa madame jasmin
merci monsieur le Président dans la
suite de sous ce qui a été dit je crois
que nous sommes dans une situation où
nous jetons la suspicion sur les
salariés de la Banque de France et
quelquefois ici même au Sénat nous avons
vu que le gouvernement a privilégié des
cabinets conseils
donc on doit se poser des vraies
questions le maintien des régimes des
salariés de la Banque de France
est important il n'y a pas de
contribution de l'État l'impact
financier est neutre pour la
collectivité donc je crois qu'il est
nécessaire justement de privilégier le
dialogue social de maintenir ce régime
qui est excédentaire et exemplaire je
dirais même donc je ne vois pas pourquoi
mais vraiment pourquoi on veut
faire de ces agents des personnes qui
comme on l'a dit n'ont rien demandé mais
pour lesquels il y aurait une véritable
suspicion et peut-être même une punition
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues monsieur le ministre
voilà de nouveau tels comme vous-même
pour fendeur casseurs je devrais dire de
tous les statuts en tant que protecteur
en effet pour la Banque de France vous
prenez l'équilibre du régime général
tout en supprimant sa caisse autonome
qui n'a rien à voir avec les côtes de la
sécurité sociale je vous pose donc la
question monsieur le ministre pourquoi
mettre fin aux acquis sociaux lorsqu'ils
n'ont rien d'anormal lorsqu'ils
profitent au bénéficiaire sans pénaliser
personne et c'est le cas ici
ce régime de la Banque de France est
protecteur et profitable à tous les
salariés de l'institution surtout sa
transparence et son autonomie de gestion
permettent une efficacité que vous
connaissez et qui ne peut donc fonder
son extinction ce régime n'est pas le
privilège de quelques-uns absolument pas
il s'inscrit dans le contrat national en
matière de service public il n'y a
absolument aucune raison de le supprimer
merci Madame Fréville merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre Michel
collègue cet amendement vise à ne pas
fermer le régime spécial de la retraite
de la Banque de France ce régime
autonome ne présentant aucun risque
financier puisqu'il n'est pas fait appel
à des compléments des finances publiques
et même on apprend que c'est tout le
contraire qu'il était excellentaire quel
est le sens de cette fermeture cela
paraît incompréhensible pourquoi prendre
d'ailleurs quelques régimes spéciaux
dont celui-ci les données en quelque
sorte en pâture c'est pour le moins une
manière assez singulière de procéder
parce que finalement c'est si facile de
stigmatiser cela a des relents aller de
démagogie voire même de populisme le
courage était de tout mettre sur la
table cette façon de viser certains
métiers et de livrer à la vindicte et
détestable vraiment une réforme des
retraites ne peut confiner à du travail
mal fait est-ce aléatoire un tirage au
sort pourquoi pourquoi sont-ils des
boucs émissaires s'agit-il juste du
terme du mot banque
en fait le monde a changé profondément
rien que ces deux trois dernières années
et Anthony vous compte de nouvelles
souffrances au travail sont apparues en
lien d'ailleurs avec le vécu des
transformations récentes des
restructurations on a pu observer des
surinvestissement dans la vie
professionnelle qui ont pu mener jusqu'à
des burn out les impératifs de
productivité ont été de plus en plus
prégnants et si tout cela c'était trop
il nous faut réfléchir à ces réalités
nouvelles qui génère des cours en forts
qui traversent nos sociétés et qui ont
des conséquences que tout le monde peut
voir des démissions des changements de
métiers et des changements de choix de
vie donc tout cela nous devons le
regarder bien en face
monsieur le Président merci de me donner
la parole monsieur le ministre chers
collègues cet amendement vise à ne pas
fermer le régime spécial de retraite de
la Banque de France car comme j'ai pu
l'exprimer tout à l'heure nous rejetons
en bloc votre stratégie de nivellement
par le bas qui s'appuie sur la division
des Français qui par ailleurs mettent en
vous mettent en minorité sur ce texte
oui nivellement par le bas quand il
s'agit de supprimer les différents
régimes spéciaux car cela ne permettra
pas d'aboutir à une égalité entre les
Français c'est un leur c'est pourquoi
nous nous opposons tout point à la
suppression des régimes spéciaux
l'urgence n'est pas là aujourd'hui il
faut protéger les français qui sont en
grande difficulté mais pour ceux qui
concerne le régime de retraite de la
Banque de France c'est véritablement un
cas d'école car c'est un régime autonome
qui est aujourd'hui excédentaire et n'a
donc rien à voir avec votre projet de
loi de finances qui suppose une économie
par ailleurs l'âge de la retraite qui
est de 62 ans un départ anticipé à 57
ans y est effectivement prévu mais il ne
concerne que les métiers pénibles et
restent plus que marginal au sein de la
Banque de France ensuite il ne faut pas
oublier que cette caisse a dégagé de
forts excédents depuis 2020 au total 30
milliards d'euros reversés à l'État
depuis 2014 de fait alors même que la
présente réforme en vouloir réduire un
soi-disant déficit un basculement vers
le régime général coûterait dès lors
plus cher que la situation actuelle et à
la lumière de ce constat donc je vous
invite à voter la suppression des alinés
à trois et quatre de cet article premier
je vous remercie
monsieur le président
un des argument du gouvernement pour
justifier la suppression de certains
régimes spéciaux de retraite seraient
leur coûts et Monsieur le soft viennent
d'évoquer tout à l'heure par rapport à
la RATP mais le régime de la Banque de
France est un régime autonome et
financièrement excellentaire avec celle
bien d'être évoqué une réversion de
plusieurs milliards reversés à la
collectivité nationale depuis quelques
années de fait un basculement vers le
régime général coûterait plus cher que
la situation actuelle de plus le régime
spécial de la Banque de France ne
correspond à aucun privilège puisque les
hommes et les femmes qui travaillent la
Banque de France partent à la retraite à
72 ans comme le reste de la population
et avec le même nombre dans l'unité de
cotisations
enfin ce qu'il faut remarquer ce qu'il
n'y a eu aucune concertation aucune
rencontre avec les organisations
syndicales et les personnels ont appris
par voie de Prince leur sort quel mépris
pourtant la Banque de France a fait des
efforts importants avec une émission des
effectifs de 25% depuis 2015 aggravant
les conditions de travail mais
l'acceptation de ces efforts n'a été
possible pour les agenda Banque de
France comme contrepartie de maintenir
leur régime de retraite et aujourd'hui
vous leur dites comme tout le monde à 64
ans c'est inacceptable
Monsieur le Comte
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues pourquoi un
régime autonome et pas un autre pourquoi
un régime spécial épineux on a
l'impression en écoutant les exposés
progressifs de ces amendements de
suppression que finalement le Conseil
des ministres qui se réunit pour
finalement établir la liste des régimes
qui seraient visés par cette suppression
finalement fonctionnent un peu comme une
salle de casino ou le gars ou le hasard
gouverne
pourquoi celui-là et pas celui-là alors
bien entendu notre système est un peu
complexe avec 33 régimes complémentaires
et et et et et généraux
toutefois il faut respecter l'histoire
de chacun de ces régimes histoire de
tous ceux qui se sont engagés dans tel
ou tel carrière et par conséquent il
n'est pas acceptable sans concertation
de supprimer un régime surtout quand on
ne comprend pas ou plutôt qu'on veut
faire là encore main basse sur une
cagnotte mais bon en fait à la fin le
mieux serait non pas de supprimer les
régimes un par un au gré donc c'est quel
explication parce que rien n'explique
que ce soit celui-là et pas un autre
mais de travailler tranquillement à ce
que parce que les carrières aujourd'hui
ne sont plus linéaires à pouvoir passer
d'un régime à un autre sans être
finalement handicapé par le fait d'être
polypensionné plutôt que de fonctionner
de cette manière là de manière
totalement
erratique sans que nous comprenions la
stratégie du gouvernement c'est la
raison pour laquelle faute d'avoir une
stratégie claire il est préférable de
conserver le système tel qu'il est je
suis le président kaner monsieur le
Président Monsieur ministre mes chers
collègues effectivement je m'associe
aussi à la demande de suppression de ces
alinéas visant à fermer le régime
autonome de la Banque de France
mon collègue Leconte vient d'évoquer
cette question de la main basse sur la
cagnotte mais finalement la main sur la
clignote elle est déjà faite tous les
ans à peu près 2 milliards d'euros sont
reversés à la collectivité nationale
donc vraiment c'est incompréhensible
enfin voilà RATP il peut y avoir entre
guillemets des Roland idéologiques et
dogmatiques en la matière on l'a c'est
un régime qui ne pose pas de problème
qui l'embête personne qui fonctionne
très bien avec des collaborateurs qui
ont déjà fait des efforts notamment à
partir de 2015 donc voilà on ne comprend
pas monsieur le ministre et peut-être
que vous allez pouvoir nous y nous y
répondre je rappelle que la Banque de
France a connu une baisse d'effective de
25% depuis 2015 donc des conditions de
travail qui se sont dégradés sur le plan
de effectivement de
qu'on pourrait imaginer dans une sorte
de fantasme les efforts ne s'arrêtent
pas là puisque la modération salariale
et la règle d'or depuis 2017 or ce
régime autonome fait partie
effectivement des éléments d'attrait
pour intégrer la Banque de France donc
manifestement on est à côté de la plaque
par rapport à l'objectif que nous
dénonçons mais que vous poursuivez de
suppression des régimes spéciaux donc
nous souhaitons la suppression de ces
deux alinéas monsieur Assouline
oui moi je veux montrer vraiment et ma
bonne volonté le fait que quand tout a
été dit c'est pas la peine d'en rajouter
et donc je vais pas argumenter plus
longtemps sur ce fameux régime spécial
mais si monsieur Étienne blanc oui merci
monsieur le Président et j'ai déposé un
amendement et visant à supprimer ces
annuler à 3 et 4 dans la droite ligne de
l'amendement que j'avais déposé hier sur
l'article préliminaire c'est pour que
nous puissions parler et du régime de
capitalisation ça n'est pas obsessionnel
mais je crois que dans une loi de
finances de la sécurité sociale on peut
difficilement éviter de parler de ce
sujet
supprimer ce régime spécifique de la
Banque de France moi je pense que c'est
une erreur c'est une erreur d'abord
parce que c'est un régime qui est calé
sur le régime général on prend sa
retraite à 62 ans comme le font un grand
nombre de Français
c'est un régime qui est un régime de
capitalisation et nous sommes un certain
nombre à penser que le régime de
capitalisation est moins fragile que le
régime de répartition pour les raisons
de démographie que l'on connaît dont on
a suffisamment parlé
c'est un régime qui verse au Trésor
public un excédent et ils sont pas si
nombreux que cela en France il verse au
Trésor public un excédent et c'est un
régime qui ne demande rien au
contribuable
alors supprimer ce régime
c'est quand même quelque chose
d'assez curieux à une époque où on se
pose la question de l'équilibre de nos
comptes
sociaux
j'observe que si on avait géré de la
même manière la retraite des
fonctionnaires avec le même dispositif
le budget de la France ferait une
économie de l'ordre de 50 milliards et
puis enfin comme parfois il faut faire
un peu de politique mais c'est un régime
qui nous permet de constater ce qu'est
une véritable conversion de la gauche
jamais jamais je n'aurais entendu madame
linman défendre avec autant de
conviction un régime de capitalisation
jamais mon excellent collègue président
Bocquet je n'aurais vu défendre avec
autant de vigueur un régime de
capitalisation prise en Laurent vous
avez eu des mots extraordinaires pour
défendre la capitalisation tout cela
sous l'autorité du président rénal
décidément il se passe quelque chose cet
après-midi au Sénat d'Asset exceptionnel
madame
[Applaudissements]
cuckermann pour l'amendement
3906 de suppression des mêmes alinéa
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues effectivement
il s'agit peut-être d'ailleurs plus
qu'un régime spécial d'un régime
pionnier puisque cela n'aura échappé à
personne créer huit ans après la Banque
de France se régime pionnier date de
2808 et donc bien avant du régime
général des retraites créées au
lendemain de la guerre en 1945 je veux
peut-être rassurer mon collègue Étienne
blanc
ou peut-être inverser les rôles
effectivement il aura fallu attendre
dans cet article premier
la situation des agents et du système de
la Banque de France pour enfin que nous
puissions avoir des amendements communs
et je crois que nous pouvons que nous en
féliciter mais au-delà de l'ironie je
crois que ça démontre une chose
fondamentale c'est que justement s'il y
a eu à travers l'histoire régime
pionnier régime spéciaux c'est bien
parce qu'il y a parfois des spécificités
qui doivent tant sur le mode de
financement tant sur la reconnaissance
de pénibilité être parfois un peu
parfois un peu plus dissocier du régime
général et donc
défendre ici et maintenant le maintien
de ce régime de la Banque de France
n'est pas demandé une généralisation en
tout cas pour ma part de ce système par
capitalisation à l'ensemble des salariés
de notre pays mais en tout cas de
préserver un système qui existe parce
qu'il comprit il n'aurait pas d'intérêt
économique si ce n'est peut-être pour
l'État mais je n'oserais vous accuser de
ça monsieur le ministre récupérer
l'excédent de cette caisse des retraites
au service du budget de l'État alors
maintenant je vais consulter pour avoir
la vie de la Commission sur l'ensemble
de ces amendements qui ont fait l'objet
d'une discussion commune madame la
rapporteur général
je crois que les uns et les autres ont
donné beaucoup d'éléments concernant la
Banque de France
j'essaierai de m'appuyer sur quelques
éléments complémentaires tout simplement
pour dire que déjà je ne sais plus qui
disait est-ce des privilégiés je pense
qu'il faut pas regarder les choses de ce
côté-là on l'a jamais d'ailleurs
utilisé ce terme ni même dans la
Commission et donc c'est simplement
regarder de quoi il s'agit en réalité
ces agents sont des agents
administratifs sauf que il y a aussi
deux centres industriels qui produisent
les billets de banque donc on voit bien
qu'il y a des métiers un petit peu
différents mais là où il y a une
particularité c'est qu'en fait il y a
aujourd'hui
7852 cotisants
pour
14647 pensionnés de droits directs et on
y ajoute 2972 pensionnés de droits
dérivés ce qui veut dire que c'est là
finalement que qu'il y a des équilibres
en quelque sorte beaucoup de pensions à
distribuer pour peu de cotisants alors
c'est vrai il y a cette subvention
d'équilibre qui fait que les recettes
sont au même niveau que les dépenses
mais il faut aussi dire que c'est à
hauteur de 87% que cet équilibre est
atteint par la contribution d'équilibre
de l'employeur alors on va pas raconter
l'histoire de la Banque de France qui a
versé moins de dividendes à un moment
donné et qui se retrouvent aujourd'hui
avec plus de moyens mais en réalité ce
régime spécial c'est ce déséquilibre qui
explique
au bout du bout il y aura pas toujours
peut-être les moyens de compenser cette
différence et que donc aujourd'hui il
est proposé d'y mettre enfin en tout cas
de fermer
ce régime spécial
la commission ayant eu un avis favorable
sur cette proposition de du projet de
loi sur cet article 1 a donc mis un avis
défavorable sur l'ensemble de ces
amendements monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président de la vie du
gouvernement et défavorable peut-être
que cette explication me permet de
souligner trois points le premier pour
dire que contrairement à ce que j'ai
entendu à quelques reprises le régime de
retraite de la Banque de France et bien
un régime spécial il apparaît au 9e
alinéa de l'article r711-1 du code de la
sécurité sociale et c'est un article
liste les régimes que l'on qualifie de
régime spéciaux avec dans les
différentes mentions tous ceux que nous
sommes amenés à examiner aujourd'hui et
encore le régime de la SNCF au titre de
la clause de grand-père la deuxième
observation que je voulais faire
concerne la capacité que ce régime et
son employeur de référence ont à verser
à l'état quand la situation financière
est bonne des excédents et donc des
financements rien de ce que nous faisons
ne remet en cause cette capacité là rien
parce que les excédents qui sont versés
le son lorsque les produits des
placements financiers qui sont l'actif
du régime spécial de retraite permettent
à la fois de couvrir des dépenses de
pension et par ailleurs d'apporter une
forme de participation de de versement
exceptionnel à l'état le maintien de ce
qu'on appelle communément la clause de
grand-père et donc l'extinction
extrêmement progressive avec le maintien
au profit du régime des actifs et des
réserves comme nous le faisons pour
chaque régime spécial que nous mettons
en extinction nous aurons l'occasion de
le dire dans d'autres
circonstances j'imagine tout cela fait
que cette capacité Cora qu'à le régime a
versé des excédents à l'état qu'on s'est
possible reste tout à fait acquise il y
a un troisième point que je voulais
souligner qui est comme en réalité le
régime général est déjà quelque chose de
très familier des personnels de la
Banque de France madame leur rapporteur
général l'a dit nous avons un
déséquilibre avec 8000 cotisants pour
14000 pensionnés mais lorsque nous
regardons le ce que nous regardons ce
qui se passe pour les nouvelles
emballages de la Banque de France
l'établissement recrute entre 300 et 400
personnes par an
sur ces 300 à 400 personnes les trois
quarts sont recrutés comme contractuel
et donc seul InCar est recruté comme
titulaire c'est-à-dire bénéficiaire du
régime spécial de retraite et j'ajoute
que si vous êtes recruté comme titulaire
à la Banque de France et que pour une
raison ou une autre vous travaillez
moins de 15 ans pour l'établissement et
que vous quittez l'établissement pour
gagner un autre employeur vous êtes
reversé au régime général et vous perdez
toute forme d'acquis au titre du régime
spécial et en réalité l'extinction à
laquelle nous procédons permet aussi de
rétablir une forme d'égalité y compris
parmi les actuels recrutés de la Banque
de France et enfin un dernier point pour
confirmer les propos de Madame la
rapporteur général et j'avais souligné
ce paradoxe si l'on peut dire en tout
cas cette situation un peu
contre-intuitive il s'agit d'un régime
de capitalisation qui est défendu à
l'Assemblée nationale comme ici par les
groupes de golf de capitalisation
collective mais le capitalisation le
régime certains 150 millions d'euros de
recettes de retraite par an et sur ces
550 millions d'euros de retraite seul 40
millions sont assurés par des
cotisations soit 7%. tout le reste et le
produit est plus exactement les
dividendes de placement financiers c'est
le prof de la capitalisation sur les
marchés financiers on peut avouer et
rejoindre en cela l'observation
d'Etienne blanc qui viennent une
situation un peu contre-intuitive en
tant que tout cela la vie est
défavorable
alors j'ai été saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public par le groupe par le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste sur les amendements
identiques numéro 343 et suivant je
rappelle que la vie de la commission
défavorable la vie du gouvernement et
défavorable madame ponce pour
explication de vote
Monsieur Laurent Madame linman et
Monsieur Laurent oui merci monsieur le
Président moi personnellement je fais
quand même une petite différence
entre les cinq situations qui nous sont
présentées ici effectivement vous avez
les régimes spéciaux dont on parle
souvent et RATP effectivement
vous avez compris comment ça fonctionne
maintenant depuis le début de
l'après-midi il y a des dépôts
d'amendement venu largement de la gauche
des amendements de suppression afin bien
d'empêcher certains aspects de la
réforme des retraites en l'occurrence là
on s'est arrêté sur le régime spécial
des salariés de la Banque de France mais
avant cela on avait celui de la RATP et
avant cela on avait tous les régimes
spéciaux et qui sont supprimés dans la
réforme des retraites l'idée pour la
gauche étant de supprimer la suppression
et donc de conserver on le comprend ces
régimes spéciaux pour en parler on
rejoint Mathias sarez et quelle est la
particularité des échanges sur
effectivement
cette cette salarié de la Banque de
France bien écoutez c'est les alinéas
trois et quatre de l'article 1 qui sont
débattus depuis un peu plus d'une heure
maintenant ici ce sont les alinéas qui
concernent vous l'avez dit les salariés
de la Banque de France qui bénéficient
d'un régime spécial un régime par
capitalisation qui compte environ
7850 cotisants pour à peu près
17000 pensionnés c'est un régime par
capitalisation je l'ai dit qui donc
lorsqu'il est excédentaire reverse les
excédents au Trésor Public cela
représentait plusieurs millions d'euros
en 2021 c'est un régime qui a été
défendu par son gouverneur François
Villeroy de Gallo le mois dernier dans
les pages du Figaro il a expliqué que
c'était un régime vertueux car il
s'agissait d'un régime autonome ce qui a
emmené donc les bancs gauche de
l'hémicyclass s'interroger en disant on
imagine que les salariés de la Banque de
France ne travaillent pas dans des
conditions difficiles comme les
chauffeurs de bus ce sont les mots de
Monique Lubin qui a ensuite interrogé en
se demande ce qu'ils ont bien pu faire
alors que leur système est excellentaire
fait un petit peu original aussi il y a
eu un sénateur LRD pardon qui a pris la
parole il s'agit d'Etienne blanc qui lui
aussi a défendu ce système on le sait
Étienne blanc est plutôt favorable au
régime par capitalisation il a donc
c'était une voix un petit peu dissonante
lors des débats merci Mathias pour
toutes ces explications donc il y a eu
le dépôt de ces amendements très
nombreux à un venu de la gauche surtout
un de la gauche même si vous notiez
celui des tiennes blancs pour les LR et
le passe maintenant non pas au vote sur
ces amendements puisque il y a avant
cela des explications de vote qui se
multiplient également façon pour la
gauche là encore d'occuper le terrain
sur ce débat sur la réforme des
retraites à l'égalité républicaine de
mettre tout le monde sur la même toise
la critique que nous faisons du système
de capitalisation donc si je puis dire
c'est un système résiduel qui ne coûte
rien à l'état qui donne satisfaction
excusez du peu pour une fois avec
quelque chose qui semble donner
satisfaction pourquoi le changer
mais la question de la capitalisation et
d'un autre ordre
car ce que nous refusons c'est le
basculement de l'actuel répartition vers
la capitalisation on peut avoir ce débat
personnellement je suis prête à mener je
pourrais vous donner 25 exemples de
comment les retraites en Suède aux
grandes Bretagne ont fondu comme neige
au soleil au moment de la crise
financière etc on peut avoir ce débat il
est légitime
mais alors chers collègues républicains
on peut pas d'un côté nous mettre la
main sur le cœur tout ce qu'on fait
c'est pour sauver le régime de
répartition pour en réalité
préparer les conditions d'un basculement
massif vers la capitalisation si vous
voulez assumer ça dites-le vraiment et
pas par la petite porte pas par la porte
de la détérioration du système général
et ensuite pour nous expliquer que comme
vous partez ta retraite comme vous avez
passé de retraite
faites donc de la capitalisation vous
êtes dans ce jeu basculement qui n'est
pas honnête qui n'est pas normale pour
conclure vous étudier
président Laurent
[Applaudissements]
oui trois remarques la première c'est
que je pense que les arguments
soi-disant comptables ou financiers
avancés par Madame la rapporteur et
Monsieur le Ministre on peut de valeur
en l'occurrence je cite le gouverneur de
la Banque de France je pense que c'est
un homme qui sait un peu compter
il dit ce régime ne correspond à aucun
privilège des hommes et des femmes de la
Banque de France qui partent en retraite
à 62 ans comme tout le monde avec la
même durée de cotisation la différence
est qu'il est provisionné dans nos
comptes donc en fait c'est un régime
autonome plutôt vertueux donc ce régime
il est soutenu par les syndicats de la
Banque de France et par le gouverneur de
la Banque de France et sa gestion et
vertueuse premièrement deuxièmement non
ça n'est pas un régime par
capitalisation sont sous volonté chers
collègues Étienne blanc puisqu'il repose
sa base repose sur des cotisations
payées par les salariés des cotisations
sociales
correspondant au système de répartition
il est effectivement complété par un
régime lié à la situation particulière
de la Banque de France mais nous-mêmes
reconnaissons depuis le début de ce
débat que on peut parfaitement avoir des
régimes qui liés à leur histoire sont
des régimes particuliers qui ne
dérochent pas aux règles générales mais
puisqu'ils sont bien gérés pourquoi les
changer c'est exactement ce que nous
disons et puis au-delà des différences
qui peuvent nous animer dans ces débats
puisque sur cet amendement particulier
les groupes de gauche proposent de
maintenir le statut de la Banque de
France le régime de la Banque de France
il y a 14 collègues centristes qui
avaient déposé un amendement dans le
même sens cet amendement a disparu je ne
sais pas pourquoi mais enfin les 14
collègues centrices eux sont toujours là
il y a 18 avec vous chers collègues
Étienne blanc 18 parlementaires des
républicains qui ont déposé un
amendement si nous joignons nos voix et
que tout le monde s'y met et bien au
moins nous aurons fait oeuvres utile cet
après-midi en préservant ce régime
monsieur Lurel
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président c'est un
collègue je vais dans la même veine que
le président Laurent
personnellement je n'ai aucune mal à
être si pragmatique que vous et je
n'empêchera pas à la banque de faire son
travail de banquier de banquier de
bancariser le monétariser et de placer
et c'est vrai c'est un régime mixte
c'est pas de la capitalisation au sens
strict du terme c'est-à-dire mixtes
pourquoi empêcher ça je m'interroge
imaginez parce que il me semble
peut-être uniquement pour la politique
monétaire la Banque de France et
indépendante et ça a fait le débat que
l'on sait au Parlement alors bien sûr on
peut s'interroger sur
l'imposition qui est faite le
nouveau régime qu'on va imposer imaginez
sur imposer ça au Sénat alors bien sûr
vous me dirige sur un régime autonome en
faisant une sorte distinction spécieuse
entre les régimes spéciaux et les
régimes autonomes là il est vraiment
autonome
et oui dans les fêtes il s'autofinance
on s'adresse pas aux contribuable il
place et lorsqu'il y accéder reverse au
Trésor public sans pour autant sombrer
dans ce que nous connaissons et que
l'histoire a condamné on a vu ça dans la
crise de 29 on l'a vu dans la crise de
2008 et c'est pas l'avenir si ça y est
du grand public là c'est un petit public
de quelques milliers de personnes qui
abondent les finances publiques voilà
donc moi je voudrais cet amendement pour
maintenir ce régime
merci nous allons maintenant procéder au
scrutin public
monsieur grostard et dernier orateur
inscrit merci beaucoup monsieur monsieur
le Président je voulais juste juste
intervenir pour dire que c'est vrai que
sur ces sur l'ensemble de ces
amendements et sur ce régime spécifique
ça a été dit par ma collègue Raymond de
Poncet c'est sûr qu'on voit bien les
problématiques qui d'ailleurs un régime
un régime autonome très spécifique par
capitalisation donc sur lequel
effectivement on a des on a des doutes
on a des questionnements par rapport à
ce régime
cependant on votera quand même ces
amendements parce que c'est justement
toute la technique et j'irai la manière
dont ils sont amenés donc ils sont
amenés dans ce dans ce texte
c'est-à-dire qu'on fait un gros paquet
et on montre du doigt en disant c'est
ces régimes c'est spéciaux c'est ces
régimes spécifiques qui sont un qui sont
un problème et encore une fois pour
monter les uns contre les autres donc
dans cette orientation là et dans cette
globalité là on votera ensemble de ces
amendements tout en ayant effectivement
un questionnement par rapport à ce
régime autonome spécifique merci
monsieur le Président donc cette fois-ci
je vais ouvrir le scrutin public je
rappelle l'avis de la commission des
favorable la vie du Gouvernement est
défavorable parce que il est à 17h19
très précisément à l'antenne de Public
Sénat vous avez compris comment ça
fonctionne maintenant lorsqu'il y a une
demande de scrutin public comme c'est le
cas et bien on ne vote pas par main
levée mais il y a une forme de
suspension de séance pour donner
l'occasion à tout le groupe de voter et
on a comme ça la cartographie de
l'ensemble de l'hémicycle sur le scrutin
et donc là on va pouvoir voter sur ces
amendements de suppression de la
suppression des régimes spéciaux des
salariés de la Banque de France donc des
abonnements qui visent à maintenir et
bien ce régime spécial pour les salariés
de la Banque de France c'est une voilà
est-ce que tu es un public qui est
utilisé notamment par les groupes de
gauche aussi pour ralentir l'examen de
la forme des retraites pourquoi parce
que au lieu de voter par main levée sur
une série d'amendements et bien vous
devez interromplacer en comme c'est le
cas en ce moment et vous perdez un petit
peu de temps comme ça ça fait un de
grignoter un petit peu de temps c'est
une stratégie aussi pour la gauche on va
voir comme cela donc aussi tout Le le
panel des votes autour de cette de cette
amendement de ses amendements mais sans
surprise on devrait avoir le même voilà
ratio que depuis le début tu sais ce que
tu public avec la gauche et la droite
c'est le centre qui va être différemment
retour dans l'hémistique pour avoir les
résultats du scrutin
plus personne ne demande à voter
le scrutin est clos
ulta du scrutin
votant 344 exprimés 338 pour 108 contre
230 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
nous allons maintenant examiner 52
amendements qui vont faire l'objet d'une
discussion commune d'abord
madame briquet un amendement 344
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues c'est amendement vise à ne pas
fermer le régime spécial de retraite des
clercs de notaire là encore pourquoi
vouloir démanteler un régime
financièrement autonome là encore si ce
régime spécial existe c'est pour une
raison bien particulière car avant la
mise en place de l'orchestre les
salariés des études notariales n'avaient
pas droit à une couverture retraite
n'étant pas classée ouvriers ou
fonctionnaire il devait pour ceux qui le
pouvaient acheter un des points de
retraite auprès de la Société de Secours
mutuelle là encore ce régime correspond
à un souci de justice et de protection
des salariés sa fermeture ne trouve donc
aucune justification je vous remercie
monsieur le Président donc un amendement
de suppression d'alinéa 5 à 13 qui va
concerner le régime spécial de retraite
des clercs et employés de notaire je
voulais ajouter une précision enfin une
information la population des salariés
du notaria est féminisée après de
88%. donc cette décision de suppression
aura un impact important en termes de
droit à la retraite de ces femmes alors
j'interroge le ministre pourquoi vouloir
toujours et encore niveler vers le bas
monsieur ficher
oui monsieur le Président
Monsieur ministre chers collègue
si ce projet devenait à adopter ce
serait la fin du régime de retraite et
de Sécurité Sociale auquel chaque
salarié du notariat est attachée cela
entraîne rien de surcroît la fin de
l'action sociale profitant au salarié de
la caisse en contrepartie du cotisation
supérieure à celle du régime général des
salariés du notariat bénéficient d'une
pension de retraite calculée sur les 10
dernières années avec les dispositions
que vous proposez elle serait calculée
sur les 25 dernières années et donc
mécaniquement cela entraînerait une
baisse de niveau des pensions
pourquoi vouloir supprimer un régime
mais qui est autosuffisant le but est-il
d'absorber les réserves de caisse des
quarts de notaire
interrogé par la profession le
gouvernement n'a apporté aucune réponse
silence les débats l'Assemblée nationale
n'ont pas plus éclairé le débat alors
afin de ne pas participer à une
réduction drastique des droits à la
retraite des terres de notaire nous nos
jours toujours la fermeture du régime
spécial merci chanterelles
voilà retour en salle des conférences
ici la salle qui jouxte l'hémicycle du
Sénat vous comprenez nous sommes en
train d'égrainer les régimes spéciaux et
qui doivent être supprimés dans le texte
du Gouvernement de la réforme des
retraites après les salariés de la RATP
ceux de la Banque de France et donc
maintenant on examine tout et bien ses
amendements autour du régime spécial des
clairs de notaire pour en parler
j'accuse ici Daniel broyier bonjour
monsieur vous êtes sénateur écologiste
du Val-de-Marne un mot sur ce qui se
joue en séance depuis le début de
l'examen des articles des amendements on
a le sentiment d'une forme de monologue
de la gauche c'est le cas pour vous
aussi je partage l'idée qu'il s'agit
d'un monologue puisque malheureusement
nous n'avons pas de réponse ni de
défense ni d'argumentaire de la part de
la majorité sénatoriale est très
rarement de la part de la majorité
gouvernementale
de droite et du centre en disant qu'il y
a les orateurs pour la commission leur
rapporteur général la centriste
Elisabeth Doisneau ou encore René
palestavary pour qui donne la vie de la
droite et du centre qu'est-ce que vous
leur répondez à ma connaissance la vie
de la commission n'est pas la vie de la
majorité sénatoriale et je pense qu'il
appartient au groupe politique et
singulièrement au groupe majoritaire des
DLR mais aussi au groupe centrisme
d'ailleurs de donner leur propre
position par exemple sur ces régimes
spéciaux c'est quand même assez
incroyable que le groupe LR qui défend
leur suppression et même l'accélération
de la suppression quand je vois
l'amendement de Monsieur Retailleau ne
viennent pas le défendre et expliquer sa
position le débat parlementaire ça
s'appelle un débat donc dans un débat il
faut être deux
choses à apporter au texte et que elle a
peur que il y a pas assez de temps plus
tard parce que la gauche occupe le
terrain avec tous ces amendements alors
qu'elle elle souhaiterait aussi pouvoir
débattre de tous les articles de la fin
de l'examen vous comprenez leur
explication je la comprends je la
partage pas si vous voulez en fait
aujourd'hui la droite elle est muette
dans l'hémicycle mais elle est surtout
sourde au million de gens qui vont
manifester le 7 mars et elle met dans
l'hémist n'est pas terrible dans le
terme en termes de fonctionnement de la
vie parlementaire mais le plus difficile
c'est que le gouvernement et la majorité
sénatoriale soit sourd à ce point à tous
les citoyens à tous les travailleurs qui
demandent que cette réforme ne soit pas
votée et qui conteste le principe même
de ce faire voler deux années de leur
vie les deux plus belles années comme je
l'évoquais dans mon propos liminaire et
en rapportant les termes d'une ATSEM de
ma commune d'Arcueil
à l'heure où l'on se parle il reste 3459
amendements à examiner d'ici au 12 mars
qu'est-ce que ça te dit de ce qui peut
se jouer dans les prochains jours au
Sénat est-ce que vous allez réussir à
parvenir jusqu'au bout du texte alors ça
dit d'abord une chose à savoir que le
gouvernement a fait le choix d'un
véhicule qui est une ruse
légistique et qui n'aurait jamais dû
être le support à une telle réforme des
retraites 47 ans la Constitution en
utilisation d'un plfssr un projet
d'affili financement explicatif de la
sécurité sociale un projet de loi de
financement rectificatif est fait pour
rectifier et en l'occurrence si on parle
des retraites et des enjeux des
retraites il faut être capable de parler
de travail même l'index senior qui
figure et que nous allons prochainement
débattre dans l'hémicycle à l'article 2
et n'est pas un sujet financier donc il
n'a rien à faire dans un projet de loi
de finance rectificatif vous avez noté
que j'ai demandé avec insistance la
publication du rapport que le Conseil
d'État a donné au gouvernement synthèse
comme dit le gouvernement la note de
synthèse et on m'a repris j'avais dit
avis on m'a dit non il s'agit d'une note
de synthèse toujours est-il que garder
secret des notes de synthèse qui disent
au gouvernement très clairement puisque
la presse en effet court mais nous
parlementaire nous n'y avons pas accès
qui disent très clairement que choisir
un tel texte c'est faire courir un
risque d'inconstitutionnalité sur tous
les articles qui ne sont pas financiers
ça veut dire c'est aggravé la réforme
qui est déjà très dure pour les
travailleurs et les travailleuses de ce
pays très bien à la fin de cette
interview cette ma dernière question
mais quelle est la stratégie de la
gauche l'idée c'est d'empêcher le fait
qu'on examine l'article 7 celui sur la
mesure phare du texte c'est 64 ans de
départ à la retraite avant la journée du
7 mars pour ne pas démobiliser l'action
sociale c'est ça l'idée la stratégie de
la gauche quelque chose l'attitude des
sénateurs de gauche et écologiste n'a ne
peut pas contribuer à démobiliser les
gens qui sont en train de se préparer à
manifester
avant le 7 mars nous espérons que le 7
mars la mobilisation se fasse avant le
débat de l'article 7 pour une raison
simple c'est que nous pensons de salut
briter publique que le gouvernement
retire sa loi et nous espérons devant
l'ampleur de la manifestation il aura la
sagesse de retirer sa loi et d'apaiser
le climat social merci beaucoup pour
cette réaction du compte public c'est né
en salle des conférences nous sommes
toujours en direct et retour dans
l'hémicycle pour suivre ses débat
maladies retraite et recouvrement et
de sépia
ponctuation de fragilité
cette caisse est une est un régime
excédentaire pérenne et financé par des
cotisations supérieures des employés et
abondés par la contribution de 4% des
employeurs qui n'accordent aucun
avantage au niveau de l'âge de départ en
retraite ce régime est donc parfaitement
autonome et très bien géré la caisse est
excellentaire depuis plusieurs années
car il y a d'une part les cotisants qui
cotisent à plein et d'autre part les
retraités polypensionnés et les
retraités n'ayant pas une retraite à
taux plein alors que la suppression du
régime spécial ne ferait que renforcer
la difficulté de recrutement que
rencontre la profession le présent
amendement propose de revenir sur cette
suppression qui apparaît injustifiée et
néfaste pour l'attractivité de la
profession une étude de l'Observatoire
prospective des métiers et
qualifications des collaborateurs de
notariat nous indique qu'il manquerait 3
à 5000 salariés dans le secteur cette
réforme risque également de
réaliser plus fortement les femmes qui
représentent plus de 88% des
collaboratrices de la profession ça a
déjà été dit mais nous ne sommes pas
dupe donc
nous souhaitons que là encore vous vous
opposez les Français des uns contre les
autres et nous serons ici au Sénat le 7
mars pour nous y opposer et soutenir ce
et celle nombreux qui seront dans la rue
et au vu de nombreuses sollicitations
des clercs et employés de notaire qui
nous ont expliqué le régime spécial ils
seront eux aussi très nombreux dans la
rue Madame la triche compta
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
l'article premier sur lequel nous
travaillons depuis ce matin vise à
supprimer les régimes spéciaux et nous
avons depuis ce matin défendu ses
régimes qui ont leur utilité liées à des
suggestions liées à une histoire aussi
et c'est amendement vise à ne pas fermer
le régime spécial de retraite des
collaborateurs de notaires qui incluent
notamment les Clerc mais l'ensemble des
collaborateurs et qui suppriment donc
les alinéas 5 à 13 de cet article
premier c'est un régime cela a été dit
paritaire qui a été négocié entre
salariés et employeurs et les employeurs
les notaires eux-mêmes souhaitent le
maintien de ce régime et c'est un
élément important donc ce régime
autonome créé en 1937 avec l'ensemble de
la protection sociale des collaborateurs
du notariat ce régime
le secteur le notariat il tient beaucoup
dans son ensemble et
la suppression de ce régime aurait pour
conséquence une baisse du montant des
pensions importantes de l'ordre
vraisemblablement de 25% et en plus de
la baisse des pensions c'est
collaborateurs devront subir le report
de l'âge de départ à la retraite de 60 à
64 ans qui va encore détériorer les
conditions de travail au sein des études
et je crois que cela a été dit pénalisé
les femmes qui sont très majoritaires
après de 90% dans ses études donc c'est
très agression sociale et donc d'autant
moins justifiée que ce régime n'est pas
déficitaire ne fait l'objet d'aucune
subvention d'équilibre et qu'il dispose
de
réserves de 800 millions d'euros donc
cela a été dit également c'est une
profession qui est des difficultés de
recrutement alors ne supprimons pas ce
régime spécial je vous remercie
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre autant je me sentais qualifié
pour évoquer le régime de la RATP voir
du ferroviaire autant je vous avouerai
ne pas bien connaître ce régime spécial
de retraite des notaires est clair de
notaire un petit peu comme celui de la
Banque de France préalablement et donc
plutôt que de démagogiquement tout
supprimer le gouvernement monsieur le
ministre serait mieux inspiré de retirer
sa réforme reprendre de véritables
négociations avec des partenaires
sociaux et étudier profession par
profession l'opportunité de revenir
intégralement ou en partie sur certains
régimes dit spéciaux une bonne réforme
de retraite est une réforme qui allie
sauvegarde de la répartition et Progrès
Social
pakistigmatise certains et qui montre
les Français contre les uns contre les
autres je vous remercie que l'URL
si nous sommes présidentielle
j'avoue assez estomaqué
par l'obsession de nos collègues de
vouloir supprimer ce qui marche
je l'avoue vous allez proposer à des
gens qui n'ont rien demandé depuis 86
ans qui
font le calcul de leur salaire
annuellement
sur les dix dernières années c'était le
cas de la fonction publique avant la
dure
qui
peuvent avoir comme la fonction publique
75% de leur Samuel
annuel moyen pour leur proposer 25
années 62 ans 64 ans et une best leur
pension il faut être un peu gonfler
quand même pour boire les vulgairements
franchement comment voulez-vous que
cette réforme là soit acceptée et que
l'on dresse peut-être un petit groupe
estimé par vous privilégiez contre
l'ensemble des Français pour susciter je
ne sais quelle envie et oui c'est un
concept en économie l'envie la jalousie
sociale ce sont des privilégiés et oui
comment pouvez-vous être attractif
lorsque vous voyez votre propre base
électorale qui refuse ça il y a du bon
sens dans votre électorat comme chez
tous les Français comment peut-on
soumettre ça à la représentation
nationale je voterai avec enthousiasme
et allégresse les amendements qui sont
proposés
monsieur le Président rénal
bah j'ai peur de rien rajouter à ce que
vient de dire à Victorin Lurel Victorin
Laurel dit tout toujours sur
l'incompréhension en tout cas qui est la
nôtre c'est vrai que quand c'est
extraordinaire quand un système
fonctionne on se débrouille en France
pour faire en sorte qu'ils dysfonctionne
donc impeccable quoi on l'a vu on l'a vu
tout à l'heure sur le système manque de
France on le voit maintenant sur ce
régime d'éclair et employé de notaire
franchement on est sur des petites
populations on est sur des sujets
problématiques on est sur des agents qui
sont pour l'essentiel féminin on a
expliqué que s'il y avait il y avait un
sujet sur les rémunérations notamment
des femmes dans ce pays on vient toucher
à ce régime donc vraiment
personne ne se soucie et surtout qui ne
comment dire qui pour les Français
comment dire ne représente pas quelque
chose dont ils ont une représentation
parfaite en termes davantage est-ce que
on cite cette population comme une
population privilégiée alors je sais
bien que on ne le dit pas comme ça c'est
pas les termes gouvernementaux mais il y
a toujours cette idée de privilège
derrière je pense que c'est un système
qui est encore une fois est ancien qui
existe finalement bien avant le régime
général c'était un système qui est
intégré maintenant au répertoire général
des carrière unique qui suit les bornes
d'âge légal les 167 trimestres cotisés
quitte et le fruit d'un accord entre
l'éclair employé notaire et les notaires
eux-mêmes et sur des professions encore
une fois ce qu'elle est compliqué
aujourd'hui de recruter donc très
sincèrement on fait toujours des espèces
d'exemplarité et il y a des gens qui
vont le payer et ça d'ailleurs pas
pourquoi
et nous non plus nous ne savons pas
pourquoi si Houlgate
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues l'éclair de
notaire sont-ils des nantis on a tous
fréquenté à un moment donné de notre vie
une étude notariale et on a été en
contact direct avec des clairs de
notaire ou des collaborateurs d'études
fin de compte c'est clair de notaire ce
sont j'allais dire un petit peu les
petites mains qui sont les rouages
essentiels de la chaîne notariale ils
assurent en effet la préparation et la
rédaction des actes de l'étude les
transactions immobilières les
successions les donations et surtout et
ce qui est important il vérifie
l'authenticité des documents des titres
de propriété où l'exactitude des
inventaires ils transmettent ils classe
ils répertorie tous les actes notariaux
c'est un travail qui est un travail
jeudi assez stressant dans la mesure où
on le sait très bien les procédures
notariales se sont considérablement
complexifier
depuis quelques années
j'ajouterais même que la
dématérialisation même si elle offre un
compte un confort
aux signataires et bien est une source
d'anxiété d'angoisse pour s'éclairs de
notaire qui sont chargés souvent dans un
domaine de compétence qui n'est pas le
leur d'assurer la bonne transmission des
actes notariés qui sont désormais
complètement décentralisés je l'ai
personnellement vécu ce ne sont pas des
nantis le salaire moyen d'éclair de
notaire pour leur qualifications et
autour de 2200 2300 euros la réforme
telle que vous la proposez va faire en
sorte que le taux de remplacement va
être diminué de 25%. je pense que il ne
faut pas comme on nous l'avions évoqué
tout à l'heure avec la Banque de France
déstabiliser une profession qui joue un
rôle essentiel à l'heure actuelle dans
la rédaction de d'actes administratif
oui monsieur le Président nous voici sur
le sujet des clercs de notaire alors
c'est pas un sujet pour Victor Hugo vous
en conviendrez ce serait plutôt un sujet
pour Honoré de Balzac mais enfin il n'a
pas siégé autant que je sache au sein de
notre assemblée sénatoriale et comme il
est mort en 1850 de toute façon ça
aurait été à la Chambre des pères enfin
peu importe le sujet des clairs de
notaire peut paraître un sujet
secondaire mais comme ça vient d'être
dit par notre collègue ça n'en est pas
un c'est une
profession qui est tout à fait
respectable qui était minimement utile
au fonctionnement administratif de notre
société et donc si des circonstances
particulières on conduit il y a fort
longtemps à définir un système de
retraite qui ne pèse pas sur les comptes
publics du moins pas sur ceux de l'État
mais qui se finance par lui-même somme
toute je ne vois pas bien de raison de
venir le remettre en cause et de
perturber un dispositif qui fonctionne
donc pourquoi changer ce qui marche bien
comme cela a aussi été déjà dit par des
intervenants précédents je serai pour ce
qui me concerne Davis de ne rien changer
à ce dispositif qui est parfaitement
utile et qui permet
d'attirer l'attention sur une profession
particulière qui est encore une fois est
utile à notre fonctionnement
administratif
oui dans dans la même veine un peu comme
j'ai dit tout à l'heure sur la catégorie
précédente je me pose la question de de
ce que ces gens ont bien pu faire pour
mériter un tel sort la qui leur est fait
tout d'un coup je pense que franchement
ils ont entendu parler très certainement
du projet de réforme des retraites du
gouvernement depuis un moment mais je
pense pas qu'il s'attendait à faire
partie de la liste des récipients d'air
si je puis dire et comme me l'a dit tout
à l'heure je crois que c'était Marie
Noël lineman est-ce que
ou une de ses collègues je ne sais plus
mais est-ce que finalement tout ça
c'était c'est pas pour justifier la fin
du régime spécial de la RATP et des
gaziers on y met deux catégories qui
comportent très très peu finalement
d'individus et et dont les régimes sont
parfaitement autonomes et comme ça on
emballe le tout et ça passe un petit peu
plus facilement et puis là aussi c'est
pareil je me dis mais j'ai déjà fait
cette remarque pour la RATP mais
imaginons dans une étude notariale bon
enfin je sais pas comment c'est dans les
grandes villes mais dans nos petites
communes les études notariale quand il y
a aujourd'hui les notaires sont
regroupés mais quand il y a une dizaine
de salariés c'est vraiment un maximum
imaginons petit à petit des gens qui
seront recrutés avec un régime de
retraite et et des gens qui auront été
recrutés deux ans avant et qui pendant
30 ans traîneront enfin pas très neuro
mais auront finalement un avenir de
retraite qui sera absolument différent
de celui des nouveaux intégrés tout ça
ne me paraît pas être en termes de
gestion du personnel extrêmement
facilitée une fois de plus bon
ces gens là je le je le dis très
clairement ce sont des prétextes ils
servent de prétexte et ça n'est pas
vraiment logique
voilà retour en salle des conférences
cette pièce qui joue que je te les
mythique ou se déroulent ces débats sur
la réforme des retraites pour en parler
d'accueillissima et Pierre de la Gontrie
bonjour bienvenue sur ce plateau on vous
a vu dans l'hémicycle défendre certains
de ses amendements un mot sur ce qui se
joue et comment est-ce que vous
qualifiez ce qui se passe autour de ces
débats depuis hier après-midi et le
début de l'examen des articles et des
amendements
je trouve ça assez étrange parce que je
ne pensais pas que la droite serait
aussi démissionnaire dans le débat
c'est-à-dire que le Parlement du débat
on a suffisamment dit qu'à l'Assemblée
il n'y avait pas eu de débat pas
suffisamment pas avec le ton qui
convenait bref ici tout ça se passe de
manière très courtoise bon comme on le
fait souvent au Sénat mais nous n'avons
aucun interlocuteur c'est assez curieux
donc voilà il y a un certain nombre de
sénateurs de droits qui sont là mais qui
ne disent pas un mot et qui ne défendent
pas davantage quelque chose dont j'ai
compris pourtant qu'il s'apprêtait à la
droite dit notamment ce qu'a dit Bruno
Retailleau en séance que ce sont les
rapporteurs à la fois Madame douano et
Monsieur Savary qui tiennent à l'opinion
qui qui vont comme ça qui ont porté la
vie de la majorité de la moitié du
centre dans l'hémicycle qu'est-ce que
vous lui répondez avec vous ne
Retailleau mais c'est une faute de dire
ça parce que les rapporteurs portent la
vie de la Commission ne porte pas la vie
d'un groupe heureusement donc lorsqu'il
dit ça en fait il a dû penser
qu'effectivement c'était un peu étrange
que personne de son groupe ne s'exprime
et donc il a trouvé cette explication
qui ne tient pas et qui est même
choquante alors est-ce que c'est pas
aussi la faute de la gauche avec ces
très nombreuses amendements ces
explications de vote on comprend que
vous vouliez
occuper le terrain pour et bien dénoncer
cette réforme mais est-ce que cela aussi
et bien n'empêche pas le débat alors ce
qui est très frappant mais comme vous
suivez le débat vous l'avez sans doute
constaté c'est que nous ne anonons pas
le même argumentaire à chaque fois
c'est-à-dire que nous sommes très
nombreux
l'ensemble de la gauche et nous
défendons donc nos positions par exemple
nous sommes contre la suppression des
régimes spéciaux sur chaque régime vous
êtes en train de prendre la parole pour
défendre à chaque fois chacun des cinq
régimes qui est supprimé par la réforme
chaque fois vous l'avez sans doute noté
avec des points de vue qui sont
illustrés différents donc
c'est vraiment moi je trouve que c'est
un débat intéressant c'est d'autant plus
triste au fond c'est même un peu
problématique du coup la droite
n'explique pas parce que moi je serais
contente de savoir pourquoi on a choisi
de supprimer le régime spécial je sais
pas de la RATP et pas des dockers de
d'éclairs de notaire et pas de la
Comédie française
c'est quoi ce qui se joue en coulisses
c'est que la droite est d'accord avec le
gouvernement et du coup soit avancer sur
cette réforme je pense que LR fait le
calcul donc je ne suis pas sûr qu'il
soit gagnant pour eux mais c'est leur
problème que au final ce texte sera le
leur et que donc vous le montrera leur
puissance positive dans En attendant il
ne s'exprime pas et ne défende pas le
texte donc un côté stablement il y a une
consigne de silence qui a été donnée
puisque y compris les rares amendements
qui ont pu être déposés très très rare
par des élus de droite ne sont parfois
pas défendues voir retirer et même
lorsqu'ils sont maintenus au moment du
vote puisqu'on a très souvent décrites
un public les personnes qui ont déposé
des amendements ne les votent pas
lorsqu'ils sont de droite donc il y a
une consigne très claire de faire bloc
de ne pas s'exprimer d'attendre que ça
passe on le voit vous êtes en train de
perdre les votes au fur et à mesure que
l'on avance dans ce texte a été le cas
sur la RATP ça a été le cas sur la
Banque de France il va y avoir ensuite
des scrutins publiques sur l'éclair de
notaire etc etc ces débats ils sont
toujours regardés par des salariés qui
sont mobilisés contre la réforme des
retraites qu'est-ce que vous leur dites
sur ce qui va se jouer avec cette
réforme elle risque de passer au
scénario vous allez perdre alors je ne
sais pas si elle passera au Sénat
premièrement deuxièmement vous savez
nous notre responsabilité en tout cas la
gauche du Sénat c'est ce qu'elle
considère comme étant sa responsabilité
nous considérons nous devons être l'écho
de la mobilisation sociale et syndicale
et que nous devons faire en sorte
qu'elle soit traduit de manière
législative donc nous ne sommes pas pour
le chaos dans l'assemblée nous ne sommes
pas pour importer la conflictualité au
sein de l'assemblée mais nous sommes là
c'est normal c'est c'est les personnes
ont voté pour nous même si si nous avons
de ce que tu as un particulier c'est une
autre responsabilité de porter leur
position il y a quand même des centaines
de milliers de personnes qui manifestent
qui font grève qui lorsqu'elles font
grève je le rappelle quand même perdre
leur salaire correspondant et donc notre
responsabilité c'est d'être en phase dès
lors que ça correspond à nos positions
ici dans l'hémicycle un dernier mot une
dernière question si vous me permettez
on le voit cette journée de mobilisation
du 7 mars un mardi prochain qui se
profile votre stratégie vous nous le
dites à ce micro c'est qu'on ne soit
jamais allé jusqu'à au vote sur
l'article 7 et la mesure avant le 7 mars
c'est ça que veut la gauche c'est bien
ce qu'on a compris nous nous voulons que
le débat soit le plus approfondi
possible y compris bien évidemment sur
l'article 7 qui l'article emblématique
sur le report de l'âge de 64 ans la
France entière va se mobiliser ce
jour-là et il nous semble important
effectivement que le Sénat ne se
prononce qu'après et alors le 7 mars
juste une indication qu'est-ce que vous
ferez vous les sénateurs vous allez
siéger normalement ou comment est-ce que
vous ferez le relais de la mobilisation
je pense que nous serons nombreux à être
dans l'hémicycle y compris en expliquant
ça d'une manière ou d'une autre parce
que notre responsabilité c'est de
continuer le combat ici puisque c'est
ici que le débat se déroule merci
Marie-Pierre de la Gonterie on va
rejoindre les missiles pour suivre ces
débats en direct merci de vouloir
supprimer cette caisse à plusieurs
reprises les claires ont démontré leur
capacité à se réformer
ainsi il paie aujourd'hui davantage de
cotisations ils n'ont pas de plafond sur
le revenu et sont les notaires qui ont
une cotisation obligatoire de 4% sur
leur zone horaire et un monument dans
ces conditions quels sont les raisons
qui poussent du gouvernement à un tel
choix comment justifier l'intégration
d'un système qui fonctionne aussi bien
peut-être la raison
est cachée comme le dit tout à l'heure
pour noyer le poisson en quelque sorte
avec la réforme voulue de la RATP et des
IEG si votre réforme aboutit la
conséquence sera parfaitement injuste
malgré la bonne gestion de cette cause
de cette caisse avec une baisse de 25%
des pensions à en plus deux ans de
travail supplémentaire c'est
inacceptable enfin cela a été dit par
plusieurs de mes collègues cette
profession est majoritairement composée
de femmes à 88%. et lorsqu'on sait que
votre réforme en général les paysages
plus
c'est tout se justifie d'autant plus
excusez-moi très bien Monsieur le Comte
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues notre
collègue Jean-Michel Houlgate à tout à
l'heure indiqué combien cette profession
était indispensable à notre pays compte
tenu des fonctions importantes qu'elle
représente en matière d'acte
il est quand même assez étonnant alors
que c'est un système où les personnes
cotisent plus et le système fonctionne
de proposer de
remplacer quelque chose qui fonctionne
pour le verset dans un système dont vous
nous dites
je me rappelle de l'amendement retiré
après de Valérie Boyer hier que le
système de toute façon
même avec cette réforme ne
fonctionnerait pas ne serait pas financé
donc comment voulez-vous comment
voulez-vous donner confiance dans la
société comment voulez-vous que les
Français aient confiance si lorsque
quelque chose fonctionne vous propose de
le casser pour le verser dans quelque
chose dont vous dites qu'il ne
fonctionne pas
nous ne vous disons que ça fonctionne
mais vous vous cassez des choses qui
fonctionnent pour les remettre dans
quelque chose ce sera pas toujours pas
financé de toute façon c'est quand même
assez étonnant donc nous nous proposons
de maintenir ce qui fonctionne de
maintenir ce qui fonctionne nous sommes
des réformistes et s'il y a des choses
qui méritent d'être d'évoluer de ne pas
reconstruire sur la base d'un système
que vous-même critiquez
donc auquel vous-même vous n'avez pas
confiance mais de le faire d'une manière
progressive contenue du fait que des
personnes peuvent changer de système
mais il est vrai il est vrai que lorsque
vous avez un système qui prend comme
base de du revenu moyen les 10 derniers
les 10 meilleurs années il est quand
même particulièrement préoccupant de
passer de 10 à 25 surtout quand vous
êtes une majorité de femmes vous voyez
les conséquences que ça aura sur un
certain nombre de carrière hachées et
c'est particulièrement préoccupant donc
pourquoi faites-vous mettez-vous des
actions qui remettent en cause la
confiance des Français dans l'avenir
monsieur le Président Keller merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur ministre
mes chers collègues vous connaissez
l'adage latin et raré ou madame est
persévaré
diabolikum effectivement on comprend pas
on ne comprend pas monsieur le ministre
cet entêtement encore une fois à
liquider et à fermer un régime qui
fonctionne correctement donc je me joins
à tous les collègues qui sont exprimés
jusqu'ici pour dénoncer cette mauvaise
manière et surtout qui touche encore une
fois une minorité de nos concitoyens ce
régime suit les conditions d'âge de
départ à la retraite de 62 ans et 170
trimestres 67 trimestres une fois de
plus ce régime qui est excellentaire
fait pas du tout appel à des
financements publics et ça dure depuis
1937 1937 à ce ne sera plus le cas à
terme si vous intégrez ce régime une
fois de plus vous présentez une réforme
qui est censée rééquilibrer et on
pourrait on y reviendra un moment venu
rééquilibrer notre système de retraite
en le et ça le déséquilibrerait est
menacerait manifestement donc ces
régimes spéciaux qui s'autofinance
doivent être conservés d'autant plus que
leur suppression serait plus néfaste que
positive au reste du système par
répartition donc je me joins au collègue
pour demander la suppression de cette
alinéa
merci Madame espanac pour
ce régime déclare nos notaires n'est pas
déficitaire et et le fait il fait de
l'objet donc par contre pardon
excusez-moi d'aucune subvention en
équilibre provenant soin du régime
général des la sécurité sociale soit du
budget de l'État comme cela est
également étadies repousser l'âge de
départ de la retraite de 62 à 64 ans ne
va pas améliorer la condition de travail
au sein des études il va pénaliser les
femmes lesquelles représentent 88% de
l'effectif dans la branche les femmes
vont devoir travailler plus longtemps
plus durement sans avoir une meilleure
retraite car tous les scénarios
démontrent que les femmes seront les
plus grandes perdantes de cette réforme
je voudrais donc contre la suppression
de ce régime
merci maintenant un amendement en 1946
rectifié monsieur blanc le présente
il porte sur les annulaire retour en
salle des conférences cette pièce qui
joue cette hémicycle je suis en
compagnie de Philippe mouiller bonjour
bonjour
ce qui se joue depuis le début de
l'examen des articles et des amendements
on a le sentiment d'une forme de
monologue parfois dans l'hémicycle avec
des prises de parole uniquement
d'opposant à la réforme et très peu de
ce qu'il a soutiennent je crois que
c'est pour nous à la fois un constat
d'un système diamant de d'obstruction
par les le nombre d'amendements puisque
lorsqu'on a 60 70 Adam rendements
identiques portés par l'opposition on
voit bien que c'est une répétition qui
vise à gagner du temps même chose dans
les prises de parole alors le nœud de
côté qui se passe on s'est organisé on a
nos rapporteur aujourd'hui qui
aujourd'hui donne clairement notre
position il donne la position de la
Commission dit
il devrait y avoir les positions
politiques aussi elle se plaint de ce
bâillon Retailleau dit-elle dans les
c'est simplement une volonté nous avons
nous souhaitons nous gagner du temps par
rapport je dirais au déroulé de la
séquence c'est-à-dire gagner du temps
elle est le plus vite possible pour
pouvoir voter le maximum et on espère
tout le texte donc qu'est-ce qui se
passe on est une intervention au moment
de la discussion générale puis on a
globalement l'intervention après enfin
préalablement à chaque vote explique son
nom de chaque article le reste du temps
ça fait partie du scénario organisé par
la gauche ici au Sénat qui consiste
avant tout à dérouler dérouler dérouler
déroulés des arguments qui qui sont en
répétition simplement c'est un combat de
temps et donc on a fait le choix nous
aujourd'hui d'être à la fois organisé
d'avoir clairement une position
favorable sur l'intervention des
rapporteurs on n'a pas besoin de
rajouter et puis on a très bien
principalement sur les articles et donc
là par exemple là nous sommes sur
l'article 1 et la suppression de 5
régimes spéciaux on la redit un RATP la
Banque de France l'éclair de notaire
aura ensuite les salariés des industries
du gaz électricité enfin de ce du
Conseil économique social et
environnemental ce sont cinq régimes
spéciaux que une réforme prévoit de
supprimer vous le dites vous supprimez
vous vous soutenez ces suppressions de
régime spéciaux pour longtemps assez peu
dans l'hémicycle donc
depuis le début on a annoncé que nous
soutenons cette réforme et notamment
concernant la discussion il y a même un
débat interne au sein de notre groupe
par rapport au calendrier voilà mais
clairement on est positionné on est
favorable les rapporteurs vont
intervenir dans le sens tout à l'heure
et au moment du vote de l'article nous
aurons aussi une intervention dans le
sens alors justement en reparlons un
petit peu de ce calendrier puisqu'on
comprend il va y avoir des amendements
qui seront examinés mais dans un
deuxième temps car certains et l'herbe
aimeraient accélérer la clause du
grand-père c'est à dire le fait que la
réforme ne s'applique qu'au nouveau
entrants dans ces régimes spéciaux
pourquoi est-ce qu'on examine pas ses
amendements pour le coup venus de votre
camp maintenant c'est un problème la
plus tôt d'organisation et on pose pas
les débats là on n'a pas le choix
puisque on est sur une perte de recettes
pour le gouvernement et de toute façon
mécanique de par l'exécuter aux
exécution du texte ça se passe son
deuxième partie donc on en vient à une
limite de cette de ce plfssr
c'est-à-dire une loi de finances alors
qu'on peut avoir un débat qui ne serait
pas contraint par voilà ces histoires de
recettes et de et de dépenses non oui
peut-être pour enfin je crois que depuis
le début le fait que les amendements
déposés
à l'initiative de l'examen de ce texte
on connaît la position donc voilà donc
je comprends même pour nous il y a une
cohérence à globaliser ce débat on est
sur un texte financier et ça se comprend
d'ailleurs puisque c'est un impact
direct financier qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
on a on est on est coupé dans ce dans la
discussion voilà donc on retournera sur
ce sujet là en deuxième partie il me
reste quelques questions en quelques en
quelques secondes mais regardez ce
chiffre
3437 amendements encore à examiner en
d'ici le 12 mars vous pensez que c'est
jouable si on regarde le même rythme
c'est impossible alors faudra-t-il en
passer par certaines
les débat
numéro 3000 946 rectifié qui le présente
Madame pour ce poli
voilà il s'agit de l'alinéa 13 et de la
suppression de l'article madame Cohen le
présente
oui je partage quelque chose qui vient
d'être dit concernant les clairs de
notaire qui sous couvert d'égalité
voient eux et aussi leur régime tombé
c'est la même chose en fait dans
l'intégralité du texte on l'a dit vous
prenez la question à l'envers plutôt que
d'accorder des droits plus avantageux et
finalement plus en phase avec la société
à l'ensemble des salariés vous préférez
celles et ceux qui ont un régime qui les
protège davantage que nous nous nommons
des régimes pionniers à certaines
professions c'est il est vrai sont moins
physiques que d'autres il est essentiel
Le Mans question de travail de bureau
mais ça n'empêche pas qu'il y a
également de la pénibilité de la
souffrance au travail de l'usure et des
difficultés longues études ou pas longue
carrière ou pas tout le monde devra
travailler plus longtemps et en fait
vous refusez absolument de voir cette
logique qui fait que
[Musique]
pour nous une des pas question de
privilégier l'argent de privilégier
système libéral contre la vie et contre
l'humain donc c'est pour toutes ces
raisons que nous présentons ces
amendements de suppression merci alors
maintenant nous allons demander la vie
de la Commission sur l'ensemble de ses
amendements qu'il faut l'objet du
diction commune et qui iront trois votes
séparés par la nature même de leurs
abandons oui merci monsieur le Président
je voudrais tout d'abord
un rendement parler de fermer le régime
spécial de retraite des notaires éclairs
de notaire donc je pense qu'il y a eu
une erreur et raré oumanum est comme
nous le disait le président un caner et
que les suivants dont celui de monsieur
Étienne blanc Mr Tano madame assessi
monsieur Canevet et bien eux ont parlé
du bon objet
alors
pour ce qui est de des éléments qu'on
peut apporter et qui sont un petit peu
différents des propos qui ont été tenus
je voulais d'abord dire que pour tout
les claires et employés de notaire qui
sont à moins de 17 heures 30
hebdomadaire et bien ils sont déjà au
régime de base donc en réalité dans un
cabinet notarial il peut y avoir
effectivement deux régimes différents et
donc pour
ces personnes il est pas question de
considérer que les uns sont nantis par
rapport aux autres ou que ce sont des
petites mains ou des voilà je ne sais ce
que j'ai entendu mais en tout cas ce
sont simplement des professionnels des
gens qui sont vraiment
importants dans dans les dans les
offices de notarial et je pense que on
doit bien y considérer ce que l'on vous
propose aujourd'hui c'est c'est pour
les personnes qui seront comment
employer à partir du 1er septembre tous
ceux qui vous ont écrit resteront dans
le régime tel qu'ils sont aujourd'hui il
faut bien le rappeler aussi je voulais
aussi vous dire que c'est aussi là
encore un déséquilibre entre le nombre
de cotisants et le nombre de pensionnés
qui fait aussi qu'on se pose la question
de ce régime spécial puisque ils sont à
peu près autour de 63000 cotisants et
qu'il y a plus de 71
000 pensionnés de droits directs et plus
de 7600 de droits dérivés et puis là si
on veut être technique aussi on peut
parler
de comment d'un régime intégré alors
pour ceux qui connaissent un peu
l'ensemble des systèmes je voudrais
rappeler que ça équivaut à la retraite
de base la complémentaire et
additionnelle ça correspond à un régime
supplémentaire facultatif comme dans les
entreprises du service privé donc tous
ces éléments peuvent apporter quelques
informations supplémentaires mais en
tout cas c'est un avis défavorable de la
commission puisque c'est contraire
finalement ce que nous avions proposé
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président Madame a dit
à tout dit en tout cas l'essentiel je
voulais simplement ajouter deux ou trois
précisions ou plutôt souligner ce qui a
été dit précédemment d'abord pour dire
qu'il est effectivement un déséquilibre
démographique avec un nombre de
cotisants inférieur au nombre de
bénéficiaires aujourd'hui ce qui
évidemment pose et de nature à poser un
problème à terme et que par ailleurs une
des motivation principale de la
fermeture des régimes spéciaux fruses
c'est le rétablissement de l'égalité et
je suis assez frappé de voir combien par
certains la défense de certains
amendements il y a finalement la défense
d'une situation particulière sous
prétexte que puisque ça marche il ne
faudrait pas changer au risque de
conserver des situations qui relèvent
parfois et j'essaye de le dire devant de
manière aussi présente que possible et
une forme de situation de ronde par
rapport à la volonté d'aller vers une
égalité l'égalité se traduisant aussi
par les mêmes les mêmes règles de
cotisations d'affiliation et donc de
détermination du niveau de la pension
pour des métiers qui sont comparables et
qui lorsqu'ils sont exposés à l'usure
feront l'objet de la prévention que nous
examinerons à l'article 9 la deuxième
chose que je voulais dire mais madame la
rapporteur l'a déjà évoqué c'est
qu'aujourd'hui dans les études telles
qu'elles fonctionnent il y a déjà
cohabitation entre ceux qui bénéficient
du régime spécial et ceux qui n'en
bénéficient pas madame le rapporteur l'a
dit tous les salariés des études à
mi-temps ou à moins de moins d'habitants
relèvent du régime général et j'amène
une précision à son propos pour dire que
les salariés des études des départements
d'outre-mer ne sont pas couverts par le
régime spécial d'éclairs de notaire et
des employés et tous les salariés des
études en département d'outre-mer
relèvent directement déjà du régime
général quel que soit leur quotité de
temps de travail et donc c'est vraiment
une marge d'inégalité que nous voulons
apporter avec cette disposition enfin ce
régime une particularité qui est que
au-delà de la description qui en est
faite ce sont c'est souvent ce qu'on
appelle
on qualifie un régime de passage avec en
réalité statistiquement très peu de
clairs ou d'employés d'études qui
restent toute leur carrière dans le
régime du notarial en tout cas elle est
clairs de notaire pardon il faut être
plus précis et donc comme on est sur un
régime de passage le fait d'affilier
tout le monde au régime général permet
évidemment de garantir plus de
lisibilité à l'échelle d'une carrière je
termine d'un mot pour dire parce que
cela a été évoqué de manière indirecte
que tant la question des réserves qui
sont maintenues pour le régime que la
question de la clause de grand-père doit
aussi rassurer sur la capacité du régime
à faire face aux engagements pour la
gestion de paiement des pensions de ceux
qui resteront affiliés après le 1er
septembre 2023 donc pour toutes ces
raisons la vie est défavorable
donc je suis saisi de trois demandes de
scrutin public que je vous propose
d'ouvrir les explications de vote et
qu'on ferait sur les droits scrutins si
vous le voulez bien en même temps
monsieur Breuillet merci monsieur le
Président le petit rat est à la première
danseuse ce que le petit claire est au
notaire l'espérance
ces mots de Madame Camille Laurence pour
ouvrir mon propos d'abord merci de ne
pas avoir fermé le régime spécial de
l'Opéra de Paris et de ses 186 ayant
droit malgré votre souci d'égalité en
ratiboisant tout le monde ce texte dont
nous débattons depuis deux jours parlent
des enjeux financiers pour préserver la
retraite par rap par répartition et
voilà un article premier qui s'attaque
au régime spéciaux et en l'occurrence à
celui des clairs de notaire par 1050
alors j'ai une question
cet article sur les régimes spéciaux
fait-il partie de la corbeille de mariée
entre la majorité sénatoriale et le
gouvernement
était demandé pour le mariage ou bien
est-ce une seule décision du
gouvernement désapprouvés puisque j'ai
entendu des remarques du côté de la
partie gauche de l'hémicycle je trouve
que lancer à la vindicte populaire
l'éclair de notaire une profession peu
rémunérée et massivement féminisée n'est
pas tout à fait correct le texte choisi
enfin un texte rectificatif de la loi de
finance de la sécurité sociale pour une
mesure qui n'a aucune aucun impact
financier je continue à ne pas
comprendre pourquoi nous débattons de
mesure qui n'ont pas d'impact financier
sur le bilan rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale et j'aimerais savoir ce que la
note d'analyse du Conseil d'État dit sur
ce sujet
monsieur ferdyck
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre j'ai un peu le sentiment que un
peu par légèreté ou plutôt plus
exactement par souci de remplir
correctement une charrette de régime
spéciaux condamné pour que la RATP les
gaziers les électriciens et de la
compagnie j'ai un petit peu peur que
vous commettiez là en la matière un acte
un petit peu irréfléchi
inutile maladroit ça a été dit comment
on appelle ça déjà un un pas de clair je
crois et bien ce pas de clair j'espère
que notre Sénat vous évitera
monsieur Meurant
merci monsieur le président
moi je vous avouerai que je comprends
pas très bien où je suis positionné il
me semblait que la liberté était un
principe défendu par la droite un peu
plus que la droite aujourd'hui et c'est
un principe d'organisation de la vie
sociale et à travers ce que nous
examinons pour les notaires ce que nous
examinions tout à l'heure pour la Banque
de France et bien ces organisations
c'était
constitué en 1808 il peut avant la
deuxième guerre mondiale il avait mis en
place des systèmes qui fonctionnaient
alors si notre système général des
retraites fonctionnait nous ne serions
pas là alors pourquoi et je vois que je
ne comprends pas pourquoi s'attaquer ça
a été dit redit à ce qui fonctionne
et là où on cherche l'égalité j'ai peur
qu'on tombe dans l'égalitarisme et le
nivellement vers le bas il y a tellement
de choses qui fonctionnent pas en France
si on pouvait commencer par s'attaquer à
ce qui fonctionne pas et Dieu sait s'il
a listé langue mais comme principe comme
principe et là je m'adresse à mes amis
de ce côté-ci la liberté et la règle
l'interdiction l'exception nous répétons
à longueur de temps que l'État que la
société que les entreprises que les
individus sont corsetés par des normes
sans cesse plus nombreuses nous n'avons
qu'à prendre nos codes différents du
travail tous les codes sont plus épais
qu'à l'étranger et là on va encore
changer les règles et les règles de ce
qui fonctionne je voudrais que je ne
comprends pas et que je voterai contre
la suppression de ces régimes qui
rapportent et qui plaisent à la fois aux
employeurs et aux salariés
que faire alors madame linman
je reviendrai pas sur l'argument ça
coûte rien à l'état c'est satisfaisant
pour les salariés et pour les notaires
et par ailleurs vous êtes dans une
situation vous défendez l'égalité pour
la rendre
ircevable pour nos concitoyens parce que
pour vous l'égalité c'est nivelée par le
bas ça n'a jamais été dans l'histoire
républicaine la conception qu'on avait
puisqu'elle était adossée au progrès
pour tous
et surtout ce qui me frappe c'est que
Monsieur Véran vient de faire des
grandes déclarations avec la réforme des
retraites il y aura pas de perdants et
ben si il va y avoir des perdants mais
alors là il y a au moins ce cas précis
où vous allez avoir dans tous les cas de
figure des perdantes parce qu'elles sont
d'abord des femmes qui puissent qu'ils
vont voir reculer de manière
significative le niveau de retraite en
tout cas pour les nouveaux qui vont
arriver et alors là il y a la clause du
grand-père l'égoïsme organisé vous
n'avez rien à dire ça vous concerne pas
ça concerne vos enfants vos collègues à
venir c'est pas grave pensez qu'à vous
et ben non l'éclair de notaire
aujourd'hui comme les notaires ils
pensent à l'avenir de leur métier à
l'avenir de leurs salariés
et franchement monsieur le ministre
quand on voit les problèmes du pays
l'immense inflation les grands problèmes
de pouvoir d'achat vous n'avez vraiment
rien d'autre à faire que vous occupez
des clercs de notaire qui ne posent
aucun problème à la nation et je n'ai
jamais entendu de matin en prenant mon
café des gens me dire madame la
sénatrice quel scandale c'est clair de
notaire ils sont en train de nous ruiner
quel privilégier franchement c'est des
mauvais coups que vous accumulez métier
par métier là où il y a aucune nécessité
nous voterons contre la suppression de
ce régime
[Applaudissements]
quelques mots d'abord pour dire que ça
aurait pu être une réforme idéologique
et donc on aurait pu entendre que le
gouvernement aurait pu dire bah voilà
tous les régimes spéciaux on les retire
là on se retrouve dans un truc assez
bizarre et moi je plains les cas de
terre parce que finalement il fallait
mettre d'autres gens sur la charrette
avec avec la RATP là il y a eu un choix
j'imagine d'ailleurs cette réunion
intéressante je sais pas si étalée ou un
client où ils sont dit bah alors en mais
qui avec il en faut d'autres alors il
faut cacher camoufler alors Taki comme
idée tu pensais que bon tout ça n'est
pas sérieux bon ça c'est le prêt pour un
deuxième point j'entends la foi la
madame la rapporteur et Monsieur Miss
nous expliquer alors voilà
très honnêtement il y a 70 000 personnes
et comme le disait mon collègue pourquoi
toutes les informations dans cette
réforme notamment la note du Conseil ta
et n'est pas possible de donner à la
représentation nationale qui jusqu'à
preuve du contraire doit pouvoir avoir
les éléments tous les éléments pour voir
justement légiférer convenablement donc
c'est une réforme qui finalement est
bricolé qui change de point de vue assez
fréquemment et il y a malheureusement
des gens qui vont perdre beaucoup avec
vos propositions voilà c'est pour ça que
moi je mettrai effectivement les
amendements comme proposé dernier
inscrit monsieur Calvet
merci monsieur le Président convaincu
par les explications de la rapporteur et
du ministre que je remercie je retire
mon amendement tirer alors madame latrix
compta monsieur Lurel je n'ai pas
d'autres inscrit je ne cherche pas les
vocation
merci monsieur le Président pour revenir
sur les propos de la rapporteur et le
fait qu'il y ait des salariés soumis au
régime de CRPCEN et d'autres le seuil de
17,5 or en fait c'est en dessous d'un
mi-temps et ça concerne très peu de gens
ou temporairement donc la très très
grande majorité des salariés du notariat
et ce ne sont pas que des clercs il y a
des collaborateurs de premier niveau qui
ont des très petits salaires et je pense
que ce renoncer à ce régime pour eux
c'est vraiment une perte de retraite une
perte de revenus et puis j'ai été
vraiment choquée quand le ministre a
parlé de rente parler de rente à propos
de travailleurs alors que la rente quand
même depuis ce quinquennat et le
quinquennat précédent où est-ce qu'elle
est la rente on n'a jamais aussi peu
taxé le capital que depuis ces cinq
dernières années donc la rente elle
n'est pas du côté des travailleurs
monsieur le Président
à la différence de mon collègue je ferai
pas un pas de clair je ferai un pas de
sénateur auquel le Président larchie
nous a ça va mal et avec beaucoup
d'humour initiés pas de sénateur et je
sais pas pourquoi mes collègues ont
quelque chose contre l'éclair disons la
cléric as-tu au sens laïque du terme je
vais défendre la cléricature parce que
ici nous sommes une forme de
cléricatures nous disons le très
clairement et on touche pas à notre
régime j'ai entendu madame la rapporteur
dire que vous comprenez à 17h30 ils sont
déjà régime général mais c'est le cas
pour la fonction publique lorsque vous
êtes en deçà de 28 heures vous êtes
alliés vous n'êtes pas à la CNRS donc
c'est pas une spécificité de ce régime
là le ministre dit mais vous comprenez
ça se fait déjà dans les outre-mer alors
là les outre-merdes sont pionniers mais
non les outre-mer monsieur le ministre
la loi Macron c'est 25% de plus sur les
notaires là c'est une taxe 4% pris sous
le chiffre d'affaires en quoi ça gêne et
c'est vrai qu'il se pose un problème sur
la base juridique le fondement juridique
peut-être constitutionnel parce que
c'est le Parlement qui vote les taxes de
toute nature est-ce une taxe parce que
j'ai entendu le militi vous comprenez
son doit être uniquement les usagers ou
les clients qui payent pas le
contribuable là je ne comprends pas cet
acharnement nous voterons avec
allégresse
bien alors je vais maintenant consulter
le Sénat sur les amendements identiques
344 et suivant puis ensuite je
consulterai sur les abonnements 1946 et
3920 puis sur l'amendement 3900
s'il vous plaît
le scrutin est ouvert le scooter est
ouvert
voilà vous êtes en direct sur l'antenne
de Public Sénat comme à chaque fois
qu'il y a ces scrutin public vous le
comprenez il y a une forme
d'interruption de séance pour laisser
tous les sénateurs votés avec leur carte
magnétique dans l'hémicycle et donc
c'est une façon pour les trois groupes
de gauche comme je vous l'expliquais
depuis le début de l'émission C'est
groupe socialistes écologistes et
communiste et bien de ralentir un peu le
débat avec ce vote électronique et non
pas un vote à main levée donc cela prend
un peu plus de temps cela permet aussi
et bien de dénoncer toujours cette
réforme des retraites et aussi d'appeler
chaque sénateur à s'engager lorsqu'il
vote puisqu'on a la cartographie ensuite
de l'ensemble du vote au niveau du Sénat
on a compris que on était en train
d'examiner la suppression des régimes
spéciaux après celui de la RATP celui de
la Banque de France et on est sur celui
des clairs de notaire on verra qu'il y
en a encore deux autres qui sont
concernés dans la suite de cet examen
donc un scrutin public les huissiers qui
sont dans
l'hémicycle qui sont positionnés pour
s'assurer que tous les groupes peuvent
voter c'est le président ou un
représentant du groupe politique qui va
voter pour l'ensemble de son groupe et
on va pouvoir avoir comme ça la
cartographie de l'ensemble du vote au
niveau du Sénat avec depuis le début
c'est scrutin public depuis le depuis la
journée d'hier et le début de l'examen
des articles et des amendements de
l'examen des de tous ces articles de la
réforme des retraites les mêmes scores
sur ces votes à quelques dizaines de
voix après à chaque fois nous sommes
autour de 90 votants pour ces
amendements de suppression et 240 contre
on va voir que c'est sans doute la même
chose même ratio qui qui risque de se
reproduire dans les secondes qui vont
arriver maintenant on va valoir le
résultat de ce scrutin on va écouter
Gérard Larcher
231 le Sénat n'a pas adopté nous allons
passer au second scrutin public sur les
abonnements identiques 1946 à 3920 le
scrutin est ouvert
deuxième scrutin public il y en aura
trois au total sur cette série
d'amendements puisque les trois groupes
de la gauche je vous le disais
écologiste socialiste et communiste et
bien ce sont relayés pour provoquer ces
scrutins publics qui comme je vous le
disais ralentis c'est l'examen de cette
réforme des retraites nous sommes
toujours donc dans l'article 1 le Sénat
qui a commencé l'examen de la réforme
des retraites jeudi après-midi il y a eu
la discussion générale le premier jour
et depuis hier nous sommes dans l'examen
des articles et des amendements c'est à
dire des différentes mesures de cette
réforme des retraites la toute première
d'entre elles étant à cet article
premier qui vient supprimer 5 régimes
spéciaux en tout cas fermé ces régimes
spéciaux pour les nouveaux entrants
c'était l'explication donnée en séance
donc 5 régimes spéciaux on les a eu à la
suite RATP Banque de France on est sur
les clercs de notaire il y en aura donc
deux autres ensuite et puis après on
pourra peut-être voir se dessiner la
perspective de l'examen dans l'article 2
et donc l'article 2 qui concerne l'index
sur les seniors les sénateurs qui
disposent comme cela jusqu'au 12 mars
pour voter examiner l'ensemble de cette
réforme et donc on va voir que le Sénat
va siéger tous les week-ends
public retour dans l'hémicycle
344 exprimer 340 pour 124 contre 216 le
Seigneur n'a pas adopté
et nous passons au troisième vote qui
porte sur l'amendement 3946
le scrutin est ouvert
alors on voit qu'il y a quand même
quelques surprises parce que on a eu des
votes plus francs depuis le début de
l'examen de cette de cette réforme et là
on voit qu'il y a des scènes Inter et
vous les voyez qui sont positionnés
notamment sur la droite de l'hémicycle
puisqu'on voit des points bleus donc ça
veut dire qu'il y a des sénateurs de la
droite et du centre qui votent bien en
faveur de la suppression de la
suppression donc du maintien de ces
régimes spéciaux alors c'est certes
quelques sénateurs qui sont extrêmement
minoritaires dans leur groupe mais on
vient de le voir et qui il y avait comme
cela quelque chose de peut-être moins
franc que depuis le début de l'examen du
texte où on a eu des votes très nettes
entre la droite c'est naturel et la
gauche sénatoriale alors que j'ai
arraché est en train de clore le scrutin
il va pouvoir donner le résultat de ce
troisième scrutin public
341 pour 106 contre 235 le Sénat n'a pas
adopté
et nous entamons l'examen de 73
amendements qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune
madame briquet
l'amendement 345
merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement vise à ne pas fermer le on va
commencer une nouvelle étape dans
l'examen de cet article 1 pour tout
comprendre on va les rejoindre
mathiasarayez expliquez-nous tout de
suite Mathias s'il vous plaît qu'est-ce
qui va se jouer maintenant écouter les
prochains alinéas qui ont été amandés
plus de 70 fois concerne le régime des
industries gazières et électriques
particulièrement dans l'actualité car
les syndicats du secteur ont annoncé sur
plusieurs sites en France des grèves
reconductibles depuis hier en début
d'après midi une courte manifestation de
la CGT mines énergie a même eu lieu
devant le Palais du Luxembourg ce régime
c'est un régime qui s'applique au 156
entreprises de la branche dont EDF et
engie pour un total de plus de 130 000
cotisants un régime excédentaire en 2021
de plusieurs centaines de millions
d'euros notamment grâce à une taxe
présente dans les factures d'électricité
et de gaz dernière information Quentin
c'est un système où l'âge de départ
moyen est actuellement autour des 60 ans
ce qui est dû notamment à les départs
anticipés liés à la pénibilité merci je
m'intéresse pour toutes les explications
très complètes retour au débat dans
l'hémicycle on revient en salle des
conférences dans quelques minutes avec
une invitée
merci monsieur le Président donc cet
amendement porte sur la suppression des
alinéaires 14 à 16 et qui concerne le
régime spécial de retraite des
industries électriques et gazières alors
soyez j'ai été dit vouloir la
suppression de certains régimes spéciaux
c'est aussi en ce qui nous concerne ne
pas avoir de réponse combien de
personnes seront concernées sont-elles
vraiment trop avantagées dans les
industries électriques et gazières seuls
23% des agents partent 5 ans avant l'âge
légal car ils ont une reconnaissance de
la pénibilité
qui varie selon suivant leur métier
travail de nuit exposition dangereuse
etc ils cotise aussi un peu plus de 13%
de leur salaire contre 10% pour les
salariés du privé la fin du régime
spécial entraînerait véritablement une
perte d'activités au moment où ce
secteur a des difficultés recrutées
madame leur rapporteur vous avez évoqué
l'évolution des métiers et la
disparition de d'une certaine forme ou
de d'un niveau de pénibilité pour
certains d'entre mais dites moi si les
emplois suivant
s dans ce cas conducteur de travaux
monteur électricien monteur de ligne
plombier menuisier chauffeur de camions
magazinier ce sont les emplois qui sont
retenus dans le statut national du
personnel des industries électriques et
gazières pour relever du régime spécial
de retraite ces métiers existent
toujours la pénibilité elle est toujours
là comment demain ces métiers ces agents
qui exercent ces fonctions seront
reconnues dans cette pénibilité comment
sera-t-elle prise en compte remettre en
cause le régime spécial ce régime
spécial c'est une véritable rupture du
contrat social
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues il y a
quand même un moment donné où il faudra
s'arrêter et expliquer pourquoi tel
régime spécial de faire l'objet de
modification et pourquoi pas tel autre
il y a des critères qu'on s'en doute été
retenu par des gens très très sachant
sur le sujet mais pour l'instant tous
les cas au niveau de la population c'est
pas le cas les régimes spéciaux c'est
quelque chose qui s'est mis en place au
fur et à mesure du temps parce qu'on
reconnaissait la pénibilité des métiers
et les conséquences que cette pénibilité
pourrait avoir sur leur vie ou l'aurait
leur espérance de vie les électriciens
comme les gaziers à chaque fois que il y
a une tempête importante dans une partie
du territoire on est très content de
rester peu de temps sans électricité ou
sans gaz parce qu'ils interviennent jour
et nuit dans des conditions parfois
extrêmement difficiles et il faut les
réparations et si pas fait assez vite on
téléphone en disant mais qu'est-ce qui
se passe pour que je te laisser plus de
6 heures sans électricité donc ce sont
des grands professionnels qui font un
travail difficile et qui mérite
effectivement de la considération et non
pas une modification de leur régime de
retraite tirer vers le bas il est
possible que nous n'arrivions pas à vous
convaincre mais je crois que
malheureusement ce qui va se passer dans
les jours à venir aura force
d'explications rudes et devra vous
amener à retirer ce projet qui somme
toute est vraiment très inéquitable je
chanterai
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues vous aimez rappeler que les
régimes spéciaux coûtent 1,8 milliards
au contribble donc j'ai fait les comptes
faisons les comptes ensemble la
suppression de l'impose de solidarité
sur la fortune coûte 4 milliards au
contribuable
par an ça a été supprimé depuis six ans
donc faites les comptes vous arriverez
rapidement à un résultat qui correspond
aux soi-disant difficile qu'on nous
sommes censés combler avec cette réforme
les super profits que vous refusez
obstinément de taxer c'est 80 milliards
pour le CAC40 cette année qui échappe au
service public
les aides publiques aux entreprises dont
très peu bénéficient d’ailleurs au TPE
PME sans aucune contrepartie ni sociale
ni environnementale ce sont 256
milliards enfin la fortune des 42
milliardaires français elle se chiffre à
546 milliards
rapportons ces montants à ce qui manque
au régime spéciaux qui ont leur histoire
leur légitimité et leur nécessité comme
cela a été rappelé du moins sur les
bancs de cette hémicycle dans les débats
vous voulez depuis le début diviser les
Français mais ils comprennent que votre
politique est de faire pleuvoir des
milliards de cadeaux fiscaux sur les
plus riches et les plus grandes
entreprises qui accumulent comme jamais
les profits depuis 2017 voilà le réel
fond du problème que vous n'abordez
jamais vous avez d'ailleurs choisi de
passer par un PDF RSS pour user des
avantages du 47-1 et depuis juin vous
multipliez
en tout cas nous continuerons jusqu'au
bout inlassablement et avec nos
compatriotes à lutter contre cette
réforme injuste et brutale merci madame
de la Contrie
merci monsieur le président la
commission des affaires sociales à
audits du Sénat pour quelques instants
puisque je suis en compagnie de
Elisabeth Doisneau bonjour vous êtes la
rapporteur général du budget de la
Sécurité sociale alors on vous voit
siéger au banc de la commission tout
devant c'est vous qui donnez votre avis
au nom de la commission sur les
amendements de l'opposition
expliquez-nous pour ceux qui découvrent
peut-être le débat parlementaire elle
aurait de cette réforme des retraites la
rapporteur général qu'est-ce qu'elle
fait quel est son rôle elle contrôle les
équilibres généraux la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale c'est
ça oui en réalité vous avez déjà un
rapporteur général sur les comptes
publics sur les comptes des territoires
etc qui est mon collègue Jean-François
Husson donc il est à la commission des
finances et moi je suis reportage
général sur le budget spécifiquement de
la sécurité sociale alors un mot puisque
vous avez cette casquette particulière
un mot sur ce qui se déroule et sur ce
que vous en pensez du point de vue de la
commission avec
des dizaines de prises de parole soit
pour des amendements soit pour et bien
des explications de vote depuis
maintenant plusieurs heures depuis ce
matin qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous
de ce qui se joue dans l'hémicycle sur
cette article 1 oui effectivement on est
sur l'article 1 qui concerne l'ensemble
des régimes spéciaux donc avec les cinq
qui vont être qui va être fermé par le
gouvernement voilà exactement alors donc
on peut les rappeler c'est 5 en fait
régime il y a celui des
IEG des industries électriques et
gazières de parler actuellement on vient
de voir le régime des clairs de notaire
et employés de nos terres nous avons vu
aussi
et puis il nous reste les comment le
CESU et puis la France et la Banque de
France voilà c'est les cinq qui sont
aujourd'hui amenés à couru ce qu'on a eu
beaucoup de prises de parole depuis le
début de cette matinée mais qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de l'attitude de la
gauche bien écoutez moi je critiques
jamais le droit d'amendement mais c'est
vrai qu'il y a eu une série
d'amendements sur la date éventuelle de
mise en application des fermetures qui a
été vraiment très lassante parce que
chacun avait pris sa date successivement
et donc on n'a pas vraiment avancé mais
pour ce qui est du droit d'amendement je
trouve qu'il est normal alors c'est vrai
que ça fait de longues longues litanie
que nous nous intervenons que à l'issue
de l'ensemble de ses amendements mais
pour autant on est quand même rentré
dans le débat alors qu'hier soir je
trouvais que c'était beaucoup plus lent
et plus difficile alors c'est la
question que j'allais vous poser est-ce
que c'est vraiment un débat est-ce que
c'est pas un monologue de la gauche
alors Bruno Retailleau s'en défend il
dit non il y a nos rapporteurs madame
Doineau bon vous êtes centriste mais
aussi monsieur Savary pour les LR qui
donne l'opinion qui donne comme cela et
bien l'option de la droite et du centre
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils prennent pas plus
la parole vos collègues notamment sont
tristes et LR mais parce que nous avons
aussi envie dans la majorité sénatoriale
d'aller le plus loin possible dans le
texte donc là on sent bien que que la
gauche a posé beaucoup d'amendements
justement pour essayer de ralentir le
mouvement surtout dans la première
partie pour aller très doucement vers
l'article 7 qui est donc l'âge de report
de départ à la retraite je pense qu'ils
veulent que ce soit sans doute examiné
mardi le jour où il y aura la grève
partout dans le pays donc après je sais
pas quelle sera leur intention s'ils
veulent discuter de pénibilité des
carrières longues des carrières hachées
la pénibilité il y a quand même beaucoup
de sujets qui sont très intéressants et
j'ai l'impression que là pour l'instant
ça va être difficile et on va peut-être
les escamoter quoi un mot sur ce qui se
joue maintenant en ce moment dans
l'hémicycle effectivement c'est régime
spéciaux qui concerne les salariés des
industries du gaz électricité ils sont
mobilisés ils font grève depuis hier
c'est salarié ils ont des conditions de
travail qui sont particulièrement
difficiles pourquoi est-ce que il ne
devrait pas bénéficier d'un régime de
retraite spécifique à ces difficultés
comme on a vu aussi pour la RATP avec
des salariés qui travaillent dans le
noir dans des dans des tunnels ou dans
en sous-sol pourquoi est-ce que cette
palier selon vous alors déjà je voudrais
dire que pour l'ensemble de ces régimes
il s'agit d'intervenir sur ce qui se
rembauchaient à partir du 1er septembre
ça veut dire que tous ceux qui ont été
embauchés avec ce contrat le garde-roi
ensuite il faut regarder la clause du
grand-père
2100 l'extinction totale ce sera 2100
parce qu'il y a les retraites de
réversion après donc il faut voir que
c'est quand même pas brutal et puis
surtout deux points le premier c'est que
les conditions de travail ont changé
même s'il reste quand même dans certains
de ces régimes des métiers difficiles et
d'ailleurs on voit que dans ces métiers
de RATP par exemple il y a des actifs
qui peuvent partir plus tôt mais en tout
cas les métiers ont changé parce que
quoi il y a eu progrès technique qui a
fait que voilà les métiers que l'on
faisait il y a 60 ans ne sont plus les
mêmes du tout aujourd'hui donc il faut
en tenir compte et c'est surtout que ces
métiers là s'exercent a on a vu le sujet
de la RATP alors quand on est à Paris
chauffeur de bus on est traité d'une
façon et quand on est à Lyon on est
traité d'une autre est-ce que vous
trouvez ça normal allez on va finir
cette interview avec ce chiffre
3437 amendements c'est le nombre d'un
moment qu'il reste à examiner jusqu'au
12 mars qui est la date limite pour
l'examen au Sénat madame vous semble
faisable ecoutez moi je n'ai pas
l'antéria l'intérieurité de certains de
mes collègues mais je pense
mais d'histoire de sénateur je pense
qu'on en a jamais vu autant en tout cas
récemment alors est-ce qu'il va en être
retiré déjà on voit que certains
orateurs ne sont pas là quand ils sont
appelés pour défendre leurs amendements
alors est-ce que il y aura une décision
de prise par les présidents de
l'opposition moi je le souhaiterais pour
qu'on ait justement plus de cet échange
ce dialogue cette confrontation
est bien par exemple de l'article 38 qui
limite les prises de parole sur les
amendements c'est quelque chose que la
droite et le centre pourrait demander
mais écoutez en tout cas moi je laisse
ça entre les mains du président du Sénat
parce que il est lui maître je dirais de
l'horloge et surtout voilà le plus comme
on dirait-je à même de faire le choix de
cet article 31 alors en quelques mots
pour expliquer bien nos téléspectateurs
si le Sénat ne va pas au bout d'ici le
12 mars et que le texte n'est pas
entièrement examiné qu'est-ce qui se
passe pour nos téléspectateurs vous nous
l'expliquer et bien écoutez le texte
pourrait être au bout du bout comme en
promulgué par ordonnance en fait donc
c'est pour ça que nous voulons en
débattre l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas
eu été au-delà de l'article 2 je le
rappelle donc là on est seulement
l'article 1 il nous reste 10 jours
allons plus vite parce que moi je pense
que ça mérite vraiment de défendre un
certain nombre de de comment de
dispositif c'est surtout qu'au Sénat on
a essayé en tout cas d'y travailler et
de négocier aussi avec le gouvernement
pour qu'il accepte nos préoccupations au
travers d'amendement particulier merci
merci de nous pour toutes ces
explications à notre micro je vous
libère pour que vous puissiez rejoindre
effectivement le banc de la commission
merci
énergétique très forte du fait de la
guerre en Ukraine nous obligeant à
réinterroger notre souveraineté
énergétique supprimer brutalement les
régimes dit spéciaux ne donne absolument
aucun signe favorable envers ses
secteurs pour des professions souvent
très difficiles donc monsieur le
ministre plutôt que de démagogiquement
tout supprimer il me semble que vous
seriez mieux inspiré de retirer cette
réforme de reprendre de véritables
négociations avec les partenaires
sociaux et d'étudier profession par
profession l'opportunité de revenir
intégralement ou en partie sur certains
régimes 10 spéciaux une bonne réforme
des retraites est une réforme qui allie
sauvegarde de la répartition et Progrès
Social pas qui stigmatise certains et
qui montrent les Français les uns contre
les autres je vous remercie monsieur
merci monsieur le Président cher
collègue avant de commencer mon propos
j'aimerais dire à Monsieur le Ministre
que lorsque l'outre-mer où les
outre-mers sont pionnières
et que on devrait généraliser ce qui se
fait de bon et bien non on supprime
c'est l'article 10 sur le seuil de
récupération sur succession nous sommes
à 100000 depuis très très longtemps ces
39000 l'héritage à partir de notre nommé
vont commencer à payer une cote-part sur
la solidarité nationale qui aurait été
octroyée
aux parents
ici
deuxième principe
est une discrimination lorsque l'on
traite de manière identique des
situations différentes là il s'agit de
situations différentes on a tenté
d'installer depuis longtemps des
critères de pénibilité d'invalidité de
handicap vous avez rouliez tout ça en
supprimant au moins 4 critères et en
alignant non pas vers le haut mais cette
fois-ci vers le bas et c'est pas
dire du mal du régime général vous
appauvrissez
les gens c'est une évidence et je finis
monsieur le Président sur l'héritage
quand même que
le régime
IEG c'est quand même quelque part les
vitesses du Conseil National de la
Résistance ici à ici des gens qui se
réclament de cet héritage là y compris à
droite l'égoïste sociaux vous mettez fin
à ça moi je crois au symbole et là vous
mettez fin à un héritage prestigieux
quoi qu'on en dise au point que vous
limitez dans son acronyme le Conseil
national de la refondation alors à 10 de
refondation on peut pas faire pire
sur le président
oui ce régime donc spécial
des industries électriques et gazières
concerne auprès de 140 000 salariés
travaillant dans 157 entreprises de la
branche
je voudrais dire d'abord que peut pas
être tout le temps sur la vision qu'il
faut avoir un système social qui
fonctionne des évidemment
des relations entre les syndicats et le
patronats qui permettent par branche de
trouver des solutions et lorsqu'elles
sont trouvées les remettre en cause par
une procédure qui soit une procédure
parlementaire il y a quelque chose assez
grossier dans le procédé qui consiste à
remplacer les partenaires sociaux dans
ce domaine et dans ce domaine
particulier lorsque 157 entreprises une
branche se mettent d'accord sur un
système qui sommes-nous pour pouvoir le
remettre en cause ici donc cette ce
régime prend contre ça a été dit des
métiers de la pénibilité la plus
importante en se basant sur un système
baptisé service actif et concerne
effectivement que 23% des des personnels
des IEG qui peuvent prétendre à ce
dispositif donc ce n'est pas un régime
comment dire général pour l'ensemble des
salariés mais bien précis par rapport à
des difficultés ou des contingences
particulières et alors évidemment en
raison de la décote imposée les salariés
même s'ils ont conservé des droits
retardent de plus en plus leur âge de
départ l'âge moyen de départ en retraite
et de 60 ans il devrait atteindre les 62
ans en 2024 par ailleurs revenir sur le
régime spécial nous répond à aucune
rationalité économique puisque le régime
est excédentaire cette excédent
d'ailleurs a rapporté 120 millions
d'euros de plus que le versement des
pensions au régime général et donc par
rapport aux questions que nous avons à
trouver je pense que effectivement nous
devrions nous élever et éviter de poser
des soucis à des personnels dont on
demande bientôt beaucoup beaucoup plus
encore dans les années qui viennent
qu'aujourd'hui
c'est Houlgate
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues avec ce
projet de loi budgétaire on bouscule en
fait tout un édifice nous avons examiné
le mois dernier le projet de loi
d'accélération des procédures liées à la
construction de nouvelles installations
nucléaires dans l'hypothèse où les
débats publics et la future PPE acterait
la relance effective du nucléaire dans
notre pays la réussite de ce programme
suppose deux conditions la première la
confiance des populations qui habitent
près des installations je m'étendrai pas
mais je mentionne quand même et même si
c'est pas le sujet que le projet de
démembrement de l'IRSN introduit par
amendement gouvernemental lors de la
navette parlementaire va altérer
considérablement cette confiance et
compliquée la concertation doullard de
se tirer une balle dans le pied la
deuxième condition c'est la capacité à
mobiliser les compétences et là on se
tire une balle dans le deuxième pied le
gouvernement semble ne pas avoir compris
que une situation énergétique de notre
pays est extrêmement grave il s'agit
d'un enjeu stratégique national de
souveraineté de compétitivité pour nos
entreprises de confort aussi pour nos
citoyens de décarbonation de notre
économie dans un contexte d'urgence
climatique l'Usine Nouvelle de décembre
dernier indique que pour construire de
nouveaux réacteurs en France la filière
nucléaire doit recruter au moins 10 000
personnes par an à partir de 2023 dont
3000 pour les seuls besoins d'EDF aucune
filière industrielle n'a de telles plans
de charges devant elle et que fait-on on
réduit son attractivité alors dans
l'hypothèse où le régime spéciale serait
fermé il est évident que pour compenser
ce manque d'attractivité EDF doit offrir
des compensations salariales aux
nouveaux entrants mais je ne pense pas
que EDF en ce moment et les moyens de le
faire ce projet de loi va pénaliser la
mise en œuvre de la future programmation
de programmation plus annuelle de
l'énergie
madame Lubin
monsieur pardonnez-moi
oui monsieur le Président je n'ai pas
grand chose à ajouter à ce qui a été dit
par mes collègues concernant ce régime
particulier si ce n'est d'insister comme
cela a déjà été fait sur le caractère
absolument stratégique de ce secteur
d'activité dans la période que nous
traversons nous avons des enjeux de
conversion
de notre modèle environnemental et de la
durabilité de nos politiques
industrielles singulièrement en matière
de production énergétique je ne crois
pas qu'il soit tout à fait opportun de
venir bousculer les équilibres
patiemment construits pour les salariés
de ce secteur et en raison des
spécificités très grandes de leur métier
par une réforme qui ne paraît pas
justifiée donc je partage évidemment la
vie déjà maintes et maintes fois
exprimée par mes collègues de maintenir
ce régime particulier pour les
professionnels de ces secteurs
énergétiques merci Madame jasmin
madame Lubin pardonnez-moi
décidément
voilà bien un beau service public qui
petit à petit a été démantelé
quelle belle idée pourtant de distribuer
l'énergie partout en France de manière
publique c'est-à-dire que tout le monde
soit égal devant cette énergie si
importante et primordiale pour chacun
des Français puis petit à petit je dois
bien reconnaître que chacun a pris sa
part t'aime plus que d'autres mais bon
j'aimerais pouvoir dire que nous n'y
avons jamais pris aucune part
petit à petit ce service a été
démantelés et aujourd'hui nous avons
quelques spécialistes ici dans le groupe
qui nous explique et qui nous
expliqueeront encore que
la fourniture d'énergie fait un nous
sommes nous sommes en danger quelque
part face à cette question de la
fourniture de l'énergie et
dans ce projet de loi nous allons
finalement mettre le coup de grâce
en nous attaquant au statut quelque part
des salariés de ce de
ce domaine là
EDF GDF nous allons attaquer le statut
en attaquant les retraites
ça a été dit ce sont des gens dont on a
besoin et dont on se félicite de les
trouver lorsque nous subissons les coups
du sort je me souviens par exemple de la
tempête cloud dans les Landes en
ou une énorme partie du Massif landais
était tombé et où des gens s'étaient
retrouvés dans une situation
apocalyptique que nous n'aurions jamais
cru connaître heureusement qu'ils
étaient là et que ce service était là et
nous devons continuer à les soutenir
merci Monsieur la Présidente c'est
amendement vise à maintenir les filières
de gars du gaz et de l'électricité il
faut justement contrairement à ce qui
est proposé dans ce texte valoriser ses
filières qui sont très utiles pour le
développement économique du pays
remettre encore ces régimes spéciaux
c'est aussi rendre une attraction les
nombreux métiers les différentes
filières concernées et là encore c'est
une très grave erreur il est au
contraire nécessaire de mettre en
adéquation la gestion prévisionnelle des
emplois et des compétences nous avons
voté récemment la loi sur les années
nous avons un mix énergétique a bien
organisé sur le territoire national il
faut de l'attractivité pour renouveler
les effectifs pérenniser les emplois
sauver ce mix énergétique mais c'est
surtout un enjeu stratégique nous allons
regretter et chers collègues je vous
invite depuis le mois de juillet dernier
j'avais attiré l'attention sur ce qui
nous attendaient nous sommes dans un
contexte de guerre la guerre est en
Ukraine mais il y a des menaces des
menaces surtout sur le territoire
hexagonal nous avons encore la chance
d'avoir du soleil mais faites attention
là ce serait une grave erreur monsieur
la ministre je vous en supplie retirer
ce texte
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues monsieur le ministre la
suppression du régime spécial des IEG et
de fait comme le disait Monique Lubin la
casse du statut des IEG constitue un
non-sens et un détournement de procédure
grossier que je veux ici dénoncer la
procédure dérogatoire d'adoption des
lois de sécurité sociale qui nous oblige
aujourd'hui n'a jamais eu pour vocation
de permettre d'introduire insidieusement
de véritables réformes sociales de fonds
relevant par principe du domaine de la
loi ordinaire de surcroît les
conséquences multiples de la suppression
des régimes spéciaux coopèrent l'article
premier sont manifestes elles n'ont pas
été évaluées dans toutes leurs
implications productives sociales et
managériales et leurs effets directs
budgétaires ne sont pas avérés les
futurs salariés les IEG n'ont pas à
faire les frais des difficultés
actuelles d'EDF dont le seul responsable
est l'état français et ceux qui l'ont
dirigé depuis des décennies la
suppression des régimes spéciaux des IEG
pour les seuls personnels recruter à
compter du 1er septembre 2023 et sans
effet direct sur les dépenses et sans
effet direct sur les recettes
puisqu’elles se bornent à introduire un
changement de régime d'affiliation de
ces personnels au profit du régime
général sans affectation directe
directement sans affecter directement le
montant des cotisations versées elle n'a
donc rien à faire dans un projet de loi
de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale mais elle confirme que
le grand oeuvre du président des riches
et de ses gouvernements successifs et
bien depuis 2017 la suppression des
statuts historiques qui ont contribué à
la force industrielle et sociale de la
France
issus du Conseil National de la
Résistance on savait que le
ruissellement vers le bas était une
fable on voit ici que le ruissellement
par le haut et la nouvelle forme de
spoliation de ce qui reste du capital
social pour beaucoup de Français ils
l'ont compris et vont vous le rappeler
dans les jours à venir
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cet
amendement vise à ne pas fermer le
régime spécial de retraite des
industries électriques et gazières le
secteur de l'énergie et d'une importance
stratégique encore plus actuellement
alors que le mur des investissements
dans les installations de production
d'électricité et devant nous la
fermeture de ces régimes spéciaux des
métiers de l'énergie sont un non-sens
absolu car ces métiers sont durs et
fermés ce régime et particulièrement
brutal jusqu'à présent prise en compte
des six derniers mois et on va passer au
25 meilleures années le départ était à
62 ans au plus tard il va passer à 64
ans les durées de cotisations ont évolué
de 37 ans et demi en 2007 on est passé à
43 ans maintenant or nous avons besoin
de salariés qui soient bien dans leur
travail c'est notre intérêt et le leur
nous avons tout simplement également
besoin de salariés de l'énergie et la
question de l'attractivité se pose la
dureté du travail
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues c'est un
avancement de suppression
de la décision de la proposition
proposée dans le projet de loi tout
simplement parce que nous sommes tous et
toutes
témoins de l'engagement de l'abnégation
des agents concernés
je vais parler de 1999 la tempête Lothar
dans le nord de la France
quelques jours plus tard le lendemain la
tempête Martin dans le sud de la France
2009 c'était la tempête Klaus comme il a
fait référence ma collègue Monique Lubin
et régulièrement dans le département
respectifs ce sont des épisodes cévenol
des épisodes méditerranéens des
inondations et à chaque fois que les
ministres arrivent à chaque fois que les
élus arrivent ils rencontrent trois
types d'agents les premiers ce sont les
agents de la sécurité civile les
sapeurs-pompiers qu'on va saluer qu'on
va remercier les seconds se sont les
agents qu'on appelle les routiers les
agents des services des routes des
départements qui sont là pour déblayer
qui sont là pour ôter les arbres qui
bloquent la circulation et les troisième
ce sont les agents qui sont là pour
rétablir l'électricité et le chauffage
et à chaque fois les élus les ministres
les saluent et tire une légitime fierté
de ce service public qui sait se
mobiliser pour établir les conditions de
vie normale les conditions de travail
pour les Françaises et les Français
ce régime spécial il est mérité il vient
saluer justement l'engagement la
pénibilité de ces travaux j'ai parlé des
périodes exceptionnelles mais je
pourrais vous parler au quotidien de
l'engagement de ces hommes de ces femmes
c'est moins spectaculaire il n'y a pas
de caméra de télévision il n'y a pas des
lieux qui vont à leur rencontre mais à
chaque fois qu'il y a un accident sur la
route à chaque fois qu'un camion rentre
dans un pylone ce sont ces hommes et ces
femmes qui vont se mobiliser pour
établir l'électricité à chaque fois
qu'un arbre tombe sur un pylône ce sont
ses hommes et ces femmes qui se
mobilisent pour aller rétablir
l'électricité et le gaz si cela la
réalité et ce régime spécial il est venu
sanctionner positivement la pénibilité
de leurs travaux et l'engagement de ses
amis et ses femmes au quotidien
madame
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président
c'est amendement vise à ne pas fermer
donc le régime spécial de retraite des
industries électriques et gazières qui
s'applique régime qui s'applique au 156
entreprises de la branche des IEG donc
bien sûr EDF et engie et qui compte plus
135000 cotisants au 31 décembre de
l'année 2021 EDF étant le principal
employeur du secteur est regroupant
44,7% des effectifs des yeuxg la réforme
va supprimer les notions de service
actif et le service insalubre qui donne
droit à des majorations de durée
permettant une retraite anticipée à ceux
qui occupent ces postes pénibles
les régimes d'EDF prévoient une
meilleure prise en compte de la
pénibilité car certains de ces
travailleurs subissent une espérance de
vie inférieure à la moyenne des Français
ou des incapacités de travail
importantes pour notre part nous
souhaitons que ces mesures protectrices
et tenant compte de la pénibilité des
métiers puis est impliqués à l'ensemble
des Français dont les conditions de
travail sont pénibles et usantes une
nouvelle fois la notion de pénibilité de
travail au travail semble négliger par
le gouvernement c'est pourquoi nous
mettons c'est vraiment demande de
suppression
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous
parlons ici du régime spécial des
entreprises électriques et gazières
et compte tenu c'est assez stupéfiant de
voir
que depuis un an il n'y a pas un jour au
Sénat ou nous ne sommes pas le bilan de
ces 25 dernières années de politique
énergétique en constatant combien ce que
ce qui a été fait depuis 25 ans
aujourd'hui dans le mur
chacun le constate à chaque fois que
nous faisons des auditions sur ce sujet
et pourtant vous nous proposez et vous
allez voter une remise en cause d'un
régime qui finalement en remettant en
cause ce régime vous allez continuer
vous allez approfondir ce qui fait
depuis 25 ans en matière de politique
énergétique dans ce pays alors il
conviendrait de changer il conviendrait
aussi de faire en sorte de regarder et
de tirer les conséquences de ce que nous
constatons depuis un an c'est à dire
qu'il faut changer de route concernant
notre politique énergétique l'évaluation
des pénibilités des métiers notre
collègue Usain borgh il a rappelé de
personnes qui sont mobilisables à tout
instant qui sont en astreinte permanente
pour des tâches pénibles parfois
dangereuses parfois très dangereuse nous
avons un système qui est capable de de
d'évaluer la pénibilité pour ceux qui
ont ces tâches là
voudriez vous abandonner cela pour
verser ces personnes au régime général
il n'est pas logique de faire cela
nous avons de ce point de vue là besoin
de ces compétences nous avons besoin de
maintenir cette attractivité et le
respect de cette pénibilité et de ce que
nous attendons des personnels des
entreprises électriques et gazières
savons-nous combien nous avons besoin de
compétences dans ce domaine combien de
centrales ont conclure combien de
centrales nucléaires ont besoin de ses
compétences et pourquoi alors ne
faisons-nous ne changeons-nous pas la
politique énergétique en marquant un
coup d'arrêt à ce que nous faisons
depuis 25 ans dans le domaine et en
refusant de passer dans le régime
général
exactement 19h à l'antenne de Public
Sénat bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez
nous examinons nous suivons l'examen de
la réforme des retraites depuis jeudi
l'examen des articles les Allemands qui
a commencé depuis hier après-midi et les
sénateurs qui sont toujours dans
l'article 1 celui qui est bien voila la
fermeture de 5 régimes spéciaux pour en
parler on va rejoindre notre journaliste
Mathias araes bonsoir Mathias vous
suivez tous les débats au plus près
depuis la tribune de presse de
l'hémicycle on en est où Mathias et bien
écoutez nous en sommes aux amendements
qui concernent les alinéas qui se
réfèrent à la suppression du régime des
industries gazières et électriques vous
le savez ce régime s'applique au 156
entreprises de la branche dont EDF et
engie pour un total de plus de 130 000
cotisants un régime qui était
excédentaire en 2021 de plusieurs
centaines de millions d'euros notamment
grâce à une taxe présente dans les
factures d'électricité et de gaz autre
information c'est un système où l'âge de
départ moyen et actuellement autour de
60 ans ce qui est dû notamment à des
départs anticipés liés à la pénibilité
c'est également un régime qui est
particulièrement de lactualité car les
syndicats du secteur ont annoncé sur
plusieurs sites en France se mettre en
grève une grève reconductible depuis
hier donc depuis plusieurs minutes
maintenant on assiste à des dépôts
d'amendement visant à supprimer la
suppression de ce régime entendait le
maintien de ce régime deux types
d'amendement le premier visant à
maintenir ce régime et le deuxième type
d'amendement et bien c'est des
amendements qui vise à reporter la
suppression de ce régime dans leur
défense les sénateurs essentiellement
issus de l'aile gauche de l'hémicycle
mettre notamment en avant la pénibilité
de ces secteurs mais également le fait
que et bien ce type de régime peut être
très attractif en au moment de rec des
employés dans le secteur merci Mathias
pour ces explications et on le comprend
la gauche sénatoriale qui use de toutes
les armes parlementaires disponibles au
Règlement du Sénat pour et bien
rallonger les temps de discussion autour
de cette réforme pour s'y opposer bien
sûr et donc on voit à la fois des dépôts
d'amendement très multiples et aussi des
prises de parole avec des explications
de vote ou encore des scrutins publics
la gauche sénatoriale qui use donc de
toutes ces armes pour se poser à la
réforme et en face d'elle une droite
sénatoriale assez peu présente dans le
débat on peut le dire avec quelques
prises de parole surtout sur les bandes
de la commission mais très peu dans les
travers de l'hémicycle
d'ailleurs dans cette idée c'est l'idée
d'un salarié souple flexible totalement
mobile capable de passer d'un métier à
nos d'un poste à un autre toujours
j'entendais président de la République
dire à propos à une quelqu'un qui lui
demandait mais une infirmière à 64 ans
vous pensez qu'elle est encore en forme
pour faire son métier et il y a eu cette
réponse étonnante il a répondu mais à 64
ans elle aura déjà changé de métier mais
non les gens changent pas de métier tout
le temps ça marche pas comme ça dans la
vie leur savoir-faire leur expérience en
stabilité ça ne fait pas d'eux des êtres
totalement adaptés en permanence aux
besoins du marché mais surtout ça
dévalorise le savoir et en fait en vous
attaquant au régime spéciaux vous
dévalorisez l'identité le savoir-faire
la fierté que donne un métier et
l'appartenance à une entreprise aussi
importante dans le service public des
Français qui est celle que nous devons
dans cet amendement
merci mes chers collègues vous entendons
depuis ce matin sur la suppression des
régimes spéciaux je me dis que nous ne
devons peut-être pas être nombreux à
avoir eu des parents qui ont exercé des
métiers pénibles
enfin je voyais mon père à partir nuit
comme jour tempête inondations feu neige
48 heures durant plus même sans compter
les heures pour réparer et rebrancher
installation électrique en haut des plus
des pylônes au plus vite pénibilité
dansé c'était son quotidien
le stress qu'un incident intervient à
tout moment pendant les dépannages ou
qu'ils mettent en danger la vie d'un
membre de son équipe la sienne aussi
combien d'entre nous nous en tant qu'élu
au lendemain des tempêtes comme l'a dit
mon collègue Hussein dans nos
territoires avons-nous rendu hommage à
ces hommes et ces femmes qui travaillent
pour le bien et la sécurité de nous tous
de nos concitoyens souvent dans les
pires conditions
vous demandez aujourd'hui la suppression
de leur régime spéciaux qui est une
mesure de justice sociale et d'équité
prenant en compte la pénibilité de leur
travail chers collègues auriez-vous la
mémoire courte Bruno Retailleau tout à
l'heure que je respecte mais addicts
spéciaux abîment le commande non
justement dans ce cas il garantit le
commun le bon fonctionnement notre pays
et de ses services publics nous avons
besoin de ces hommes les deux ces femmes
de ces personnels qui sont de plus en
plus et qui sont aujourd'hui un enjeu
stratégique pour notre pays enfin le
régime de retraite des industries
gazières et électriques est adossé au
régime général depuis 2008 il ne doit
rien à la solidarité nationale au
contraire il y contribue il y contribue
en lui apportant des recettes sous le
slogan on meurt plutôt et on part plutôt
ce régime est présenté comme un régime
pionnier par ses bénéficiaires prenant
en compte la pénibilité au travail à une
espérance de vie entacher et au
bouleversement des conditions de vie mes
chers collègues leur régime si spécial
doit être maintenu je vous le demande
merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole d'État notre collègue pour
l'amendement
je te présente
oui merci monsieur le Président beaucoup
de choses ont été dites et c'est vrai
que moi aussi je voulais parler des
tempêtes parce que je trouve que il y a
un parallèle quand même avec ce qu'on a
connu avec la covid c'est cette
reconnaissance purement symbolique de
discours quand il y a un grand événement
comme la tempête et effectivement il
faut souvenir de 1999 et effectivement
après ce qui s'ensuit c'est à dire que
pour les métiers de soins et d'aide rien
de plus et pour ce qui est de des
électriciens des gaziers et bien une
remise en cause de leur système on va
pas redire ce qu'on a dit sur la RTP
c'est absolument la même chose
c'est-à-dire que ce sont des régimes qui
en fin de compte reconnaissent et
préviennent l'exposition à des risques
et à des facteurs de pénibilité
spécifiques donc ce sont des systèmes
protecteurs on peut les appeler
pionniers dans le sens où il devrait
effectivement
être un exemple un modèle pour les
autres de faire cela alors il faut
effectivement ça a été dit dans les
entretiens on est passé en traitant
entre très peu de temps de 15 ans où il
fallait faire du service actif pour voir
partir à 55 ans pour les industries
électriques et gazières à 17 ans de
service actifs pour partir à 55 et puis
après à 17 ans maintenant pour partir à
59 ans alors on nous dit bon bah ils
vont passer au C2P je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure pour la RATP le C2P avec un âge
légal à 64 ans c'est deux ans avant pour
un départ anticipé c'est à dire qu'on va
leur dire de passer à un départ
reconnaissant la pénibilité
reconnaissante 17 ans de pénibilité
d'exposition au risque de 59 ans à 62
ans c'est-à-dire ils pourront pas partir
avant 62 ans et bien ils auront le même
taux d'invalidité permanente un départ
sur cinq et dû à l'invalidité perman
ente eux ils en ont moins puisqu'ils
préviennent effectivement et en passant
au régime général vous aurez 20%
d'invalides
permanent à 62 ans
Madame A pour ce poly pour présenter
l'amendement
3932 merci monsieur le Président les
retraités des des IOG qui représentent
un peu moins de 1% de l'ensemble des
retraités ont un régime qui n'a jamais
été tributaire ni de l'État ni des
autres régimes pourquoi cet acharnement
a le supprimer pour des raisons
financières non le régime est
excédentaire pour des raisons d'équité
le régime participe au financement
d'autres régimes qui comptent moins
d'actifs que de retraités comme ceux des
agriculteurs et des artisans en raison
de la contribution tarifaire
d'acheminement qui soi-disant coûterait
1,7 milliards aux usagers pourtant cette
contribution est une imposition de toute
nature et non une aide d'État qui se
substitue et c'est le choix qui a été
fait lors de la libéralisation du
secteur en 2004 par le gouvernement
Raffarin à part du tarif d'électricité
et de gaz naturel qui assurait le
financement la perte des droits
spécifiques passées correspondant aux
activités régulières la CTA et neutre
sur le prix global a quitté par le
client final ainsi et pour le
contribuable comment pouvez-vous
garantir la pérennité du régime alors
que nous savons que la fameuse clause du
grand-père conduira à appliquer le
régime général à tout nouvel entrant
traînant rapidement la bord du régime
général avec de moins en moins de
cotisants il ne pourra pas survivre
aucune des raisons que vous invoquez ne
tient à la route ne nous y trompons pas
aujourd'hui comment 2004 la suppression
du régime des IEG est à chercher dans
votre volonté du démantèlement du
service énergétique français des
intentions de
dépeçage et la dislocation d'EDF vient
un plan Hercule qui peut revenir à
chaque instant malgré l'opposition
unanime des organisations syndicales et
de ceux qui défendent un service 100%
public engie entreprise privée ne s'est
jamais cachée de son rêve de sortir du
statut national c'est la seule
justification à l'article 1 que ce soit
pour les sujet ou la RATP je vous
remercie merci
et gazier est profondément lié à
l'importance que notre pays accordait à
la question énergétique et à la volonté
de bâtir des entreprises publiques
puissantes capables de relever les défis
de l'électrification de notre pays de
l'après-guerre ce régime c'est consolidé
au fil du temps pour garantir aux
électriciens et aux gaziers au niveau de
droit correspondant aux contraintes et à
la pénibilité de leur mission on parle
ici de femmes et d'hommes profondément
engagés dans le service public de
l'électricité du gaz et aujourd'hui nous
sommes à nouveau face à des défis
majeurs relance du nucléaire en France
construction de nouveaux pr nécessité de
renforcer nos réseaux de distribution
pour faire face à l'essor des énergies
renouvelables déploiement au niveau
industriel du véhicule électrique et
malice est loin d'être exhaustive et
pour assurer cette transition
énergétique il faudra des agents de plus
en plus qualifiés il faudra consolider
les compétences et les savoir-faire et
recréer un tissu industriel de qualité
en effet aujourd'hui le régime spécial
de retraite des IEG fait partie d'un
pack global qui reflète notamment un
certain nombre d'astreintes et de
difficultés au travail dès lors quelle
erreur historique de vouloir supprimer
un régime qui est aussi avec un vecteur
d'attractivité dans un secteur essentiel
la suppression du régime spécial des
i.e.g ne traduit en vérité que votre
volonté de remettre en cause leur statut
et d'achever par la même l'émission de
service public en effet la caisse des
IEG je l'ai dit à plusieurs reprises et
plusieurs de mes collègues également
étaient excédentaires elle a largement
contribué à alimenter les comptes du
régime général ces dernières années les
électriciens négasiés cotisent à un
niveau supérieur et se constitue
mutuellement des droits à la retraite
correspondant à leur situation c'est un
modèle vers lequel il faut se tourner il
s'agit pas à nos yeux de régime spéciaux
mais nous l'avons dit et je leur ai
affirme de régime pionnier nous sommes
attachés à la défense de ces conquis
sociaux c'est pourquoi nous demandons la
suppression des alinéas 15 et 16e
merci monsieur le Président là le sujet
dont nous des bâtons est grave
parce que nous ne débattons pas d'un
régime de retraite nous débattons de du
pacte que nous allons passer pour
l'avenir ou que nous allons rompre avec
l'ensemble des salariés des industries
électriques et gazières nous savons tous
que la sécurité de l'approvisionnement
énergétique du pays est à nouveau une
question d'avenir une question qui est
sur la table et il va falloir procéder à
la plus grande mutation de notre système
électrique depuis la construction du
parc électro-nucléaire et du parc
hydraulique de la France donc soit nous
sommes capables de réussir cette
mutation et nous répondrons possiblement
aux enjeux d'industrialisation de
souveraineté d'urgence climatique avec
du nucléaire et avec des ENR soit nous
n'en sommes pas capables et alors rien
ne sera possible or rien de cela ne sera
possible sans une mobilisation générale
et durable de l'ensemble des professions
i.e.g dans le pays or votre projet fait
exactement l'inverse il propose à
travers cette affaire du régime de
retraite de rompre le pacte national qui
a été passé avec les salariés des yeuxg
depuis la Libération et il est en train
de provoquer et ça a commencé parce que
pendant que nous discutons ici les
grèves sont en train de s'étendre dans
tout le pays il est en train de
provoquer la plus grande greffe du
secteur depuis des années pour s'opposer
au projet que vous voulez passer en
force alors ce pacte vous l'avez déjà
beaucoup abîmé la question qui est
devant nous c'est de savoir si vous
allez l'achever ou si au contraire nous
allons le relancer pour l'étendre à
toutes les professions IOG d'aujourd'hui
et à celles que nous devrons embaucher
former pour construire la réussite du
nouveau projet énergétique en France
madame luber
[Applaudissements]
nous entamons une série d'amendements
nous amener à descendre dans le temps
allez-y
monsieur le Président
nous avions envie de continuer le débat
il n'y a pas vraiment de débat sur
les
ces régimes spéciaux notamment sur les
sur les gaziers alors c'est pour ça que
nous avions décliné un certain nombre
d'amendements et des dates voilà mais
finalement il nous semble que notre
parole a été entendue sur le sujet dans
cette hémicycle et donc nous considérons
que tous ces amendements sont défendus
très bien les amendements sont défendus
jusque
voilà l'ensemble des amendements sur des
fourmis merci alors nous allons sur
l'ensemble des amendements avoir la vie
de la commission la vie du gouvernement
et ensuite puisque je suis saisi de
demande scrutin public je l'annonce à
l'avance nous procéderons au scrutin
public madame la rapporteur général
oui mais le président chers collègues
tout comme vous nous rendons hommage aux
femmes et aux hommes qui interviennent
effectivement en cas de tempête en cas
de dommage sur les lignes électriques
sur les canalisations gazières je
voudrais aussi associé à cet hommage
tout ceux qui interviennent pour la
maintenance du réseau et qui sont des
sous-traitants
sur les travaux de maintenance
80% sont réalisés par des sous-traitants
et ils n'ont pas du tout de régime
spécial eux
je voudrais
aussi et qu'il y a plus de 180 000
pensionnés et c'est là où est le
déséquilibre en réalité et
l'État intervient donc pour 5 pour toi
3141 millions d'euros donc 3 milliards
141 donc c'est quand même important sur
cinq virgule 184 milliards d'euros c'est
énorme donc on peut se dire à partir de
là que c'est sans doute normal que on se
pose la question d'aller vers la
fermeture de ce risque vieillesse et je
le rappelle surtout les autres risques
ça reste le régime spécial
de la caisse pour national des
industries
électriques et gazières je voudrais
aussi dire que certains ont parlé de
l'excédent mais l'excédent c'est la
contribution tarifaire et donc ça chacun
d'entre nous y contribue donc pour
toutes ces raisons
nous avons émis un avis défavorable
puisque les propositions des amendements
sont contraires à la vie de la
Commission
monsieur le ministre
mais merci monsieur le Président
gouvernement fait si l'intégralité des
propos de madame le rapporteur général
et donc la vie est défavorable je
voudrais simplement amener trois
compléments le premier pour dire que
parfois dans les explications sur les
présentations d'amendement il est
évoqué sous-entendu mais le terme n'est
pas le mieux choisi donc je fais
attention qu'il y aurait une rupture du
pacte social or je le répète au risque
de la répétition par définition nous
maintenons les régimes spéciaux pour
celles et ceux qui en bénéficient et
seuls les nouveaux embauchés à partir du
1er septembre seront affiliés au régime
général de l'assurance vieillesse c'est
important à souligner pour bien dire que
toutes celles et ceux qui imaginent ou
qui laisse penser que demain l'ensemble
des salariés des IEG n'auraient plus
régime social ne sont pas dans le vrai
sont uniquement les nouveaux qui vont
l'être et cela m'amène à un point qui a
été évoqué rapidement notamment sur les
conséquences de ce qu'on pourrait
appeler ce tarissement du flux par
rapport à un système spécial qui doit
gérer les retraités actuels et celles et
ceux qui gagneront leur retraite sous
couvert toujours de ce régime spécial
nous l'avons déjà fait pour la SNCF et
lorsque nous avons mis en place
l'extinction du statut pour le coup pas
seulement du régime général de pas
seulement du régime d'assurance
vieillesse pour la SNCF nous avons
garanti le financement de la SNCF et de
la même manière que nous avons garanti
le financement de la SNCF bien
évidemment que nous garantirons la
soutenabilité du financement de du
régime de retraite des industries
électriques et gazières la deuxième
chose que je voulais dire ou souligner
et que à plusieurs reprises sur ce sujet
là en particulier a été évoqué le fait
que ce régime avait été mis en place
dans la libération et qui relevait
finalement de l'héritage du Conseil
National de la Résistance il relève en
réalité très directement de l'ordonnance
du 4 octobre 1945 et cette ordonnance du
4 octobre 1945 qui vient acter la
création des régimes spéciaux de manière
générale précise de manière explicite
que cette création provisoire et que
l'objectif est d'aller vers le régime
général et donc lorsqu'on veut prendre
l'héritage de cette période et notamment
sur les textes il faut aller jusqu'au
bout des textes et peut-être que c'est
d'ailleurs en allant progressivement
vers un régime général que nous y sommes
le plus fidèle et enfin il y a un
dernier point que je veux souligner
c'est qu'il n'y a pas d'excédent il peut
y avoir parfois tel ou telle année des
reversements mais un régime qui
s'équilibre et un régime qui produit de
légers excédents alors qu'il bénéficie
d'une contribution payée par l'ensemble
des usagers l'ensemble des clients
aujourd'hui l'ensemble des abonnés à
hauteur d'un milliard 700 millions
d'euros par an ce n'est pas un régime
équilibré parce qu'évidemment si tous
les régimes particuliers bénéficiaient
d'une taxe affectée parce que je précise
pour la bonne compréhension du débat
qu'il y a des jurisprudences qu'il y a
des dispositions législatives qui
précisent que la CTA est bien une taxe
affectée lorsqu'un régime bénéficie
d'une taxe affectée il est plus facile
que ce régime atteigne l'équilibre mais
ça s'appelle le financement de la
solidarité par les contribuables et donc
pour ces raisons un pixel de Madame la
rapporteur les avis sont défavorables
ces amendements de suppression merci
alors j'ai été saisi de trois demandes
de scrutin public d'abord sur les
abonnements identiques 345 et suivant
sur deux amendements ceci à la demande
du groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste pour les trois scrutins
publiques sur l'amendement
3964 puis sur l'amendement
étant donné que pour les amendements qui
ont été présentés de manière globale par
Madame Lubin nous procéderons par un
vote à malvet qui saura pas global donc
explication de vote monsieur temal
voilà retour en salle des conférences
cette pièce qui jouxte l'hémistiques je
suis en compagnie de Cécile ku Kerman
bonjour vous êtes sénatrice communiste
de la Loire porte-parole du PSF alors un
mot sur ce qui se joue ce que vous en
tant que communiste vous avez pensé de
ces débats et qui sont à la hauteur des
enjeux est-ce que c'est pas une forme un
peu de monologue de la part de la gauche
dans l'hémicycle depuis hier bah écoutez
je crois qu'il en tout cas beaucoup
d'amendements effectivement qui ont été
déposés d'ailleurs par les différents
groupes de gauche qui invitent peut-être
à ce à ce sentiment en tout cas de
monologue mais je crois que le débat
d'abord est construit le débat est
structuré les arguments de son posés
sans que voilà à part de temps en temps
peut-être quelques emportements de part
et d'autre et c'est aussi ça le débat
législatif mais dans l'ensemble tout
ceci se passe dans un grand respect la
gauche a certains à gauche notamment
madame de La Gontrie parle d'un bâillon
Retailleau comme si voilà les LR étaient
interdites parole et que ça empêchait le
débat qu'est-ce que vous en pensez je
crois que c'est d'abord et avant tout au
groupe LR qu'il faut le demander voilà
forcer le constater mais de toute façon
l'exercice ce serait trop long
aujourd'hui effectivement elle a la
succession d'un moment de toute façon on
n'invitera pas chacun à prendre la
parole de façon rythmée puisque c'est au
bout de seulement une cinquantaine ou
soixantaine d'amendements que le débat
s'ouvre donc voilà moi je n'ai pas à
commenter la stratégie des autres
groupes si ce n'est qu'en tout cas nous
nous restons dans la ligne qui a été la
nôtre celle d'un nombre d'amendements
raisonné sur le fond mais d'amendement
qui en tout cas sur tous les articles
sur tous les enjeux de ce texte de loi
nous permettent d'intervenir de donner à
voir et de pointer en quoi ce projet de
loi tel que proposer aujourd'hui n'est
pas juste pour les Françaises et les
Français
de l'examen de ces articles et
amendements vous perdez les arbitrages
lors du vote ça signifie que la réforme
elle va passer qu'est-ce que les
citoyens qui nous écoutent doivent se
dire la droite le centre allié avec le
gouvernement vont réussir à voter une
réforme des retraites au Sénat non moi
je crois d'abord que les citoyens
doivent rester mobilisés et mardi
prochain moi je les invite surtout à se
mobiliser plus que télétravailler comme
l'a dit le ministre Clément bonne donc
ça je crois que c'est la première des
choses vous savez le Parlement il est
aussi soumis à ce qui se passe dans
notre pays et puis nous l'avons déjà vu
alors bien évidemment on sait toujours
cet exemple là mais souvenons-nous du
CPE texte voté au Parlement et qui pour
autant ne rentrera pas en application
donc je crois que il ne faut pas rester
focalisé c'est certainement le débat
d'actualité qui est passionnant mais ne
restons pas focalisé uniquement parce
qu'il se passe au Parlement c'est
important mais la démocratie elle a
j'oser deux jambes elle a le Parlement
elle a le mouvement social et tout ceci
doit pouvoir s'exprimer aussi très
fortement mardi prochain comment est-ce
que vous allez soutenir ce mouvement
social du mardi 7 mars est-ce qu'on peut
s'attendre à un examen de la mesure
phare du texte celle qui est la plus
scrutée sur le décalage de l'âge de
départ de 62 à 64 ans donc l'article 7
est-ce qu'on peut s'attendre à l'examen
de cette mesure le jour de la manif
peut-être le soir du 7 mars
je n'ai pas la
il y a encore la journée demain il y a
encore la journée de lundi et donc
effectivement si l'on en reste on va
dire un rythme de travail c'est notorial
habituel nous devrions arriver
normalement à l'article 7 mardi je crois
que ce serait en tout cas au-delà plus
qu'un symbole mais important moi vous
savez ça fait maintenant plusieurs jours
plusieurs semaines dans le monde
département de partout les gens me
demandent une seule chose même plus
Karman nous voulons qu'il y ait un vote
sur l'article 7 et je crois que c'est
important nous faut l'entendre et à ceux
qui sont pour il y a ceux qui sont
contre mais il y a en tout cas une vraie
exigence populaire à ce que nous
puissions avoir le temps du débat et du
vote sur l'article 7 est-ce que vous
pensez que la majorité de la droite et
du centre et ils vont avoir un vote net
sur cet article 7 ce que vous voulez
provoquer le vote
attention
légèrement du vote et puis sinon nous le
verrons au moment du vote puisque sans
surprise nous demanderons un scrutin
public et bien merci on sera bien sûr
tout ça en direct sur l'antenne de
Public Sénat merci
et vous nous donniez des leçons il
fallait ouvrir les marchés il fallait
casser les statues il fallait dynamiser
les salariés
et qu'est-ce qu'on observe aujourd'hui
jamais on a eu un état énergétique aussi
catastrophique pour le pays
à vous les libéraux qui avaient accepté
qui avait accepté le marché européen
[Musique]
qui avait accepté le marché européen de
l'énergie la reine qui tue et Déesse et
le prix du marché adossé au gaz
la réalité c'est pas notre cas la
deuxième réalité
c'est que vous nous aviez expliqué que
les salariés étaient des nantilles qu'il
fallait casser les statues qu'il fallait
banaliser leur protection sociale et on
manque de compétences et on manque de
motivation et on a le droit des
situations difficiles ou comme on dit
les collègues encore heureux il y a des
gens qui ont la dignité de défendre ce
service public et c'est à eux qu'il est
défendent au quotidien que vous dites
aujourd'hui que vous allez saper leur
système de retraite vous pensez à
conclure et donc je crois que si vous
vouliez économique énergétique et
sociale vous refuseriez d'abandonner les
régimes de desiji
merci monsieur le Président supprimer au
prétendu nom de l'équité et de la
justice sociale certains régimes
spéciaux bien ciblés en particulier dans
des secteurs pourtant stratégiques et
celui de l'IG en est vraiment la preuve
stratégique pour la nation et qui repose
sur la pleine mobilisation des salariés
dans l'exercice de leur mission de
service public s'apparente davantage à
de la provocation qu'à une quelconque
volonté de justice entre les salariés du
régime général et ceux du des services
publics cette décision cette proposition
est totalement incohérente
incompréhensible alors je vais revenir
sur mes deux questions moi aussi
pourquoi le gouvernement veut-il les
supprimer combien de personnes seraient
concernées surtout sont-elles
véritablement trop avantagés serait-il
serait-elle des nantis alors monsieur le
ministre permettez-moi peut-être une
petite incursion dans ma vie privée il
se trouve que je suis la fille d'un
gazier qui est aujourd'hui à la retraite
et je ne crois pas qu'il ait été un anti
un privilégié il a exercé ses missions
ses fonctions son métier dans les
conditions qui étaient les siennes
parfois difficiles et comme cela a été
dit par mes collègues parfois aussi au
péril de sa vie mais il fallait exercer
cette mission de service public alors
non il n'y a pas de nanti il n'y a pas
de privilégié enfin je voulais dire vous
avez annoncé monsieur le ministre que
pourquoi nous nous inquiéter pourquoi
réagir ainsi puisque votre proposition
ne portait que sur les nouveaux entrants
les nouveaux recrutés pardon à partir de
ce premier septembre 2023 et donc avec
un effet lointain mais moi je veux aussi
attirer votre attention si on l'article
l'amendement sur lequel nous nous
pourrons parler
de l'article 7 l'amendement déposé par
notre collègue Retailleau qui vise à
mettre en application cette réforme sur
les régimes spéciaux dès ce mois de
septembre 2023 madame la Présidente
oui merci monsieur le Président en fait
j'ai quelques interrogations autour de
la suppression du statut des IEG donc
cette suppression prévue par les alinéas
14 à 16 de l'article 1 comporte
effectivement à un certain nombre de
questions et j'aimerais bien
d'incertitudes et j'aimerais bien que
Monsieur le Ministre puisse y répondre
la première question si les nouveaux
embauchés des IEG à partir du 1er
septembre verse leur cotisation
au régime de droit commun et agir Arrco
ou Arrco et non plus à la caisse
nationale desieg il y aura donc un
manque de recettes certain qui complera
le manque de cotisation la cotisation
employeur du régime spécial question la
contribution tarifaire d'acheminement là
c'était un question
l'étude d'impact qu'il est précisé que
la suppression devrait conduire à ce qui
est environ
4490 nouveaux affiliés au régime général
entre septembre et décembre 2023 et
autant en moins pour les régimes
concernés avec des impacts en cotisation
de plusieurs dizaines de millions
d'euros de recettes supplémentaires pour
le premier et de moins pour les autres
dès le premier quadrimestre 2023 la
fermeture de principaux régimes spéciaux
de retraite au profit du régime général
a un impact direct en recette puisque
les changements de régime d'affiliation
des nouveaux embauchés dans les secteurs
concernés entraînera une modification
des flux de cotisation qui finance les
régimes dès 2023 et qui ira croissant
d'année en année cette fermeture aura
donc pour conséquence une augmentation
du besoin de financement des régimes
fermés mais leur modalités de
financement permettront de garantir leur
soutenabilité financière à court terme à
court terme
il ne devrait pas y avoir de problème
pour le paiement des retraites qu'en
est-il monsieur le ministre a moyen et à
long terme dans le cadre de la
neutralité du régime des USG il ne sera
pas question de recevoir ni de
subventions publiques ni de financement
des autres organismes de sécurité
sociale comment comptez-vous faire
comment allez-vous éviter la faillite du
régime je vous remercie merci Madame
pouce et bon
merci monsieur le Président tout d'abord
je souhaiterais dire qu'on peut être une
défonceuse forte durée du régime
IEG sans pour autant le baser et
l'expliquer par la fuite en avant
nucléaire effectivement vous avez raison
les sous-traitants dans le nucléaire
effectivement existe à plusieurs
d'ailleurs sous-traitants et c'est une
façon d'ailleurs de ne pas faire face à
son coût et à sa dangerosité j'aurais de
nouveau répondre à Monsieur le Ministre
oui oui tout à fait moi je ne pense pas
que c'est une rupture du contrat j'ai
bien compris effectivement la clause du
grand-père et si vous voulez c'est même
enfin c'est là c'est un problème aussi à
savoir non pas que vous la mainteniez
mais ça pose effectivement ça a été dit
par le président de la Caisse un
problème de cohésion ceux qui vont
travailler sur les pylônes électriques
qui seront les nouveaux entrants ou ceux
qui n'auront pas le même régime que les
les protéger de la clause de du
grand-père et effectivement les
responsables RH je pense vous remercie
pour votre contribution à la cohésion
des équipes et à la cohésion de
l'entreprise je l'ai dit pour la RATP et
c'est valable ici ils vont gérer
plusieurs collectifs pourtant qui
exercevront les mêmes activités ils vont
gérer des gens avec statut et avec
l'ancien régime de retraite qui leur
permet de partir à un âge avant d'être
cassé c'est la clause du grand-père ils
vont gérer ceux qui sont qui auront le
statut mais sans le régime effectivement
de la retraite c'est les nouveaux
entrants ils vont gérer ceux qui sont
sans statut et sans régime ce sont les
sous-traitants donc effectivement il va
y avoir un véritable problème dans les
équipes et de cohésion d'entreprises
dans une entreprise voilà qui qui en a
pourtant bien besoin et puis dernière
chose donc j'ai encore un peu de temps a
priori
je voudrais quand même dire que
l'attractivité reste largement
considérée comme un élément essentiel de
couverture sociale du secteur merci le
président
Laurent
monsieur le ministre comme nous parlons
devant les Français comme vous l'avez
dit je ne veux pas vous laisser dire ce
que vous avez dit tout à l'heure sur
l'ordonnance de 45 parce que vous êtes
livré à une imposture on prétendant que
les ce que vous faisiez en ce moment
serait dans la filiation des ordonnances
de 405 en 45 il y a parmi le
gouvernement mis en place par le général
de Gaulle entre autres deux ministres
communistes qui sont chargés de les
mettre en oeuvre hongroise Croizat qui
met en œuvre qui commence à mettre en
oeuvre le projet de création de la
Sécurité sociale avec l'ambition de la
généralisation de la sécurité sociale et
un second ministre communiste tous les
deux étaient des ouvriers syndicalistes
Marcel Paul qui va aboutir à la création
d'électricité de France
et à Électricité de France effectivement
Marcel Paul et les syndicalistes
construisent un régime de protection
sociale qui a vocation dont leur esprit
à s'étendre à l'ensemble du monde du
travail et pas c'est exactement le
contraire de ce que vous faites donc
vous ne pouvez pas vous réclamer de ça
c'est une imposture les héritiers de
Marcel Paul et d'Ambroise Croizat ils
sont sur c'est bon pas sur les bancs du
gouvernement ils sont dans la rue
aujourd'hui pas aux côtés de ceux qui
mettent en pièce le régime de sécurité
sociale des agents d'EDF
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues monsieur le ministre
j'aurais pas eu l'occasion de
cette expression pour rendre hommage aux
centaines de milliers
d'agents hommes-femme gazier électricien
qui depuis 1946
son l'honneur
industriel de la France
tu trouves que je suis moi aussi issu
d'une d'une famille de gaziers
d'électricien
oui oui mais je la suis je l'assume
pleinement je l'assume pleinement et
j'en suis plutôt fier que le contraire
c'était mon entreprise c'était mon
entreprise donc je vais en parler
avec un peu d'émotion et beaucoup de
respect
pour vous dire que ce à quoi on assiste
par la volonté du gouvernement
c'est d'abord
l'assemblée l'affaiblissement du pacte
social de cette entreprise
et il faut se poser la question de
savoir pourquoi
les arguments ont été développés par les
collègues indiquant à juste titre
qu'on ne devait pas rentrer dans les
dans les grands projets auxquels la
France doit faire face en matière
énergétique avec voilà un pacte social
d'électricien de gazier affaibli c'est
évidemment et pourtant le gouvernement y
va
il y va pourquoi
il y va et ça a été aussi évoqué parce
qu'il y a un projet
de vente à la découpe
d'edfe et de ce qui reste de Gaz de
France voilà ça ça n'est jamais parti de
l'esprit des gouvernants actuels c'est
fondamental donc moi ce que je voulais
dire il faut conclure pour terminer
c'est que je soutiens les électriciens
et les gaziers qui ont commencé à se
mobiliser ils ont raison et on sera avec
eux jusqu'au bout
madame Cohen
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président vous
persistez dans votre volonté de
destruction malgré les chiffres et les
démonstrations que nous faisons depuis
le début de nos débats vrai pour le
gouvernement mais contrairement au
gazier aux électriciens mes chers
collègues vous n'affrontez pas la
tempête vous courez le dos sans mesurer
les conséquences de votre attitude
comment allez-vous renforcer
l'attractivité des métiers comment ces
intrus peuvent-elles rester attractives
alors même qu'elles ont besoin de
recruter face aux nouveaux défis du 21e
siècle comment allez-vous lutter contre
la sous-traitance en cascade qui casse
le service public et qui exige que les
IgE réparent les erreurs le manque de
formation de ces salariés qui sont
exploitées on voit bien qu'il faut une
autre logique et ce régime devrait tirer
vers le haut l'ensemble des protections
de tous les salariés vous dites monsieur
le ministre que c'est à cause du régime
spécial des IEG que les factures
énergétiques explosent vous dites qu'à
travers leur facture les Françaises et
les Français paient ce régime spécial
c'est faux
ces régimes ont toujours participé à la
solidarité nationale en reversant leurs
excédents au caisses déficitaires par
ailleurs je rappelle que ces salariés
que vous pointez du doigt cotise à
hauteur de 13% quand les salariés dans
le privé cotisés hauteur de 10%. comment
réglerez-vous cette situation monsieur
le ministre enfin ces salariés
travaillent en 3/8 il et elles sont
présents à toute heure dans les
installations pourtant vous les pointez
du doigt vous avez dit que ce régime
pesait 1,7 milliards or vous avez fait
cadeau de centaines de milliards au
grand patron sans aucune contrepartie
chercher l'erreur
merci monsieur le Président comme le
rappelle les premiers concernés les
électriciens les gaziers de près de 157
entreprises de la branche des
IEG il est impensable de faire cohabiter
d'origine outre l'injustice les nouveaux
embauchés qui devront effectuer les
mêmes tâches que leurs collègues mais
avec un régime différent c'est
travailleur et travailleuses savent bien
que c'est la disparition assurée et
assumée de leur statut comment
pouvez-vous nier la dégradation rapide
de l'équilibre entre cotisant actifs et
retraités qui sera un énième prétexte
pour remettre en cause les dispositifs
statutaires or ce statut et ses régimes
spéciaux de retraite
et de sécurité sociale camieg sont la
juste contribution sociale du aux agents
qui assure le service public de
l'énergie
365 jours par an 24 heures sur 24 par
tous les temps pour la nation et les
usagers mais encore une fois encore une
fois sous couvert de soi-disant m'a
quitté on supprime ré ce régime pionnier
qui prend en compte la pénibilité avec
des anticipations de départ pour tirer
tout le monde vers le bas votre
véritable crainte c'est justement que ce
régime sert de modèle à d'autres et je
me souviens dans mon département il y a
peu des salariés mobilisés jour et nuit
suite à une tornade dans les villages
autour de Billancourt et je vois encore
le ministre d'armanin venir le cœur sur
la main
finalement
félicité et bien comme ça a été dit tout
à l'heure par d'autres collègues les
pompiers mais également les agents EDF
et puis aujourd'hui et bien finalement
pour seule récompense ce que vous
présentez monsieur le ministre avec vos
collègues de droite et bien c'est de
supprimer le régime de ces agents je
trouve cela quand même assez scandaleux
joli
le ministre mes chers collègues je dois
vous faire part de mon étonnement de
voir le gouvernement proposer la
suppression du régime de retraite des
agents des industries électriques et
gazières au-delà de ce qui a déjà été
dit sur leur engagement sur la qualité
de leur activité et de leur action d'une
manière générale est-il de bonne
temporalité de susciter des crins des
aigreurs et en tout cas une
déstabilisation des agents de ces
industries à travers cette proposition
alors qu'il y a des sujets sur l'énergie
beaucoup plus essentielle pour notre
pays saint-s souveraineté et la réponse
à apporter au risque qui pèsent sur
l'humanité avec notamment les
conséquences de la guerre en Ukraine
ainsi que les évolutions du paysage
géopolitique avec les sujets
environnementaux et notamment de
décarbonation que nous devons affronter
notre pays a besoin de paix sociale pour
que les Français là où ils sont là où
ils agissent puissent le faire le plus
utilement possible pour affronter ces
défis je voterai donc en conséquence
pour tout amendement qui prévoit le
maintien du régime de ce régime spécial
je vous remercie
monsieur le Président guitare
oui merci merci monsieur le Président
effectivement ces amendements sont
importants et c'est vrai que je m'étonne
beaucoup que ça fasse pas plus débat et
qu'on n'est pas plus d'intervention de
ce côté-là parce que ça a été rappelé on
est quand même au cœur d'un enjeu
fondamental la question énergétique la
question climatique sur lequel
d'ailleurs vous n'avez aucune visibilité
et pourtant vous décidez justement dans
ce cet enjeu particulier de revenir sur
ce régime des IEG mais on sait
évidemment que derrière cette
suppression du régime bah il a
suppression d'un statut et ça a été
rappelé un statut créé en 1946 et un
statut qui a pas été créé pour rien
parce que justement la question
énergétique elle est fondamentale elle
est au cœur au cœur de notre pays on a
besoin de cette indépendance de nos de
nos fonctionnaires des gens qui
travaillent justement pour cette
question énergétique et les avantages de
ce statut ça a été dit aussi permet
d'attirer de fidéliser dans une
profession à la fois difficile et
usante et maintenant aujourd'hui on se
couperait de ça nous sommes bien dans un
dans un jeu de domino après le régime
spécial ça sera évidemment la
destruction du statut et vous l'avez
d'ailleurs très bien dit Monsieur le
Ministre puisque vous avez donné
l'exemple de la SNCF dont on commence à
voir les résultats et de la même manière
il y aura cette vente à la découpe qui a
été très bien expliqué alors moi je me
pose la question en fait quel est quel
est ce but ce but de destruction de vos
services qui se font de nos services
publics qui se font un par un qu'est-ce
qui vous gêne en fait dans ce dans ce
régime que des gens est une bonne
protection que des gens puissent faire
leur métier correctement qu'est-ce qui
se vous gêne à part une petite politique
comptable ou alors justement plutôt
votre dogmatisme libéral et que à cette
seule fin vous voulez détruire un par un
l'ensemble de nos services publics
merci madame monsieur Lecomte
voilà il est 19h45 nous sommes en direct
sur antenne de Public Sénat j'accueille
ici Yann chanterrel bonjour bonjour vous
êtes sénateur socialiste des Français
établis hors de France un mot avec vous
on arrive vers la fin de cet après-midi
de débat à un conçu depuis 14h30 sur
l'antenne de publics qu'est-ce que ça
vous évoque vous ce débat on a entendu
d'ailleurs que même dans votre propre
camp il y a une forme de frustration une
forme de monologue en fait que vous
regrettez en fait oui absolument en tout
cas on constate depuis le début de ces
débats qui manque une partie de notre
hémicycle qui est son côté droit qui est
incroyablement absent qui ne dit rien
qui ne dit mot alors que qui ne dit mot
peut-être consent par rapport à
peut-être qu'on est en train de les
convaincre je ne sais pas mais c'est
vrai c'est assez surprenant parce que à
la base nous sommes des parlementaires
nous sommes là pour échanger pour
débattre c'est un sujet majeur dans
notre pays qui préoccupe dans toutes les
discussions de nos compatriotes et de
voir une droite amorce en quelque sorte
qui ne répond pas c'est assez
particulier on va dire en tout cas vous
avez pu le constater nous la gauche oui
nous sommes là vous êtes nous sommes
présents très mobilisés vous allez poser
des dizaines d'amendements vous réalisez
des dizaines d'explications de vote dans
l'hémicycle c'est quoi votre stratégie
c'est de montrer qu'il y a une
contestation dont vous faites les causes
c'est cela c'est de montrer qu'il ne
contestation qui n'est pas entendu
puisque ça fait des semaines que les
Françaises et les Français manifestent
pacifiquement et qu'il ne se passera
rien je pense que ça véritablement parce
que le gouvernement n’entend pas bah
nous nous prenons toutes les moyens
possibles de notre droit de
parlementaire pour représenter ces
Français et ses françaises qui se
mobilisent pour discuter des sujets
justement du fond nous mettons tout sur
la table et nous discutons directement
des enjeux liés à cette à cette mesure
particulièrement brutale mais quelle est
la nuance entre ce que vous faites et de
l'obstruction parlementaire en fait
c'est pas de l'obstruction à partir du
moment dépose des Normands qui est notre
droit le plus formel certains ont
vraiment les copier-coller les uns des
autres non c'est pas c'est pas des
copier-coller vous voyez on argumente en
argumente sur des sur des sujets de
fonds vous pouvez regarder et
permettra la pression sur cette droite
sénatorielle pour qu'on puisse justement
faire en sorte que cette réforme soit
retirée il y a une rumeur qui bruisse
dans les palais dans les couloirs du
Palais du Luxembourg c'est le fait que
l'on pourrait aller vers un examen de
l'article 7 celui sur la mesure d'âge le
soir du 7 mars donc comme si bien la fin
des manifestations on pouvait brancher
Public Sénat et suivre les débats toutes
les article 7 vous confirmez que c'est
ce qui pourrait se jouer alors je peux
pas vous confirmer en tout cas on fera
tout pour que ça n'est pas lieu avant la
journée de mobilisation ça c'est certain
mais par contre nous nous l'avons
toujours dit depuis le début nous
souhaitons sur cet article 7 un débat
pour que les Français puissent juger on
demandera un scrutin public comme ça les
change les Français pourront voir de
manière transparente qui vote quoi par
rapport à cette réforme je pense que
c'est essentiel qui défend quoi et qui
vote quoi et on a bien compris qu'avec
l'excuse un public on pouvait voir
l'intégralité des votes dans l'hémicycle
est-ce que vous pensez qui pourrait y
avoir des voix dans la droite et du
centre de la Voie de la majorité c'est
natale qui manquerait à l'appel lors du
vote sur cet article 7 et mesure d'âge
ben écoutez il faut l'espérer avoir des
débats ça sert aussi à ça ça sert à
pouvoir convaincre justement l'autre
banc de l'hémicycle pour leur dire à
quel point cette mesure est injuste les
mobilisations et le combat que nous
menons actuellement dès l'hémicycle
ajustement pour but de faire en sorte
que nous puissions gagner la bataille et
bien merci merci pour cette réaction au
micro
Ian chanterelle vous êtes sénateur PS
des français établi hors de France Merci
Merci à VOUS
cert protecteur mais sur d'un secteur
qui est extrêmement stratégique et
encore plus maintenant il est critique
alors il y a des scénarios qui sont plus
précis que que ceux du corps est plus
inquiétant pour l'avenir ce sont ceux du
GIEC et on a étudié ici plusieurs choix
énergétiques plusieurs textes qui
portaient sur l'énergie mais quel que
soit nos choix quel que soit les
directions qu'on prendra à l'avenir dans
l'énergie on aura besoin de l'expertise
et de l'expérience des IEG
et vous décidez de fragiliser
aujourd'hui ce secteur au lieu de
renforcer l'attractivité vous
affaiblissez nos métiers d'avenir votre
réforme elle est déjà à rebours du
progrès social elle est aussi maintenant
à rebours des enjeux du siècle des
enjeux climatiques en désarmant la
France face aux enjeux d'avenir face aux
enjeux énergétiques vous tirez une
nouvelle fois notre pays vers le bas
des systèmes de contrôle voire des
pénalités pour tous ces opérateurs en
cascades qui étaient là pour intervenir
là où aurait pu intervenir des personnes
compétentes on a fait d'autres choix
donc
sans parler en plus de l'inégalité
territoriale je pense que ce modèle là
que vous voulez demain c'est installer
pour nos territoires une véritable
inégalité l'accès ne sera pas garantie
de la même façon partout comme il peut
l'être aujourd'hui avec les personnes
qui ont ce statut donc oui il faut
rejeter ces amendements qui permettent
qui vont qui vont permettre de remettre
en question ce qui est fondamentale pour
les territoires
si Monsieur
le Ministre merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président dans un sourire je voudrais
juste te dire monsieur sénateur qui
vient d'intervenir que je suis d'accord
avec lui puisqu'il a conclut son
intervention disant qu'il fallait
rejeter les amendements et mais j'ai cru
comprendre que c'est une confusion et je
disais avec un sourire puis sérieusement
je voulais répondre à l'interpellation
directe de la présidente sur deux points
madame la Présidente d'abord le premier
vous m'avez interrogé sur le fait que
dans l'étude d'impact dans les
différentes fiches d'impact que nous
avons remises avec la présentation du
PLFSS rectificatif vous dites à raison
que dès la fin de 2023
salariés serait Verseau régime général
les nouveaux embauchés et que ce serait
autant de d'inscription en moi auprès du
régime spécial et vous inquiétez pour la
pérennité du financement du système j'ai
eu l'occasion de le dire tout à l'heure
mais je le répète bien volontiers y
compris comme engagement du gouvernement
au bon nous avons d'une part informé
signaler notifié à toutes les
entreprises concernées par une réforme
du régime spécial enflux que nous sommes
évidemment engagés à garantir la
pérennité financière et le financement
des retraites à verser que ce soit les
retraites des retraités actuels comme
les retraites de celles et ceux qui
gagneront l'âge de la retraite en
continuant à bénéficier du régime
spécial dans le cas de la clause de
grand-père c'est ce que nous avons fait
dans un contexte un peu différent
puisqu'il y avait fermetures du statut
et pas seulement du régime général pas
seulement du régime d'assurance
vieillesse dans le cas du pacte
ferroviaire et à titre d'exemple puisque
cela avait sera discuté à l'occasion des
lois de des lois financières et il y
aura il y a pardon pour le pacte
ferroviaire des transferts entre la CNAV
et le régime spécial pour garantir ce
financement et dont je répète bien
volontiers devant nous engagement et
pris engagement été pris auprès des
entreprises d'assurer la soutenabilité
le financement des régimes spéciaux tant
qu'ils auront des retraites à verser à
des assurés qui relèvent du régime
spécial retraités actuel ou tes avenir
la deuxième chose que je veux souligner
madame la Présidente et je pense que le
président Retailleau ne m'en tiendra pas
rigueur c'est sur la question de
l'amendement que le président a déposé
après l'article 7 puisque de manière
organique qui relève de cette partie-là
du texte sur une accélération de du
régime de convergence et donc de la mise
en œuvre ou de maintien de ce qu'on
appelle la clause de grand-père je sais
que le président Retailleau dépose de
manière assez systématique cet
amendement et j'en souligne à la fois la
constance mais j'ai eu aussi l'occasion
de dire de manière publique avant que
nos débats commencent ici que le
gouvernement n'était pas favorable ne
sera pas favorable nous l'exprimerons
lorsque l'amendement sera examiné mais
vous m'avez posé la question directement
j'apporte une réponse tout aussi directe
et enfin monsieur le Président si vous
me permettez un mot pour dire à Madame
Cohen que à aucun moment je n'ai dit que
la CTA était responsable de l'explosion
des factures énergétiques j'ai dit par
contre que c'est une taxe affectée payée
par l'ensemble des consommateurs et donc
au travers des consommateurs par les
contribuables mais je n'ai pas fait le
lien entre la situation que nous
connaissons d'augmentation du prix
d'énergie et la CTA puisque celle-ci est
redoutablement stable et enfin j'utilise
parfois et le moins souvent possible les
mots influés stocks n'ont pas que
j'ignore
la le fait que nous parlions de
travailleurs de d'assurer et d'être
humain mais parce que nous avons de
manière assez générale peut-être est-ce
un défaut de nos langages de débats ou
de langage préparatoire cette habitude
pour bien discerner bien différencier ce
qui relève des nouveaux retraités des
nouveaux embauchés de ceux qui
bénéficient d'une session actuelle
maintenant nous passons scrutin public
trois scrutins publics et tout d'abord
sur les amendements identiques 345 et
suivant le scrutin est ouvert
deux fois défavorable de la commission
et du gouvernement
voilà un nouveau scrutin public que vous
pouvez suivre sur l'antenne de Public
Sénat je rappelle la règle au lieu de
voter à main levée il y a un vote
électronique qui est assez rapide
puisqu'il est presque terminé et donc on
va avoir comme cela et bien la
cartographie du vote de l'ensemble de
l'hémicycle qui a s'afficher sur les
écrans du Sénat va pouvoir voir un site
comme on voter tous les groupes au sein
du Sénat c'est ce que tu es un public
qui sont utilisés pour ralentir l'examen
de la réforme des retraites notamment
par les groupes de gauche qui déposent
un des demandes de scrutin public depuis
le début de la journée sur les mesures
phares du texte donc sur tout elle est
différent et bien régime spéciaux qui
sont examinés au fur et à mesure de cet
article 1 de la réforme des retraites je
vous laisse suivre la fin de ce vote et
on se retrouve juste après on se
rapproche de l'heure de 20h qui est
l'heure habituel de suspension des
travaux pour et bien la pose dîner et
donc on va pouvoir faire ensuite un
petit point sur le bilan de la journée
qui s'était coulée puisque nous sommes
en direction d'antenne depuis Xena
depuis 9h30 ce matin quand on va pouvoir
voir comme ça un peu tout ce qui s'est
passé une fois que ce scrutin puis que
ce sera achevé on va écouter la fin du
vote on revient juste après
le scrutin est clos
résultat du scrutin votant 344 exprimé
340 pour 98 contre 242 le Sénat n'a pas
adopté
scrutin public portant sur l'amendement
3964 toujours demandé par le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen le
scrutin est ouvert
voilà un nouveau scrutin public vous le
voyez la gauche puisque ce sont les
communistes qui demandent ces scrutin
public pour ralentir l'examen de la
réforme des retraites c'est comme ça
qu'on le comprend et aussi pour que
chaque sénateur est bien est à s'engager
sur son vote puisqu'il est ensuite
publié au Journal officiel et on le voit
c'est
écologique communiste ou encore
socialiste et qui multiplie et bien ces
armes parlementaires qui dont ils
disposent au Règlement du Sénat il les
utilise tous entre dépôts d'amendements
massif prise de parole sur des
explications de vote on le voit comme ça
le tout sur un ton certes très feutré
comme c'était l'habitude au Sénat mais
donc avec quand même de façon assez
massive sur cet article 1 allez on va
écouter les résultats de ce scrutin
public français
98 contre 241 n'est pas adopté
et nous passons au troisième scrutin
public pour l'amendement 3937 présenté
par le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen écologiste